EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING TONIGHT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS SONORA
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. TODAY
SENATOR PAN WILL BE JOINING US
IN PERSON- AND WE WILL HAVE NO
OTHER SENATORS IN THE COMMITTEE
OR PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ANY ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YES EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO RECOGNIZE IT
EASIER RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING FOR
YOUR LIFETIME YOU. PLEASE SELECT
ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING ALL RIGHTY PERSONAL PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE
DONE WHEN TRACKING TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL. DISTANCING
CAN BE MAINTAINED. I WILL BE
USING A TELECOM. OF FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY ALSO. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND NOW AND THE
ACCESS CODE. AND I WILL ALSO
TELL YOU THAT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE THREE SIX
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
THREE THREE FIVE. ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND OR COMMITTEE. WEBSITE WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY AMAT MODERATOR TO
DIAL ZERO THEN ONE. ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU TO AN
ONLINE NUMBER. THIS COULD BE A
SHORT WAIT MUCH RECEIVE YOUR LAN
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE.
FOR THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THIS TIME YOU'LL BE ON
READ AND YOU WILL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR CLEARLY
TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL ROUTE MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS OR CONNECTIONS.
MUTED I WILL NOTE THAT- DOCTOR.
CENTER DR PAN HAS JOINED US- IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. IN THE
BEGINNING THERE. HEARING I WAS
GONNA GO OVER WHAT WE WILL BE
COVERING TODAY. IN THE GOVERNOR
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICE AGENCY. THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION. BERMAN OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA. IN TODAY'S HEARING
WILL ALSO ASKING DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO SPEND SOME TIME
DISCUSSING THEIR IMPLEMENTATION
OF INVESTMENTS MADE IN. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS
WILL BE DOING SOME OVERSIGHT AND
CHECKING ON IMPLEMENTATION WHILE
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT NEW IDEAS.
WILL ALSO BE ASKING DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES ONCE HE'S OVERSIGHT
DISCUSSIONS HAVE CONCLUDED TO
PRESENT ALL THEIR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS AFTER WHICH I OUR UR
DOCTOR PAN. BE AS SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANYONE OF THESE-
AND I WILL SAY THAT WHEN WE
BEGIN TO CUT PUBLIC COMMENTS WE
WILL JUST HAVE ONE MINUTE PER
CALLING WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE A-
HEART STOP TIME AGAIN TO GET US
OUT AND SAFELY AS AS POSSIBLE-
AND BEFORE WE BEGIN I'LL ASK
DOCTOR PAN IF YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS. OKAY HE DOES
NOT AT THIS TIME. SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH THE PRESENTATION AND I'LL
JUST START OFF BY SAYING I WANT
TO. THANK ALL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ALL THE STUFF
IT TOOK TO PUT THIS THIS HEARING-TOGETHER. SEEMS LIKE JUST
YESTERDAY WE WERE WE WERE HERE
AND NOW. WITH THAT WOULD BE ALL
BACK IN PERSON AND WE'RE STILL.
WE'RE STILL IN OUR RESPECTIVE-
CUBICLES WERE EVERYWHERE WE'RE
SPEAKING FROM AND SERVICE HERE
IN PERSON. TUITION BEGIN THE
THIRD YEAR OF THIS. WE
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULTY HAS BEEN. TO PROVIDE
FORCE FOR THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FOR THE STATE. OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE DURING THIS TIME SO.
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND TO ALL
THE STUFF WE DO APPRECIATE. THE
HARD WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS
AND WE- I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TODAY WITH US- IT IS.
SOMEWHAT ON SWEARING TO SEE THE
COLLECTIVE WISDOM- THAT IS A
SYMBOL BEFORE US TO TALK TODAY.
SO WITH THAT SAID WE WILL BEGIN
WITH- HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AN OVERVIEW. AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE BY MR OF PRINTED MCCARTY TO
DEPUTY SECRETARY- AND ALSO BY
MELISSA STAFFORD JONES WHO'S THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CHILDREN YOUTH
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
INITIATIVE PRINTED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN. YES THANK YOU
MANAGER CAN YOU HEAR ME I CAN'T
HEAR YOU VERY WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO I'M BRINGING
MCCARTY DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
PROGRAMME FISCAL AFFAIRS I'LL
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
AGENCY'S BUDGET- TO OUR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IS
COMPRISED OF TWELVE DEPARTMENTS.
AS WELL AS FIVE OFFICES MA'AM
KLUGE NEWLY CREATED OFFICE OF
THE CENTER DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION. AND THE OFFICE OF
MUSIC COMMUNITY RESTORATION. BOB
IN TERMS OF OUR TOTAL AGENCY
WIDE BUDGET INCLUDING OUR
DEPARTMENTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
THE TOTAL PROJECTED BUDGET IS
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL FUNDS. OF THAT
SIXTY FIVE BILLION IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. TWENTY NINE
BILLION IS FROM OTHER STATE
FUNDS AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE BILLION IS FROM ST STE. I
WAS TOTAL FUNDS BREAK DOWN 252%
OR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PREDOMINANTLY BUT
NOT EXCLUSIVELY WITH THEMEDICAL
PROGRAM. 70% OF THOSE FUNDS ARE
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. 80% OR UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. 14% A REALIGNMENT
FUNDS USED BY THE COUNTIES TO
OPERATE A REALIGN GRAMS. AND 8%
ARE OTHER EXPENDITURES IN OUR-
CHURCH. THE AGENCY IN TOTAL
INCLUDING ALL OUR DEPARTMENTS
AND OFFICES HAS JUST OVER THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS. SPECIFIC TO THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
ITSELF WE HAVE A BUDGET OF FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL FUNDS OF THAT
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION IS
UNDER THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS AND
INTEGRATION. AND WE HAVE FORTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND OR AGENCY BUDGET. THE
AGENCY HAS FIVE HUNDRED NINE
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY OF WHICH ARE UNDER THE
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
SIXTY FOUR ARE WHICH ARE UNDER
OUR SECRETARY DR GALLEY. THIRTY
THREE ARE AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
UNDER THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION. FIFTEEN
OR UNDER THE OFFICE FOUNDED THE
CENTER FOR DATA SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION AND SEVEN ARE UNDER
THE OFFICE OF SEARCHING JOHN.
THAT'S A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
OUR AGENCY WIDE BUDGET I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK THAT I WOULD
ALSO JUST. NOTE THAT I AM GOIG
TO BE PROVIDING THE OVERSIGHT
UPDATE ON OUR EQUITY LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROPOSALS ON HOW TO DO
THAT NOW OR AFTER YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE CHILDREN USED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
WHICH AVERAGE ACROSS. EACH R. I
THINK WE'LL GO AHEAD WITH THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. ANALYSTS ARE
DEPENDED YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ON
TO SIT TO EXPECTED OKAY THERE
WILL BE LIVE UP TO THE NOW OR
LATER BUT WE CAN TAKE WE CAN
TAKE A PAUSE RIGHT HERE FOR. NO
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT.
BRIEF PRESENTATION AND- RIVAS
GOOD. HI JESSICA THIS COUPLE
QUESTIONS A THE CITY OF THE OF
THE NEW CENTER FOR DATA INSIGHTS
AND INNOVATION- YEAH AND I KNOW
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER A LOT OF
DIFFERENT OFFICES. DEPRIVE YOU
HELPFUL. ESPECIALLY WITH A TITLE
LIKE DATA INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION TO PERHAPS SHARE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE INSIGHTS THAT
COME FROM THE THAT THE VARIOUS
OFFICES THAT NOW COLLECTING
DATA. THERE ARE SOME- WAY TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION AS IT
DOES REFLECT AS TO. YOU KNOW- TO
THE OFFICE PATIENT ADVOCATE AND
SO FORTH- WHAT PEOPLE'S
EXPERIENCES WITH THE WITH OUR-
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SO. I
JUST WANNA MAKE THAT COMMENT AND
THEN- ALSO APPRECIATE TO THE I
KNOW THAT MAYBE PART OF HAVING
ANSWER THIS- NO THE OFFICES IN
GENERAL WITH THE SURGEON GENERAL
LEAVING. I KNOW THERE WAS ANY-
IN TERMS OF ANY THOUGHT ABOUT.
THE SCOPE OF THE OFFICE MIGHT BE
CHANGING OUT THERE TO GET MANY
MODIFICATIONS TO THE- SUPER
DUTIES OF THAT POSITION AND
AGAIN YOU MAY NOT HAVE AN ANSWER
TO THAT RIGHT NOW BUT- WOULD
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON- WHAT DO
YOU SEE THE FUTURE OF THE
OFFICE- WITH THE DEPARTURE OF
FAT. ON DELIVERANCE WITH- DR
NADINE NADINE BURKE CAROUSEL.
JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS THAT. YES
THANK YOU CENTER SO I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING I CAN SAY ABOUT THE
DUTIES OF THIS OFFICER GENERAL
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU BUSINESS WE WORK. OUR
AND A SHORTFALL UPON ANY
INSIGHTS FROM THE DATA CENTER
STATE IN INNOVATION- ALWAYS
DECREASE YEAH YES I'M SORRY WHAT
YES WILL BE TO PUTS IF TOGETHER
FOR YOU AND YOUR STE ON ON LESS
LEARNED THAT'S THAT CITY AYE AYE
HUSBANDS. CAN YOU ALSO SPEAK A
LITTLE ABOUT THE OFFICE OF
INCOME. AT REST FIRST I CONTINUE
TO HEAR A LOT OF. IT BUT HOW THE
TRANSITION COMING. YES WE DO SO
YEAH IT IS GOING WELL SO WE HAVE
BROUGHT IN- JUDGE KATHERINE SERO
WAS THE DIRECTOR AND WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS NOW OF SCOTT'S.
HIRING STAFF SO IT IS A YOU KNOW
A RELATIVELY LARGE OFFICE OF
THIRTY THREE PEOPLE WITH THAT
AGENCY AND SO ON WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF ACTIVELY HIRING STAFF
AN ONBOARDING STAFF TO. WORK ON
OFFICE AND- WITH A LOOK AT. AND
THERE IS ENOUGH FOR IN PLACE TO
BE ABLE TO PROPERLY CARE FOR THE
YOUTH THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DURING THIS TRANSITION PERIOD I
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM. PEOPLE IN
LOCALLY THAT THERE ARE VICTIMS
THERE'S A HUGE STRUGGLE. IN
TRYING TO FIND PLACEMENTS AND
SERVICES FOR- SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS WERE CLOSING BEFORE WE
HAVE NEW ONES OPEN UP. IT'S A
VERY GOOD POINT SENATOR AND I
THINK I'M- JUST TO BE FAIR TO
THE COMPLEXITY THE SUBJECT IF
YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU BROUGHT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. ON ON SOME OF
THE LESSONS ARE BEING LEARNED IS
B. O. Y. C. R. IS BEING STOOD UP
. OKAY SEVEN COULD CHECK MY
CALENDAR NEXT WEEK- THE NEW AND
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANNA SAY
ABOUT THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION JUST BECAUSE AS YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD A- THERE'S BEEN
DIFFICULTY INTEGRATING ALL OUR
LARGE SYSTEMS- TWO CAN YOU SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. YES SO
I WOULD SAY- YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN IN INTEGRATING COMPUTER I.
T. SERVICE SYSTEMS PARTICULARLY
ACROSS MULTIPLE PROGRAMS IN IN
ALL THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
COUNTIES I THINK THEY ARE
OFTENTIMES LARGE CHALLENGES- BUT
WE ARE HAPPY TO. PROVIDE SOME
FOLLOW UP IN CONNECTION WITH THE
FOLKS FROM THE WEST SIDE TO GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE ON. THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE. BECAUSE IT
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO. TALK WITH
EACH OTHER AS WE KNOW DR. THANK
YOU AND I CAN IT'S JUST A SORT
OF ADD ON TO- SIR EDMUND- I KNOW
THAT IN THE PAST WHEN WE'VE HAD.
PRECODING WE HAD MORE TIME WE
ACTUALLY WOULD DO- MORE
OVERSIGHT HEARING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT IT SYSTEMS AND WE BRING IT
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. BUT I
THINK WOULD BE GOOD TO BE SURE
WE HAVE YOU KNOW JUST. WHERE
WHERE THINGS ARE- AND ALSO
PERHAPS AND ALSO AN ASSESSMENT
FOR THE- SIGNALED YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF LARGE I. T. WE'RE
GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ACCOUNT
HERE'S A LITTLE LATER ON BUT- WE
ALSO HAVE TILE SAWS WILL. LARGE
IT PROJECTS GOING ON AND-
USUALLY UNFORTUNATELY MAKE THE
NEWS WHEN SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS
SO- SO. LIKE TO AVOID THAT AND-
ALSO WITH- THANK YOU CAN YOU
KNOW JUST TO BE SURE WERE-
GETTING GOOD UPDATES ON WHAT'S
GOING ON THE IT SYSTEMS AND-
CLEARLY- YOU KNOW WE- WOULD NOT
LIKE TO REPEAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS- WHERE.
ANTIQUATED IT SYSTEMS LEAD
LETTER SENT TO FILL LEADERS. TO
SERVE. THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
YES SIR WE WERE HAPPY TO FOR UP
WITH YOU ON ON THE ISSUES. THANK
OKAY I SURE WE TRANSITION NOW
TO- THE- CHILDREN YOUTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
AND- LET US KNOW HOW THOSE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE INVESTMENTS
ARE ARE COMING ALONG. ANALYSTS
AT STANFORD JONES DIRECTOR OF
THE CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE AS YOU KNOW
WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
GOVERNOR AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN CREATING THAT
CHILDREN WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. CALIFORNIA IS
REIMAGINING THE SYSTEM SUPPORT
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR ALL
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AGES ZERO TO
TWENTY FIVE UTILIZING A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH. AND ENSURING
THAT YOUNG CHILDREN'S AND YOUNG
PEOPLE'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS
SUPPORTED IS KEY WE ALL KNOW TO
THEIR OVERALL HEALTH AND
WELLBEING CHECK THEIR LEARNING.
AND WE KNOW IT'S CONNECTED TO
LIFE OUTCOMES. SO WITH THIS
INITIATIVE WE ARE WORKING TO
BUILD A COORDINATED ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES RESOURCES AND
COMMITMENT TO ALL KIDS THERE ARE
TWENTY FIVE THAT WILL FOCUS ON
PROMOTING WELLBEING AND
PREVENTION OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. AND I'M ROUTINELY
SCREENING SUPPORTING AND
CIRCLING ALL CHOKED AND USE OUR
EMERGING AND EXISTING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS BOTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE. A KEY AREA OF
FOCUS FOR CALLIE CHEST IN THIS
FIRST YEAR IS LAYING THE
FOUNDATION FOR THE APPROACH TO
DOING THE WORK OF DESIGNING AND
IMPLEMENTING THAT THAT CHILDREN
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. SO THAT TOGETHER WE
CAN ACHIEVE TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE WE KNOW AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS HAVE
EMPHASIZED TO US IN RECENT
TIMES. SIMPLY ADDRESSING
INDIVIDUAL ISSUES IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE CURRENT. SITE LOOKS
JUSTIN'S. BUT IT'S SYSTEMS LOAD
APPROACH IS NEED THAT'S BACK AND
SETS UP. TO BE A MAN AND
REDESIGN. HOW THE JUST WORK AND
IN A REAL. TO THAT WE CAN BUILD
A COORDINATED INTEGRATED SYSTEM
AND THAT'S HOW THAT'S HOW WE
APPROACH THAT WORKS WORK MATTERS
IN ADDITION TO THE WEST BECAUSE
THE CHEATING DIFFERENT RESULTS
WILL TAKE DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY. OUR PLANNING WORK
OF THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS HAS
BEEN ROUTED IN THE RECOGNITION
THAT THAT SHOULD BRING YOU
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE IS
A CRITICAL APPROACH EACH MAKE
SYSTEMS LEVEL CHANGES. AND SO WE
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON THEM I'M
GUIDING APPROACHES THAT WORK.
WHAT IS A REAL FOCUS ON MOVING
UPSTREAM AND INCREASING OUR
FOCUS ON PREVENTION. FOCUSING ON
ALL CHILDREN ZERO TO TWENTY FIVE
WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THOSE
WHO BASED THE MOST SYSTEMIC
BARRIERS TO WELLNESS INCLUDING
CHILDREN YUTH COLOR LGBTQ PLUS
YOU AND LOW ICOME AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES EQUITY
IS REALLY A DEFINING FOCUS. AND
PRINCIPLE OF THE WORK. CENTERING
THE VOICE. OUR EXPERIENCES
DURING YOUTH AND FAMILIES
READING A SYSTEM WITH NO LONGER
WORK IT'S REALLY OUR OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE BEYOND SILOS AND ROUTE A
REDESIGNED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ECOSYSTEM IN CROSS SECTOR AND
CROSS SYSTEMS COLLABORATION
INCLUDING HEALTH AND EDUCATION
WHICH INCLUDES EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR TRIAL AND COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND OTHER SECTORS IN SYSTEMS
THAT HELP ADDRESS IN SUPPORT OF
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN YOU. WERE
WORKING TO TAKE A POPULATION
BASED APPROACH WE WANT
EVERYTHING THAT SURROUNDS KIDS
TO SUPPORT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
WELL BEING AND A KEYNOTE YOU
ADDRESSING THIS IS WORKING ON
AWARENESS AND STICKMAN AND
SPECIFICALLY AND. CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE AND RELEVANT WASTE.
I JUST WANNA I NOPE THAT D. IS
THESE KINDS OF ARE REALLY WHAT
ME TO WORK OF THE- YOU'D BE HERE
FOR HEALTH AND IS FIVE. VERY
HONORED TO BE PART OF THE WORK
AND I'VE BEEN IN MY WILL FOR
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF MINUTES NOW
. I HAVE MY OWN WORK
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN HEALTH
POLICY FOCUSING ON UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS SPEAKING AT
IMPROVING ACCESS TO CARE AND
HEALTH STATUS ARE PARTICULARLY
ADDRESSING HEALTH DISPARITIES.
MY ROOTS IN MY EDUCATION ARE IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SO. AND
AS I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK INCREASINGLY ONLINE. AT
BODIES OF WORK AND ALL THE
SYSTEMS LEVEL APPROACH LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN BUILD POLICY
FUNDING AND PROGRAM FRAMEWORKS
THAT ARE HOLISTIC AND INTEGRATED
THEM. I'M CHIU INCREASE IMPROVE
HEALTH AND HEALTH EQUITY AND
THAT IS THE CORE OF THE WORK AND
THE CHILDREN YOU HIT RUN HEALTH
AND STRESS AS. I SAID I'M VERY
HONORED TO BE A PART OF THAT.
TELL HHS UNDER TO. SEVERAL F. TO
DO. TO THE FRAME. FOR THE WORK
HEY WITH THE- YOU BEHAVIORAL.
STANCE ON SENSE THE CIVIC. WHERE
DEVELOPING PROJECT MANAGEMENT
PLAN A DRAFT GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE. WE'VE ALSO WORKED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF H. TO
DEVELOP SET OF MILESTONES ACROSS
THE FIVE YEARS FOR THE POLITICAL
OPPONENTS OF THE INITIATIVE. FOR
COORDINATING AND INTEGRATING
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT OF HHS.
REGULAR MEETINGS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AND CROSS DEPARTMENT
MEETINGS. WE'RE ALSO HAVING A
SERIES OF CROSS DEPARTMENTAL
PLANNING MEETINGS WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING SHOULD BLACK GENOCIDE.
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
NEED FOR COORDINATED WORK. AGAIN
GOES BACK TO THAT ISSUE AFFECT
THE CRITICALITY OF ADDRESSING
SILOS. WITH RESPECT TO
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WE ARE
MEETING WITH A RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND MULTIPLE FORMS
AND FORMATS SHOULD LISTEN AND
HEAR ABOUT THE KEY ISSUES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. TO AND STRANGE.
THIS INCLUDES A SERIES OF
MEETINGS WITH EDUCATION
STAKEHOLDERS. TO BUILD A
STRONGER UNDERSTANDING OF
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. OR NETWORK OF
HHS DEPARTMENTS ON THIS
INITIATIVE. I THINK THIS DEEPER
MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING OF HEALTH
AND EDUCATION SYSTEMS IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL TO. A
COLLABORATION THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO REALIZE THE POSSIBILITY. OF THIS INITIATIVE. WE'RE ALSO
IN THE OF. A COUNTRY STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGED PLAN HOW THE AGE WILL
STAKEHOLDER THROUGH WHAT'S
SESSION WORKSHOP. ARE THEREFORE
SPECIFIC TO THE INITIATIVE AS
WELL AS OTHER EXISTING BRANDS
SUCH AS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TASK
FORCE. INDIVIDUAL HHS
DEPARTMENTS ALSO BE DOING
DIRECT. ENGAGEMENT AND THE
AGENCY IS WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENTS TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
SUPPORT COORDINATION OF
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT SAID WE
AREN'T DUPLICATING EFFORTS ARE
CREATING CONFUSION ARE BURDEN
SEVEN. ARTICLE. ARTICLE ARE.
ALSO PARTICULARLY FOLK ON AND
YOUTH FAMILY ENGAGED WE ARE TO
AND THAT CAN GIVE IN THE WORK OF
THE INITIATIVE. WE'RE CURRENTLY
MEETING WITH ORGANIZATIONS WITH
EXPERTISE AND YOU DON'T NEED FOR
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND WE
WILL BE UTILIZING THE INSIGHTS
WISDOM THE ADVICE FROM THOSE
CONVERSATIONS CHIU SHAPE AS-
ECSTATIC G. AROUND I'M TELLING
YOU TRANSLATE CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES IT'S PART OF OUR
PLANNING EFFORTS. AND AS WAS IN
THE A GENTLEMAN. WE ARE AND
AFTER AN INITIAL LANDSCAPING.
ALL OF NAY ISSUES NOT ONLY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE CHILDREN
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE BACK CONNECTED AND
RELATED SHE WENT ACROSS BOTH
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
EDUCATION AND BEYOND. WE SEE
THIS IS A CRITICAL TOOL FOR
COLLABORATIVE WORK AND PLANNING
GOING FORWARD. ARE ALSO. CHIU
AND ISSUED A PROCESS TO SET
SPECIFIC FIVE YEAR OUTCOMES
GOALS AND WILL BE WORKING WITH
INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDER NETWORK. I'M FOR
COMMUNICATIONS WE ARE COMMITTED
CHIU PROACTIVE AND TRANSPARENT
COMMUNICATIONS AROUND THE BURKE
AT THE INITIATIVE IN DECEMBER WE
RELEASED A AND INITIATIVE BRIEF
ON OUR WEBSITE. CURRENTLY
WORKING ON AN UPDATE THAT WILL
ALSO BE POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE
AND SENT OUT STAKEHOLDERS THAT
INCLUDES A LIST OF ALL OF THE
COMPONENTS UNDER THE INITIATIVE
A FIVE YEAR MILESTONES EACH.
OPPONENT'S ADDED UPDATE ON THE
CURRENT WORKING ACTIVITIES ARE
HAPPENING IN EACH OF THOSE. AND
LASTLY CAL HHS IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE EVALUATION OF THE
INITIATIVE WE ARE CURRENTLY
DOING BACKGROUND WORK TO INFORM
THE DEVELOPMENT AS AN ART
TEACHER SELECT AN EVALUATION
EARLIER THIS YEAR. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THESE
UPDATES AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- THANK OU AND
I WAS AT THAT REMISS IN NOT THAT
IT WILL CONTINUE- TO WELCOME TO
THIS POSITION WE HAVEN'T WE
HAVEN'T SEEN. THAT SINCE YOU
SINCE THEN WE'VE WE'VE DONE
THIS- AND I WAS READING SOME OF
YOUR BACKGROUND. IT'S JUST IT'S
QUESTIONS LIKE HOW HOW DO YOU
THINK YOUR WORK. WITH THE ROLL
OUT OF THE ACA. WILL AID YOU IN
THIS I MEAN WHAT DID YOU LEARN
NUMBER WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
FORWARD AND- HOW TO HELP. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. YES I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ARE OUT
THAT IN REGION NINE TO REALLY
ACROSS THE WEST AROUND THE
ROLLOUT OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
LESSONS I THINK THAT WORK WELL
AS DEEPLY DEEPLY I AM DEAD IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE GROUND AND IN COMMUNITIES.
AND I THINK WE KNOW THAT FOR
SYSTEMS CHANGE WORK TO OCCUR IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY WE REALLY HAVE
TO CONNECT. STATE LEVEL POLICY
FUNDING FRAMEWORKS WITH THE WORK
THAT'S HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE BI
DIRECTIONAL WORKING TOGETHER
THAT WAS CERTAINLY THE APPROACH
THAT I TOOK AND TOOK TO THE WORK
ON THE ACA IMPLEMENTATION. AND I
THINK ANOTHER IS THAT THERE HAVE
TO BE A WILLINGNESS TO STEP BACK
AND LOOK AT WHAT'S WORKING AND
MAYBE WHAT'S NOT AND WHAT COULD
BE DIFFERENT IN ORDER TO REALLY
CENTER THE CHANGE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IN TERMS OF THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. OF OUR-
OVER SERVING AND SO I THINK IN
THIS CASE THAT REALLY GOES TO
THE STATE TRAINING ON CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES. AND THEIR
EXPERIENCES IN TERMS OF. AND
SUPPORTING THEIR WELLNESS AND
HOW WE- YOU KNOW I THINK SYSTEMS
WERE CREATED IN SILOS OFTEN AND
THAT IS THE CASE HERE AND WE
HAVE WORK TO DO TO RE ORGANIZE
THOSE SYSTEMS IN A WAY THAT IS
REALLY CENTURY. I'M THE NEEDS
AND EXPERIENCES IN THE
PRIORITIES AND STRENGTHS OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH I THINK WE
CERTAINLY SAW THAT IN THE ACA
WORK WHICH IS ACT I'M- IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL CHIU FOCUSED ON
THE HUMAN LEVEL. WHAT PEOPLE'S
NEEDS ARE IN ORDER TO ENGAGE
THEM AND SYSTEMS CHANGE WORK.
AND THEN THE LAST OBSERVATION I
WOULD TAKE IT IS THAT AND IT
TAKES AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP I
TO DO THIS KIND OF WORK THAT WAS
CERTAINLY THE CASE AND ARE WORK
AROUNDS THE ACA AND I THINK
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE CASE HERE.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE INSIGHTS AND
I THINK YOU'RE I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT ON AND I THINK IT'S JUST
AS YOU'VE AS YOU ALLUDED TO THE
CHALLENGES VERY LARGE RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY AS WE TOOK WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT. ENGAGING WITH OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEMS WERE A LOT OF
THIS WORK WILL BE DONE AND IF WE
THINK ABOUT THAT. OUR SCHOOL
SETTINGS RIGHT NOW HAVE REALLY
BECOME GROUND ZERO FOR A LOT OF
THE- DIVISIBLE SIMPLY ALREADY
THAT WE'RE SEEING. AROUND UP AND
SO I'M WONDERING IF YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DEVELOP TEAMS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS THAT MAY HAVE
BECAUSE I MEAN IF WE WANT THINGS
TO BE EFFECTIVE WE HAVE TO MEET
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE. WITH
RESPECT AND IN IT AND A REAL
DESIRE TO HELP- SO ARE YOU SO I
GUESS MY I GUESS MY REAL
QUESTION IS AROUND. WE'VE HEARD
A LOT ABOUT THE BILL THE LACK OF
WORK FORCE OR THE AT THE
DIFFICULTY IN IN FINDING WORK
FORCE RIGHT NOW. HAVE YOU INCOME
THAT AS WELL AND DO YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU HAVE WHAT YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO PUT TEAMS ON THE
GROUND WHAT DO THAT LISTENING.
AND TO BE ABLE TO REALLY DEVELOP
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK AWAY THAT WE'RE REALLY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH-
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES IN WAYS
THAT ARE IT. IS EFFECTIVE FOR
THEM. IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION I THINK THAT I AM. AND
WE- WERE VERY A PERSON I AM VERY
PERSONAL AT THE TIME THAT ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO TAKE IN MY
FIRST COUPLE OF MONTHS TO REALLY
. FIFTEEN OP THE RANGE OF
CRITICAL ISSUES THAT NEED T BE
ADDRESSED AS PART OF THIS WORK
AND SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO THANK
OUR EDUCATION STAKEHOLDER
PARTNERS WHO BEAT AND HAVING A
SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH REALLY.
ENGAGING MORE DEEPLY AND
UNDERSTANDING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AS YOU SAY THERE ARE
TIMES. YEAH OUR OUR SCHOOLS WE
KNOW HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGED AND WROTE IN THE WORK
THEY'RE DOING AND I SPEAK ABOUT
PERSONALLY AS WELL MY HUSBAND IS
A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER. I AM.
AND SO I THINK OUR PARTNERSHIP
THERE IS REALLY CRITICAL SO
WE'VE BEEN WANTING TO PLAY A LOT
OF GROUND WORK AND WORK ON THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WORK ON THE
UNDERSTANDING THESE TWO SYSTEMS
THAT HELP THE- EDUCATION AND-
HOW DO THEY CONNECT TO YOUR
POINT WITH THE STATE LEVEL AND-
THE LEVEL I THINK WE WERE
THINKING ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW IS
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY CRITICAL
TO ARTICULATE. A STATE. LEVEL
FRAMEWORK WHERE. WHEN THEY
SPEAK. IS WORKING THE WAY WE ALL
. WANT AND NEED AND I WILL SAY
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE VERY.
POWERFUL ABOUT MY FIRST COUPLE
OF MONTHS IN THE WILL IS HOW
SHARED THE VISION IS AROUND THIS
WORK FROM A RANGE OF PARTNERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS THERE'S JUST
SUCH SHARED VISION ABOUT. HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO REALLY
RETHINK THIS ECOSYSTEM TO
SUPPORT THE WELL BEING OF OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. AND COMING
AT IT FROM THAT THAT
PERSPECTIVES AROUND. AND
ARTICULATING THOUGH WHY NINETY
BECAUSE SYSTEM IS WORKING REALLY
WELL WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
WHAT ARE THE FUNCTIONALITIES AND
CAPABILITIES IT HAS. AND WHAT
ARE THE SPECIFIC OUTCOMES. AND
YOU KNOW FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WITH OVER FIVE YEARS AND- ARE.
AT THE SAME TIME IT'S CLEAR THT
HAS TO BE PAIRED WITH AS YOU
STATE. I'M ARTICULATING AND
SUPPORTING THE FRAMEWORKS AND
MODELS THAT CAN BE USED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO IMPLEMENT FACT
BECAUSE NOT GONNA LOOK THE SAME
EVERYWHERE IN DIFFERENT.
PROPERTIES UNITY'S THERE WILL
STILL. CONSISTENT WITH PARTNERS
BUT EXACTLY HOW THAT ORGANIZED
THERE'S GOING TO BE SUCH. AS IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE DURATION WE
HAVE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITIES THE WORK IN THE
INDUSTRY IS TO BE CAN. TO
PARTNER WITH OUR AND- STATE. TO
OUT. WHAT OF SUPPORT OUR NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE BUILDING OF THAT
ECOSYSTEM ACROSS PARTNERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SH AND HOW DO WE
UTILIZE BOTH. THE TOOLS AND
COMPONENTS THAT ARE WITH IN THIS
AND SHOULD SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THERE'S NOT MANY OTHER
THINGS HAPPENING IN HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND EDUCATION AND
BEYOND. ALSO SEEK TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE. ARE LINKED AND
NOT SPEAKING ROCKLEDGE COMMITTEE
TO KEEP. EXPECTING C. FIELD
ABOUT THE TEMA. WE'RE WORKING ON
IT YOU I HERE COME OF MONTHS.
YEAH IT'S JUST SECRETARY AND IN
PLACE WE ARE BUILDING OUR TEAM
WE HAVE A PROJECT MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANT AND PLACED AND- I WE
WILL BE FINDING A PARTNER TO.
READ AS YOU WERE DESCRIBING THAT
THAT IT STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PARTICULARLY AROUND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE. REALLY DOING THAT AND IN
A VERY AUTHENTIC WAY AND ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE ALREADY BEEN
HEARING FROM THE EXPERT.
INTERVIEWS WE'VE BEEN CONDUCTING
WITH. ORGANIZATIONS AND LEADERS
THAT ARE DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
DOING FAMILY AND YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT WORK AROUND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS THAT. IT'S
GOING TO TAKE ENGAGING WITH A
NETWORK OF TRUSTED PARTNERSIN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND THAT I'M OUR WORK
NEEDS TO BE REALLY SUPPORTING
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS TO DO THE
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE NEED TO
INFORM THE WORK OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH HIP-HOP INITIATIVE AND
SO I DO THINK RIGHT NOW THAT WE
HAVE. WE WITH AND JUSTICE WORK.
AND AS WE BILL THAT WE'RE STILL
ABLE TO PROVIDE A I KNOW WE JUST
HAD MORE MONEY FOR MOBILES FOR
THAT BRIDGE SUPPORT I KNOW I HAD
A SUICIDE OF A JUNIOR HIGH
STUDENT MY DISTRICT THIS THIS
LAST WEEK I MEAN IT'S JUST. THE
CRISIS IS NOW- TOPICS OR DO I
JUST SAY AND SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO DR PAN
NOW- AND JUST I GUESS I GUESS
THE- THE- MY- MY LAST WORDS TO
YOU ARE JUST NOT MY LAST BUT-
THERE'S URGENCY. AND WE CAN'T
GET. LOCKED DOWN WITH PARALYSIS.
OF OVERWHELMED BY THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
TOGETHER AS WELL AS THIS YOU
KNOW. THANK YOU. DOCTOR THREE
EIGHT THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN
AND- AGAIN WELCOME. PRESHEAF YOU
COMING ON BOARD- MY BACKGROUND
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN WHO ACTUALLY
FOCUS ON CHILDREN WITH.
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND LEARNING
DISABILITIES SO SORT OF. THE ON
MY TRACK HERE- AND OF COURSE I'M
ALSO PARENTS AS WELL SO- AND I
DID FOR SO I DID WANT ME TO
START OFF BY- SO ECHOING WHAT
DOESN'T EGGMAN SAID ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES GOING TO BE'S I
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. GETTING ON
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT SO FORTH
AND CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT BUT
WE ALSO HAVE A TREMENDOUS DEMAND
RIGHT NOW NEED RIGHT NOW
CERTAINLY WAS COATED- THE
UNCERTAINTY OF THE FACT THAT WE
HAD SO MANY- YOUTH AND CHILDREN
WHO'VE LOST. CARETAKERS AND
GUARDIANS- YOU KNOW THE OTHER
STRESSES THAT THEIR FAMILIES ARE
GOING THROUGH- THERE'S CERTAINLY
A LARGE DEMAND RIGHT NOW AND SO
WELL CERTAINLY I UNDERSTAND YOU
NEED TIME TO TRY TO GET INPUT
AND SO FORTH. WE CAN ALSO SIT
STILL WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO
RUN IN PARALLEL RIGHT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE WE PROVIDE THE. KERR
EFFECT I GUESS ONE QUESTION IS
THAT. IN IN THIS PER. IS THERE
AXE S. OF THE DEMAND FOR THE
SERVICES YOU'RE PLANNING TO
PROVIDE- YOU KNOW. WE DID BUDGET
NOW THREE AND A HALF BILLION SO
IS THAT ENOUGH IS THERE SOME IS
THERE SOME EFFORT TO TRY TO
ALSO. ASSESS WHAT IS THE ACTUAL
GIVEN THE SCOPE OF WHAT YOU'RE
PLANNING- WHAT'S THE ACTUAL
DEMAND THE GOING TO BE IN ORDER
TO MEET. MEET THE NEEDS. OR
PUSHING IT BACK QUESTION THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I'M- ON THE
ISSUE OF THIS. YES BUILDING AND
AN ASSESSMENT OF WHERE THERE ARE
GAPS AND NEEDS IT WILL BE
HAPPENING WITHIN VARIOUS
COMPONENT PARTS OF THE
INITIATIVE. SO YES THAT IS PART
OF THE WORK AS WELL AS I THINK
IN OUR- CONVERSATIONS AROUND HOW
TO SUPPORT. BUILDING THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE NEEDED IN
THE COLLABORATIVE APPROACHES
THAT ARE NEEDED. AND AT LOCAL
AND REGIONAL LEVELS I THINK THAT
IS WERE ALSO THERE NEEDS TO BE
ASSESSMENT AS- BUILT INTO THIS
PROCESS OF BUILDING ECOSYSTEMS.
REALLY LOOKS AT WHERE ARE THOSE
GAPS SO WHAT ARE THOSE NEEDS SO
YES I THINK ASSESSMENT AND-
FINDING THE GAPS IS A KEY PART
OF THE WORK. IN A MONSTER
MILESTONES WHEN DO YOU EXPECT
THAT ASSESSMENT TO THE THIRD TO
BE COMPLETED- WHEN WE SHOULD
PERFORM BY. SO
IT IS NOW FEBRUARY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO- WE BUDGETED THIS AND
WILL YOU JUST CAME OUT TWO
MONTHS AGO WE BUDGETED THIS. FOR
STARTING JULY FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO READY. EIGHT
MONTHS SAID- WHEN TWO WEEKS THIS
TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU YES THERE
ISN'T ONE I STAFF THAT CREATED
THERE WILL BE ASSESSMENT WITH IN
VARIOUS. OF THE INITIATIVE
RELATED TO SPECIFIC ASPECTS OF
IT WHETHER THAT'S RELATED TO
WORKFORCE FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING FOCUSED
ON WEATHER RELATED TO
INFRASTRUCTURE OTHER PIECES THAT
ASSESSMENT PIECE IS BY A
COMPONENT WHICH AND EACH
COMPONENT IS ON A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TIMELINE IS AS YOU
KNOW BY ENABLING LEGISLATION
AROUND ACCESS. YES THAT EACH
THAT IS OUR MILESTONES FOR EACH
INITIATIVE SORT LAYS OUT THERE
TIMELINE AND PROCESS UP SO
RAPIDLY WINDY UNITED A VERY
REALIZES AND MAYBE ONE GRAND
ASSESSMENT BUT SOMETHINGI WENT
WHEN WILL YOU START GETTING A
PICTURE OF WHAT THE DEMAND IS
GOING. GOING TO BE. AND TO
DISSIPATE THAT BY. YOU KNOW THE
SUMMER. NECK FALL. I'M HAPPY TO
FOLLOW IN JUST A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL TOGETHER AROUND THE TIME
LINES AROUND SOME OF THE
ASSESSMENT COMPONENTS THAT WE
CAN OKAY ALL RIGHT AND AGAIN
THIS SPEAKS TO AND I REALIZE
AGAIN YOU JUST CAME OUT TWO
MONTHS AGO INSISTS THAT THIS IS
THE URGENCY PART RIGHT AND
TRYING TO- THE OTHER THE OTHER
QUESTION WHY FOLLOW ASK ALSO IS
THAT AND BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
MENTION IT AT LEAST IN THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL LAST YEAR. AND
I AND IT WAS A BIG PART OF
PROPOSAL ACTUAL THIS PLATFORM
THIS UNITARY PLATFORM AND
THERE'S GONNA BE A CONTRACT FROM
DCS TO IN FACT I THINK I ASKED
ABOUT WILL WHO YOU KNOW IS THERE
AN EXISTING MODEL THAT WE'RE
PURSUING. FOR THIS PLATFORM
THAT'S GOING TO BE THIS UNIFYING
YOU KNOW I. T. PLATFORM TO DO IS
THAT STILL BEING PURSUED IT IS
THAT- PARO IS THAT STILL PART OF
THE PLAN OR AND IF IT IS WHAT
THE PROGRESS TOWARD THAT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THAT WOULD TAKE
SOME TIME TO BRING ON BOARD. SO-
SO I JUST WONDER WHAT THE STATUS
IS ON THE ON THE PLANNING IN
TERMS OF THIS THIS PLATFORM DATA
IS GOING TO EXPOSE UNDERLIE MANY
OF THE EFFORTS AND- AND THEN.
PROVIDE SIR THE INFORMATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION YES THE- PASSPORT IT'S
A PART. PART THE CHILDREN YOU.
SHOULD YOU NOTED. GOING TO HELP
CARE SERVICES A LEADING THE TO.
OF THAT. AND SO THEY ARE DEVELOP
A- BROKE WORK PLAN AROUND. THE
DEVELOP AND ULTIMATELY. OF THE-
VIRTUAL PLATFORM OKAY FIVE GIVE
ITS KEY ROLE THE SENATE ORIGINAL
CONCEPTION AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE AT THE END OF
TIMELINE ON THAT AND WHEN WE
EXPECT THAT TO BE YOU KNOW. UP
AND RUNNING OR- EARLY STILL WHAT
THE SO. AT LEAST THE IS THE
SENATE IT'S A- ITERATION. PLAYED
A PRETTY KEY ROLE AND TYING
THINGS TOGETHER SO I THINK WOULD
BE IMPORTANT AND ALSO WE ARE
WHICH- IS THE LAST YEAR BUT SORT
OF FOLLOW UP IS YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT IS WHAT EXISTING MODELS I
MEAN RETREATING SOMETHING
COMPLETELY BRAND NEW WHICH OF
COURSE IS HAS ITS OWN
CHALLENGES. BUT I MEAN HOPEFULLY
WE'RE BASING IT ON. OTHER
PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
THAT WE CAN POINT TO SET THIS IS
HOW THIS THING WOULD WORK SO I
APPRECIATE IF WE CAN GET TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT. YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUR SERVICES WE
CAN WORK WITH THEM TO BRING YOU
MORE INFORMATION ON THAT BUT
THEY ARE DOING. BACKGROUND IN
PLANNING WORK THAT DOES INCLUDE
LOOKING AT A RANGE OF EXISTING
MODELS BUT LESSONS ARE TO BE
PARKED. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO. YOU
HAVE A TIME ASSOCIATED WITH.
OKAY YES I MEAN AGAIN BECAUSE OF
THIS IS GONNA BE A KEY QUOTE
FOR. OF IT TENURE KNOXVILLE A
LOT OF YOU DON'T A PLATFORM
RIGHT- IS THAT. BEHIND. THIS IS
. IT AND YOU KNOW YOU DID
MENTION WORK FOR- WE KNOW WE
HAVE. WE HAVE A OTHER PARTS OF
THE BUDGET. INCLUDING BY THE
PARTS CAN BE TALKING ABOUT
LEADERS IN THE VERY HEARING IS
ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE. ROLE COURSE
CENTER. I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T TRAIN. A. B.
HEALTH SPECIALIST INSTANT. AND
FOR. ARE IT TAKES A LOT OF.
TIMES SKILLED TO TRAIN SOMEONE
UP- THE- IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
MAXIMIZE- PEOPLE PEOPLE WHAT
WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE ROLE
OF PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS WHO
ALREADY HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
FAMILIES- WE DO HAVE TRAINING IN
MENTAL HEALTH. AS PART OF OUR
TRAINING BOTH NOW WITH FOUR
YEARS OF MEDICAL SCHOOL THREE
YEARS OF RESIDENCY SO HAVE BEEN
AROUND YOU KNOW BEFORE YOU BEGIN
TO PRACTICE. WHAT HE SEES THE
ROLE OF PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
IN- HELPING ADDRESS MANY ISSUES
BEING- THEM NOW OF COURSE YOU DO
SO THAT FAMILY PHYSICIANS
PEDIATRICIANS LIKE MYSELF- HOW
DO THEY FIT IN AND HOW WE
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS INITIATIVE. YEAH THANK
YOU FOR QUESTION TIME YES SO AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COMPONENTS
RELATED CHU IN THE HEALTH
SETTING THE WAYS IN WHICH
PRIMARY CARE. PROVIDERS AND
PEDIATRICIANS ARE A PART OF THE
INITIATIVE SO I'M ONE OF THOSE
AS YOU KNOW IS ACTUALLY RELATED
TO THE VIRTUAL POP YOU WERE JUST
ASKING ABOUT HAD THAT. VIRTUAL
PLATFORM INCLUDES. I'M AROUND
BEING ABLE TO CONNECT. BITERS
WITH SPECIALIST IN IN THE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHILD
PSYCHIATRY TO REALLY SUPPORT I
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS IN AND
PEDIATRICIANS AND TREATING THEIR
PATIENTS SO THAT PEACE IS BUILT
AND IT WILL BE PART OF THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM SH I YOU MAY
RECALL ALSO A PART OF THE
CHILDREN U. ZERO HEALTH
INITIATIVE IS THE ADDITION OF A
DYADIC HERE BENEFITS SHE ADDED
HEALTH PROGRAM. REALLY SUPPORT
IN. THE CHILD BUT ALSO WHAT WE
KNOW THEIR CARE AND CARE GIVER
AND THEIR WELL BEING AND A
RELATIONSHIP THERE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT CHU AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH INSPECTION ON THE STREET
WHILE BEING IN. ACTOR BUT IF IS
ANOTHER REALLY AND PIECE OF THE
PIE. CARE ASK OF THE- SHE AT
THAT IS YOU KNOW THERE'S ALSO I
AM. WORK HAPPENING THIS IS- AND
THAT IS THIS IS CONNECTED. IN
TERMS OF THE SURGEON GENERAL'S
WORK AROUND A SOMEWHERE. AND
REALLY SUPPORTING I HAVE PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS IN TERMS OF EACH
JUST SCREENINGS AND OBVIOUSLY
THAT IS ENACTED ALTERNATELY
DEPARTMENT WHICH- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. NUMBER WORK AT BECAUSE
ACTION THAT ARE REALLY. I
THOUGHT AWAY AS WELL. OKAY NOW
I. THAT I IT CERTAINLY. THE WORK
OF THE GENERAL IN THE ACE PRO
WHICH SALAS COURSE THAT PROCEEDS
- THIS UPPER. AND I THINK THAT
AND UP. I WOULD MAKE NO THAT WE
DENTAL BEAR TO PRIMARY CARE FOR.
BE ABLE TO HELP AND PARTICIPATE
- SOMETIMES OF BILLING ISSUES
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT FORMALLY OF.
MANUAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL THERE'S ISSUES
THERE YOU TALK ABOUT THE ATTIC
CARE. YOU KNOW THE PEDIATRICIAN
OF ANY TEACHERS MEDICAL
LIABILITY. REFORM THAT ALLOWS ME
TO. NOT GET SUED FOR PROVIDING
CARE TO APPARENTLY ON OUR-
REFERRING YOU KNOW THE PARENTS
FOR CARE- THAT THAT THAT. THAT
SO SOME OF THOSE HOPEFULLY WILL
ADDRESSED AS WELL- SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY- DO THE KIND OF-
WORK THAT BEING ENVISIONED. AND
THEN- SO AND THEN I GUESS THE
OTHER JUST A FINAL QUESTION AND-
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE MORE AS FOR
THIS PROGRAM OF ALDEN AGAIN VERY
VERY EXCITED ABOUT IT. AS
SOMEONE WHO'S- VERY. INTERESTED
IN THIS FIELD- HELLO WE ARE FOR
ON THIS IS FOCUS ON YOU CHILL
AND YOUTH. NOW ARM YOU KNOW WE
SERVE HAVE OR MENTAL SYSTEM IS
KIND OF. WE HAVE A COUNTY. RIGHT
AND THEN WE HAVE. WE HAVE SOME
THE SCHOOL AND HE ICE TO BE A
SCHOOL FOR- MET CONSOLE FOR MY
LOCAL SCHOOL THIS- HOW HOW YOU
SEE. SORT OF BRIDGING. SERVICE
WE- THE BE OF SERVICE COUNTY MAY
HEALTH WHERE A LOT OF THE DEBT.
MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS CHANNELED
THROUGH. MANY OF SCHOOLS. HOW DO
YOU SEE BRIDGING. THE SCHOOL AND
COUNTY A SPACE IN TERMS OF
MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY. AND AND
INVITING THE SILO THAT SOMETIMES
EXISTS BETWEEN THE TWO. YES IT
DOES I MEAN THAT IS THE HEART OF
THE WORK THE INITIATIVES THAT
SUCH AN IMPORTANT QUESTION. I
THINK IT ACTUALLY THAT'S THE
FIRST STARTING ZERO IS THIRTY TO
BUILD WAS RELEASED. AND
PARTNERSHIPS. AS YOU KNOW THERE
ARE SOME KEY. AT THE INITIATIVE
THAT ARE STILL BASED ON.
PROVIDING RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
WHAT WERE AND THE PARTNER AND
PROJECTS THAT COME OUT OF THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN ALL OF THE
CRITICAL. AND ELEMENTS OF THE
SYSTEM AS YOU WERE DESCRIBING
BOTH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SCHOOLS THEMSELVES ELEAZAR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION ALSO
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
REALLY LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
BUILD NOT ONLY DOES THE
INDIVIDUAL INFRASTRUCTURE EACH
COLLABORATIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
BETWEEN THEM. AND DOING SO IN A
WAY WHERE WE ARE REALLY CENTURY
WHAT WE ARE HEARING FROM
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
YES I THINK. WE ARE WE NEED TO
BUILD. OUR SHIPS AND
COLLABORATION AROUND THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE BRINGING PEOPLE
AROUND THE TABLE SO TO SPEAK
THAT ORIGINAL TABLE. TO REALLY
IDENTIFY WHERE ARE THIS IS A KEY
PART OF OUR STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WORK WHERE ARE THOSE
SILOS WHERE ARE THE BARRIERS TO
GREATER INTEGRATION AND GREATER
COLLABORATIVE WORK AND THEN HOW
DO WE ADDRESS THOSE. SO THAT
THAT REALLY IS THAT THE WORK TO
CONTACT I DO WANT TO JUST ALSO
SHARED THAT QUESTION THAT BOTH
YOU AND TERMINATE MEMORIES
AROUND. THE URGENCY OF THIS
ISSUE. AND I WANT YOU. I IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR OF ALL I
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE STATE. OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. WHICH WE
KNOW IS ACTUALLY- UNFORTUNATELY
LONG TERM CARE THESE ISSUES
WHERE WORK INCREASING
UNFORTUNATELY WELL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND WERE EXACERBATED
AND THE PANDEMIC CHECK YOUR LATE
WE ALL KNOW FOR OUR CHILDREN
USED TO COLOR LGBTQ. YOUTH AND
LOW INCOME AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AND THESE ARE LONG
TERM AND ISSUES AND CHALLENGES
THAT ARE GOING TO TAKE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AND TRANSFORMATIONS
AND WE'RE REALLY COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT HARD WORK IN THE
CHILDREN WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
AS YOU KNOW THERE HAS TO BE
HAPPENING TODAY TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES AND THAT WORK IS
HAPPENING THERE ARE THERE IS
WORK HAPPENING BOTH WITHIN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
BUT IN OTHER PARTS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT WITH OUR PARTNERS ON
THE GROUND IN COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW. AROUND REALLY ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES AND I THINK THAT
ALL THAT YOU HAVE BEEN INTEREST
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO BE
REALLY OF WORK H. THAT THERE ARE
LEAST AVAIL TO CHILDREN YOU AND
FAMILIES BUT ABOUT FIVE BONE
TAXED WEBSITE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
ONLINE RESOURCES PEER TO PEER
COUNSELING THAT IS AVAILABLE IN
SOME CASES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE THE
CALHOUN RIGHT LIKE. LINES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND WEBSITE AND
OPTIONS OUR CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES BETTER BAILABLE IN THE
MEDIA SUPPORT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. THERE IS AROUND.
REALLY THAT ARE PROVIDE AS MUCH
ACCESS AS- CHIU THE SERVER THAT
ARE. TODAY I TERMINATE WHEN
EARLIER THAT READ INVEST. IN
ABOUT IN OF HEALTH CARE SIR ON
PRICE RE. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ON GOING INVESTMENTS ALREADY AND
WAY LIKE THAT THAT ARE WORK. TO
REALLY INCREASE THE THAT WE HAVE
NOW THERE'S WAITED FOR SAM CHEAP
EVEN DURING LIKE. TO
REQUIREMENTS AND APPROPRIATE WAY
BUT I CAN OF OUR OUR STRATEGY
HAVE. TO BE ABLE TO DO AND OF
SERVICES AND BABY LAST TIME ON
THE DOCKET. ISSUES I'M STILL
WORKING THAT WERE MADE IN THE
BUDGET LINE YEAR IS YOU KNOW
CHIU. AND THE COURTS OF THE WORK
THAT IS ACT THE EMBLEM OF EIGHTY
AND- WORK THAT HAPPEN IN
COMMUNITIES TO DO THAT NOW SO
THERE IS. AND WORK NOW THEN
THERE'S A WORK AT YOU KNOW ALL
REALLY TO ON. AWARENESS AND
HEALTH IS AND MAP WHICH WE KNOW
WE REALLY DID IN ORDER FOR
PEOPLE TO SEEK SUPPORT PURPOSES
BY PAYING. SO THERE ARE THESE
MULTI INITIATIVES AND EFFORTS
HAPPENING NOW AS YOU SAY IN
PARALLEL WITH THE LONGER TERM
MARKET THE CHILDREN IN THE HIP
HOP. AND THE RECOGNITION OF HOW
INCREDIBLY. BOTH PART IN THAT.
HE ALSO COMMITTED SHOULD SURE
THAT THOSE. ARE IN. SO THAT WE
LEARNING FROM MUCH AND WORKING
ON THINGS THEY'RE HAPPY NOW TRUE
REALLY MAKES WERE IN. THIS
LONGER WORK. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH MAYBE TO ONE. BRIEF
ADDITIONAL COM BECAUSE IN THE
SAN- MY FRIEND CENTER. AND I'M-
PLEASE REPORT TO HIM. ON IS ALSO
TRUE TO BE SURE GET SCHOOL STAFF
PERSONNEL ALSO TRAINED SO THEY
CAN IDENTIFY USE OR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SO I HOPE THE
GOVERNOR WILL SUPPORT THAT TYPE
LEGISLATION BUT- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND I GUESS JUST. TO PUT
UP TO PUT IT TO PUT A LITTLE
RIBBON ON THIS. AS MUCH MONEY AS
WE PUT IN HERE. DIRECTOR. WHEN
DO YOU FEEL LIKE ONE THE PUBLIC
WILL WILL FEEL C. WILL FEEL THIS
MASSIVE INVESTMENT AND HOW WILL
THEY KNOW WHAT WHEN THEY SEE IT
. YEAH I'M SO ONE OF THE THINGS
WE ARE GOING TO BE WORKING ON IT
AND I MENTION THIS VERY BRIEFLY
BUT IS ACTUALLY IDENTIFYING
SPECIFIC OUTCOMES THE INITIATIVE
AT THE END OF THE FIVE YEARS AND
WE WILL BE ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS
NOT PROCESS AND INTERNALLY AND
EXTERNALLY TO REALLY HELPED
SHAPE THAT THE SPECIFIC OUTCOMES
AND THOSE OUTCOMES WILL NEED TO
BE I THINK A COMBINATION OF
LOOKING AT THE SYSTEM ITSELF AND
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM
IS IMPROVING. AND LOOKING AT
SPECIFIC OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH ON A POPULATION BASIS
AS WELL SO I THINK IT WILL BE A
COMBINATION SO WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ARTICULATE
THOSE OUTCOMES AND NOW WE ARE
GOING TO NEED TO COLLECTIVELY
WORK TOGETHER TOWARDS THEM AND
THAT WE DO AS I MENTIONED WE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR FINDING
AN EVALUATION PARTNER AND I
THINK IT IS OUR HOPE AND
INTENTION THAT THAT EVALUATION
PARTNER WELL NOT JUST- HELP US
GAUGE. OUR PRO. AFTER THE FIVE
YEARS BUT OVER THE COURSE OF THE
FIVE YEARS WE WILL BUILD IN
PLACE TO STRUCTURE. IN ORDER TO
ROUTE YOU ANSWER ASK AND ANSWER
THAT QUESTION YOU'RE RAISING
WHICH IS HOW DO WE KNOW WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS. THESE TO BUY
I'M- UNDERSTANDING FOR MY OWN
WORK AND THE RESEARCH AROUND
MAJOR SYSTEMS CHANGE
TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVES THAT
THEY GENERALLY TAKE EIGHT TO TEN
YEARS. THE ALLIES THEIR FULL
POSSIBILITY. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
PROGRESS WE CAN AND YOU NEED TO
MAKE IN THESE NEXT FIVE YEARS
AND THAT I'M- READING WITH A SET
OF OUTCOMES THAT'S GOING TO
ANCHOR AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WORK BACKWARDS FROM IS GOING TO
BE REALLY KEEP IT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
RIGHT NOW. OKAY THANK YOU AND
I'VE BEEN I'VE I THEN I YOU FEEL
AND HAVE HEARD THE URGENCY THAT
WE ALL FEEL- OKAY SHOULD WE MOVE
ON TO EQUITY IN LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROPOSALS. BRENDAN MCCARTHY WITH
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS
DESIGNED TO ALLOW THE COUNTY
TEACHERS IN OUR MEMBER
DEPARTMENTS TO MANAGE OUR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS IN A MANNER
THAT'S MORE INCLUSIVE ENACTED
PROVES THE OUTCOMES FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS ALL CALIFORNIANS SIR
RIGHT. I WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS
ON PROVIDING LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO OUR
PROGRAM BENEFICIARIES. TO THAT
END KELLY CHICHA. ESTABLISHED
THE EQUITY DIVERSE AND
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT SUBCOMMITTEE
IS CULTURE BY MARCEL RUIZ AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND ROMANCE RON RADHAKRISHNA THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE INCLUDES. HEALTH
ACT THE CHIEF EQUITY OFFICERS
FROM ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENTS. AND
THAT TOO MANY WILL OVERSEE THE
EXPENDITURE OF THESE INVESTMENTS
ACROSS THE AGENCY. I SHOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT TALLY HHS ISN'T
ACTIVELY RECRUITING FOR OUR OWN
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER TO OVERSEE
OUR EQUITY EFFORTS ARE BROADLY
ACROSS THE AGENCY. I DON'T SINCE
MAY IN THE CURRENT YEAR
INCLUDING EQUITY DASHBOARD WHICH
MY COLLEAGUE JOHN HANEY AND WILL
ADDRESS AYE HE'S UP NEXT LET'S
TALK ABOUT HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE HE WILL ADDRESS THE
EQUITY DASHBOARD IN HIS REMARKS.
INCLUDE STOP FUNDING FOR
WORKFORCE EQUITY TRAINING APP OR
AGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND SO THAT
IS BACK TRAINING FOR OUR STAFF
TO HELP IMPROVE THE RACIAL
EQUITY OF OUR PROGRAMS I AM SURE
THAT THEY ARE SERVING FOLKS IN
AN EQUITABLE MANNER IN A
CULTURALLY. AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE WAY. HI IT ALSO
INCLUDES TIME WHEN ACCESS POLICY
SO ARE- THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND SELENA EFFORTS
ACROSS OUR AGENCY. TO DEVELOP A
POLICY FOR- PLAYING WHICH ACCESS
TO OUR PROGRAMS. REALLY TO LEVEL
UP ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS SO THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING SERVICES AND
ACCESS TO OUR PROGRAMS AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE WAY.
BUT AS AN AGENCY WE PROVIDED AN
UPDATE ON THAT WORK TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT THE POLICY WILL
ADDRESS. WE ARE NOW WORKING TO
FINALIZE THAT POLICY- WE ARE
WORKING BOTH INTERNALLY ACROSS
OUR DEPARTMENTS AND ALSO WITH
THE EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDER
HOLDERS. AND WE ARE- THE PLAN IS
TO BRIEF LEGISLATURE BEFORE WE
ARE FORMALLY ADOPT THAT POLICY
TO GET THAT THE LEGISLATURE HIM
. YOUR BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. TO IMPROVE LANGUAGE ACCESS
ACROSS OUR PROGRAMS ANNOUNCED
SPENDING OF THOSE FUNDS WILL BE
GUIDED BY THE LANGUAGE ACCESS
ACCESS POLICY- THAT MONEY OTHER
WAS INITIALLY APPROPRIATED TO
THE AGENCY WILL BE TRANSFERRED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. WILL- STAFF UP TO
IMPLEMENT THE POLICY. AND IN THE
LAST- ADDITION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WAS FUNDING FOR A POST CODE
IN EQUITY ANALYSIS AS WE ALL
KNOW- THE IMPACTS OF CODE HAVE
BEEN DESPERATE ACROSS OUR
DIFFERENT. EIGHTIES AND- HAVE
HIT. HARDEST SOME OF OUR LOW
INCOME ETHNIC COMMUNITIES RURAL
AREAS OF THE STATE. AND SO WE
REALLY WANT TO TAKE A HARD LOOK
AT HOW COLD IMPACTED THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE SPONSORED. TO
LEARN LESSONS THAT WE CAN APPLY
BOTH TO OUR ON GOING OVER ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH WORK BUT ALSO OUR
PREPARATION FOR FUTURE WEATHER.
DISASTERS WHETHER THEY ARE
PUBLIC HEALTH- VERSION SEIZE OR
OTHER DISASTERS SO THAT WE CAN-
BETTER ENSURE THAT OUR RESPONSE
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
INEQUITABLE IMPACTS OF THOSE
DISASTERS. SO THAT'S AN OVERVIEW
OF OUR EFFORTS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. YOU'RE NOT
GONNA TALK ABOUT THE WORK FIRST
EQUITY TRAINING COMPONNT
CORRECT RIGHT NOW CORRECT. OKAY
IF YOU'RE REFERRING TO DEBT AND
EQUITY DASHBOARD I JOHN HEANEY
AND IT'S GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT
THAT IN THE NEXT PRESENTATION.
OKAY OKAY UNDER TRUMP. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I DO
APPRECIATE THIS- FOCUS ON-
EQUITY AND LANGUAGE ACCESS SAYS-
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS-
LANGUAGE ACCESS IS A- IS A
GREAT. BIG BERRIER FOR OUR
COMMUNITY HAND- AND OFTENTIMES
WE ARE TOLD THAT WELL WE SPEAK
TOO MANY LANGUAGES BECAUSE- YOU
CAN'T JUST DO ONE LANGUAGE YOU
GOT THERE'S A LOT OF LANGUAGES-
SO THE COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANTED
TO- TO ASK ACTUALLY. AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THIS EFFORT- SO- WHEN
IT COMES TO- CONNECTED I USUALLY
LIKE THE WORD USE THE WORD
INTERPRETING NOT TRANSLATING
BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES WHEN YOU
HAVE A LITERAL TRANSLATION IT
DOESN'T NECESSARY CONVEY. THE
INFORMATION THAT PEOPLE NEED-
THOSE WERE LOOKING AT- SO FIRST
OF ALL I SEE A LOT OF THINGS
ABOUT DOCUMENTS AND WEBER YOU
KNOW WEB PAGES AND SO FORTH- BUT
WE ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF- THAT
ONE- JUST LIKE ACTUALLY IN
ENGLISH THERE MAY BE SOME
LITERACY ISSUES RIGHT SO. YOU
KNOW IT'S WHAT'S THE GRADE LEVEL
RATE HOW IS IN THESE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES LIKE ARE WE USING
LANGUAGE OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND. EVEN IF IT IS A YOU
KNOW IT IT IS IT IS TRANSLATED
RIGHT SO WHAT IS THE- YOU KNOW
HOW COMPREHENSIBLE IS IT AFTER
IT'S BEEN TRANSLATED SO IS THAT
IS THAT BEING ASSESSED. AND THE
OTHER ISSUE IS THAT FOR SOME
LANGUAGES AT LEAST A- THEY'RE
NOT REALLY I MEAN. THEY CAN BE
WRITTEN BUT THERE USUALLY MORE
OR ALSO. THAT WE PROVIDE.
ALTERNATIVE WAYS THAN SIMPLY- A
YOU KNOW A DOCUMENT THAT'S
TRANSLATED. AND THEN AND THEN OF
COURSE THE OTHER PART SO
APPRECIATE TRYING TO MAKE
DOCUMENTS KEY DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
AND SO FORTH. WHEN IT COMES TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS IT'S NOT JUST
THE DOCUMENTS IT'S BEING ABLE TO
INTERACT SO YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT WE HAVE A OFFICE A PATIENT
ADVOCATE THAT'S AN INSIDE
STRAIGHT WHEN THEY CALL CAN I
GET SOMEONE OF THESE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES. WHEN THEY NOTICED IT
AND I THINK AS TO WHAT THE HEART
OF WHAT TO- EGGMAN ASTOR. ABOUT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HELPING. TO
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND WHEN THEY
SEE THIS DO THEY KNOW YOU KNOW
THAT THIS INVESTMENTS IT IS THAT
THE DAY ACTUALLY CAN GET ACCESS
RIGHT I MEAN IT'S ULTIMATELY.
WHAT THAT MEANS SO- PERHAPS CAN
YOU TOUCH ON- YOU KNOW TERMS OF
NOT ONLY IS IT BEING. TRANSLATED
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY BEING
INTERPRETED AND IT'S BEING DONE
AT YOU KNOW AND THAT THAT IT'S
TOUGH TO FOR COMPREHENSION AND
IN THAT LANGUAGE. AND THEN ALSO
. THE SIMPLY. WRITTEN THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO. US WITH. SO THAT-
NEWS AGAINST LANGUAGE- MAYBE TO.
FOR ISN'T A- THE BEST WAY TO
CONVEY. THE INFORMATION. THANK
YOU DR PANDA X. QUESTIONS AND
YOU KNOW I'M STARTING WITH THAT
TRANSLATION BOERSE'S
INTERPRETATION IS A VERY GOOD
POINT YOU MAKE AND YOU KNOW IN
THE WORLD OF HEALTH CARE HUMAN
SERVICES GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS. A
LITERAL WORD FOR WORD
TRANSLATION IS NOT GOING TO CUT
IT IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
PEOPLE CAN ACCESS OUR PROGRAM SO
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING.
THAT IS PART OF THIS WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WHAT WE'RE
PRODUCING IS LINGUISTICALLY AND
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE FOR OUR
TARGET AUDIENCES SO THEY CAN'T
REALLY HAVE. ACCESS TO OUR
PROGRAMS- THAT INCLUDES AS YOU
MENTIONED MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT IS
ACCESSIBLE SO THINKING ABOUT.
THE BOOK THE LANGUAGE IN THE
INTERPRETATION. BUT ALSO THAT
THE GRADE LEVEL THAT IT'S
WRITTEN ESTIMATE THESE ARE
BROADLY AVAILABLE WHEN WE'RE NOT
EXCLUDING ANYONE BECAUSE WE'RE
MAKING ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT. YOU
KNOW THERE LITERACY AND IN.
ENGLISH OR OTHER LANGUAGES. I'M
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT ALTERNATIVE
TREATMENTS HILLS IS A VERY GOOD
ONE SO I WANTED. TO WITH OUR
TEAM AND GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE IT'S A REALLY
INTERESTING QUESTION I WANT TO
GIVE YOU. A GOOD ANSWER ON IT
BUT IT'S A WELL TAKE A POINT.
I'M AND I WOULD SAY IT'S YOUR
LARGER POINT- IT'S NOT SOLELY
JUST ABOUT TRANSLATING DOCUMENTS
SO THAT THAT A DOCUMENT FORM-
I'VE DONE A REPORT IS ON A
WEBSITE THAT'S- TRANSLATED BUT
IT'S ABOUT ACCESS TO SERVICES
SO. OUR PROGRAMS ON THE GROUND
LEVEL ENSURING. THAT OUR
LANGUAGE POLICIES ALLOW PEOPLE
ACCESS OF BOTH. ROLLING IN OUR
PROGRAMS BUT THEN BEING SERVICE
SO IN CONNECTICUT MAKING SURE
THAT. PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING
MEDICAL SERVICES BUT THEY ARE
GETTING THEM IN A LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE WAY THAT MEETS OUR
OUR BENEFICIARIES WHERE THEY
ARE- SO THAT THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE IS AS I SAID WE'RE NOT JUST
LOOKING TO TRANSLATE. SOME
DOCUMENTS ON THE STATE WEBSITE
REALLY THINK HOLISTICALLY ABOUT. HOW PEOPLE CAN ACCESS. ALL
RIGHT APRIL THAT LOOK FOR TO
SOME THAT. ON HOW YOU FOR THAT
YOU. I THINK VERY MUCH HI TO
PROCEED. GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE JOHN- HANG IN HERE-
CHIEF DATA OFFICER FOR CALLIE
JUST ON THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER OF THE INSIGHTS AND
INNOVATION I MEAN I COVER I JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON THE EQUITY WORK
THAT WORD I SIGNED WITH. WE'VE
BEEN DESIGNATED THE PLACE TO
DEVELOP THAT THE EQUITY
DASHBOARD AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AN EQUITY
DASHBOARD TO IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THE EQUITY DATA GAPS AND
DISPARITIES AMONG OUR CALENDAR
JUST HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS-
WE'VE BEEN A PART OF THE JOB I.
COMMITTEE AND CONSTANCE. AND THE
AREAS THAT WORK. PARTICULARLY ON
A DATA GAPS WHICH STARTED AGAIN
IN MAY LIKE EQUITY- DATA COMES.
FOR INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY OUR
PROGRAM- BE ACTUALS SERVED
POPULATIONS AND THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE SERVED. WITH OUR
PROGRAMS THERE AS WELL AND THEN
POPULATION NEEDS AND
DISPARITIES- WHICH IS STATE ON
HELPING THE SERVICE- NEED TO
TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIANS BITE OUT
QUICKLY- DEMOGRAPHICS- AND
CHARACTERISTICS TO INFORM
PROGRAM AND- A PROGRAM
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH ENGAGEMENT-
ARE DELIVERABLE RIGHT NOW IS HIS
TARGET FOR APRIL- I. HAVE TO
CONFIRM THE EQUITY OUT FOR THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT PLAN AND
WEBER OUR TIES. AND DATA. AND TO
HAVE PHASE ONE OF THE EQUITY
DASH LAUNCHED BETA ONE HI OSCAR. TWENTY TWO TWO. ALL THERE FOR
QUESTIONS. AT I'M SORRY HER
DEBUT THE PEOPLE YET. WE ARE WE
HAVE AN- BEING SLOW AND WE HOPE
THAT THE PERSON POSITION THAT
THIRTY DAYS. OUR BUT WOMEN
CONTRA TO A PLAN THAT ALONG IT
AFTERWARD A PERSON COMMENTING
AND RUN- WE'VE FOR TO BE ON SOME
EXPERTISE THAT WE- CAN OVER THE
PAST YEAR AND- IN TERMS OF THE-
OF THE ALL HAZARDS. WHAT IT'S AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DATA SHARING- FOR
DASHBOARD DEVELOPMENT SO SOME OF
THE GROUNDWORK IS B. DONE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK- NO IT REALLY SO
IT'S THE ISSUES IN TERMS OF
PROTECT WHEN I COME TO THE API
COME. IS THAT WERE VERY LARGE TO
HIGH SAID WE WERE A WEEK WE TO
PUT A TO PEOPLE FROM THE LAW CUT
IN THE WORLD AND LARGEST- OCEAN
IN THE WORLD. AND SO OFTEN TIMES
WHAT IS- IF WE DON'T DECIDE- WE
ACTUALLY- AND FOR- HI TO ISSUE-
THAT COME UP SO LET'S JUST TALK
KOBE ACTUALLY- SO FOR. TO POINT
CENTER COMMUNITY HAS THE HIGH
DEATH RATE OF ANY RACIAL ETHNIC
GROUPS. THAT WE JUST DO API
WASHED OUT OF IT. THAT'S
INTERESTING IS WITH ABOUT WHEN
ACCESS- THERE'S SOME INDICATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE WELL ASIANS LOOK
LIKE WE'RE DOING WE WOULD NOT DO
AS POORLY- POLITICO BID BUT
THERE'S BEEN SOME STUDIES
LOOKING AT. ASIAN TO ONLY SPEAK.
THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE AND DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH ACTUALLY DO VERY
POORLY. BUT IF YOU JUST WATCH IT
ALL TOGETHER YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
IS STILL DO YOU DON'T SEE THIS
DISPARITIES. SO. CAN YOU JUST
MAYBE SPEAK TO- DASHBOARD IN
TERMS OF THE AT. BE SURE THAT WE
DISAGGREGATE. THE SO THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY- DON'T THE THESE
DISPARITIES WITHIN VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES- AND AGAIN YOU KNOW
THEY THINK AT THE OFTENTIMES WE
TALK ABOUT- THE API COMMUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY EITHER TO AN H. P.
I GET OVERALL HELLO HI HOW ARE
OR OTHER SUBGROUPS- GET MAST
WHEN THEY'RE ALL GROUPED
TOGETHER. SO I WOULD SAY THAT
BAD ACTORS PROBABLY BETTER ONCE
WE GOT OUR FRAMEWORK ON BY APRIL
WE WOULD HAVE AN IDEA THAT I
THINK WHERE WHERE. I'M TRYING TO
LEAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
RIGHT NOW IS. WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING TO ACHIEVE AND SO I
THINK THAT'S HELPFUL AND THAT
ADDITIONAL- INPUT IN TERMS OF
THE END IN MIND. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TRACK WILL ALLOW US TO
PROBABLY BETTER PLAN OUR EFFORTS
SO. WE WANT TO HAVE A TOOL.
NUMBER ENOUGH. TO BE ABLE TO-
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT- TO BE
ABLE TO DRILL AND- TO THAT
CERTAIN POPULATIONS AND- I THINK
THAT'S- PROBABLY THE BEST ANSWER
I CAN GIVE YOU AT THIS POINT.
REPLY THIS INVOLVES I THINK THIS
IS OF COURSE VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE API COMMUNITY AND- OF COURSE
ALSO TO BE SURE WE GET ACTED
INFORMATION I DO APPRECIATE FOR
EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR- IF YOU'RE
A FACULTY BUDGET WOULD PUT IN
SOME FUNDING- FOR. UCW FORM SOME
VERY IMPORTANT SOCIAL SERVICE
RESEARCH TO IDENTIFY THE
DIFFERENT NEEDS OF DIFFERENT
SUBGROUPS IN THE API CAN
HOPEFULLY THAT. CAN HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO. YOUR- TO HAVING A
DASHBOARD THAT ACTUALLY WOULD BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY- INEQUITIES AND
BEEN VERY DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
. ABSOLUTELY JUST THE L. G. B.
T. HAS HISTORICALLY A- AN ISSUE
WITH THIS OFTENTIMES NOT BEING
COUNTED AND SOMETIMES IT FEELS
LIKE EVEN WHEN WE- IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ASKED FOR
INFORMATION ON PASSED BILLS. BY
THE DATA STILL IS NOT COLLECTED.
SO WHAT APPROACH IS ARE YOU ARE
YOU TAKING ON TO THINK ABOUT- IT
ESPECIALLYSINCE A SEXUAL
ORIENTATION BILL TO BE TAKE
COMMUNICANTS ACROSS ALL OF
THESE. DEMOGRAPHICS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PARTICULAR ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED.
WITH SOMETIMESPEOPLE DON'T SELF
REPORT- THEIR IDENTITY YEAH I
THINK IT'S A GREAT QUESTION IT'S
ACTUALLY THE WHEN WE THINK OF
INEQUITY DASH FOR THE FIRST
OUTWARD WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WITH OUR TEAM IS THE DASHBOARD
THAT ADDRESSES THE MISSING DATA-
WE KNOW THAT AS WE TRY TO BRING
A PERSON CENTRED VIEW AND BRING
DATA FROM. ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER EVEN
DIFFERENT APARTMENTS QUITE
DIFFERENT DATA SOME DATA IS NOT
COLLECTED AT ALL SO
UNDERSTANDING. GAP START TO THEN
IN OUR SERVICE DELIVERY EFFORTS.
TO FIND EITHER WAYS TO OBTAIN
THAT DATA OR BUILD INTO SERVICE
FEATURE SERVICE. DELIVERY VERY
EARLY ON IN TERMS OF I GOT FIND
GAP SOME THEY ARE. BRING THEM TO
. AND THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE TO
ABLE TO THAT DE. THEN TO BE ABLE
TO WHERE THE NEQUITIES ARE AND
ADDRESS NOT JUST SITTING UP
THERE. SO WE SEE IT AS A- AS A
CLASS. TOOL BOTH A PRIVATE FOCUS
WELL AS A- BASIC. PATCHWORK.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
YOU WORK FOR EQUITY AS WELL. NO
I WAS TO GIVE AN UPDATE ON THAT
EXTREME FRAMEWORK ONE THIRTY
THREE OKAY. HELLO REAL QUICK I
JUST A- TWO MINUTE- ST OKAY- ON
JULY TWENTIETH. GOV NEWSOM. A
ONE THIRD THREE BUT CAL. ON PATH
TO BUILDING A AND HUMAN SERVICES
DATA EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK. THAT
WILL ADVANCE IN GOVERNING THE
EXCHANGE OF ELECTRONIC HEALTH
INFORMATION ACROSS THE STATE. WE
ARE IN AGGRESSIVE- WE'RE ON AN
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE TO DELIVER A
DATA EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK TO GUIDE
THE EXCHANGE. A SINGLES SINGLE
DATA SHARING AGREEMENT AS
STRATEGY FOR DIGITAL IDENTITIES
BY JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
CAN BE IN THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP CHAIRED BY
SECRETARY CALLED. WHICH HAS A
WIDE REPRESENTATION OF TWENTY
SEVEN ORGANIZATIONS AND THIRTEEN
DEPARTMENTS WITH DEEP EXPERTISE
AND ARE ENGAGED IN MAKING THIS A
REALITY. WITH HELP FIVE MEETINGS
AND HAVE ALMOST SIX TO SEVEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
COLLECTIVE WORK. TO DATE WE'VE
ESTABLISHED GUIDING PRINCIPLES
THAT ALIGN WITH FEDERAL AND
CATHOLIC CHURCH. PRINCIPLES
FOCUSED ON CONSUMER AND PATIENT
PROTECTION. FOR WORKING ON
MODELING SCENARIOS TO IDENTIFY
DATA EXCHANGE GAPS. AND ARE
DEVELOPING RECOMMENDED STANDARDS. POLICIES AND REFORMS. OUR
SYSTEM FOR THREE THEME THAT WE
THINK ABOUT A THE DEVELOPER OF
THIS EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK. ONE IS
THAT. STAKEHOLDERS AGREE
QUESTION ABOUT SOURCE OF FINING
SUPPORT FOR IMPLEMENTATION
INCLUDING BUILDING NECESSARY H.
I. T. CAPACITY. PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. KELLY
DRESSES EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF ALIGNING EXISTING STATE
EFFORTS AT IDENTIFYING FEDERAL
PRIVATE SECTOR AND PHILANTHROPIC
RESOURCES THAT MAY BE LEVERAGED
. SECOND STAKEHOLDERS OF
ADVANCED PROPOSALS THAT CONFLICT
WITH THE TECHNO TECHNOLOGICALLY
AGNOSTIC MANDATE OF THE DATA
EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK AND WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT TECHNICALLY
TECHNOLOGICALLY AGNOSTIC
OFFERING. AND THIRD FUTURE
POLICY GUIDANCE THIS WORK IS
BEING DONE VERY QUICKLY AND WITH
THE SUPPORT OF MANY STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUPS AND WHILE WE
ANTICIPATE MEETING THE
LEGISLATIVE WE ARE REQUIRED
DEADLINES POLICY GUIDANCE WILL
LIKELY BE REQUIRED BEYOND THE
JULY. LEGISLATIVE DEADLINE TO
CLARIFY MORE COMPLEX AND
DETAILED ISSUES WILL RETURN TO
LEGISLATURE IN APRIL WITH A MORE
DETAILED UPDATES AND INFORMATION
ON HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
REALIZE THAT VISION OF AB ONE
THIRTY CREEK. THANK YOU. BAKER
MACHINE. ACTUALLY TO COURT TWO
QUESTIONS POINTS ALTHOUGH THE
COUPLE DIFFERENT- AND AGAIN
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK AND
THIS IS A THAT YOU ARE AN
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE I APPRECIATE
THAT SO ON ONE LEVEL ON ONE
HAND- I GUESS CAN YOU TO SPEAK
TO EXAMPLE DATA SECURITY RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA BUILD EXCHANGE
WHICH MEANS EVERYONE'S
EXCHANGING DATA WITH EACH OTHER
THAT'S GOOD- BUT ALSO WE WANT TO
BE SURE THAT SOMEONE CAN'T TAP
INTO THE EXCHANGES WHO SHOULDN'T
BE. AND- AND THEN TO DOUBLE DOWN
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE SO- HE TALK
ABOUT PERHAPS SOME OF THE STEPS.
BEING TAKEN TO ENSURE DATA
SECURITY AND THE FRAMEWORK. OR
EXCHANGING DATA THEN ON THE FLIP
SIDE THOUGH- TALK ABOUT MONEY
GET GREATER ACCESS TO DATA- YOU
KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE LEARNED IN KOBE-
PERHAPS IS THAT. BEING SURE
PUBLIC HEALTH ACTUALLY AS ACCESS
TO A LARGER AMOUNTS OF DATA TO
BETTER DO SURVEILLANCE AND
IDENTIFY YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
UPCOMING. HAZARDS OR OR BETTER
MANAGING EXISTING ONES LIKE
COATED OR OTHERS. AND SO WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO ALSO ENSURE
THAT- PUBLIC HEALTH. HAS IT HAS
THE- BUT ACCESS BUT ALSO THE
RESOURCES TO ANALYZE DATA THAT
MIGHT BE COMING THROUGH THE
EXCHANGE. SO I REALIZE THAT
MAYBE POINT TO DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS BUT- WANTED SECURITY
THE OTHER ONE IS YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE THAT ON A POPULATION BASIS
WERE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF.
OF THIS DATA TO PROTECT PUBLIC.
SURE AND I WILL SAY ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL WATCHING THE
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE GROW
OVER THE LAST TWELVE OR THIRTEEN
YEARS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE- AND
ALSO FOCUSING A LOT OF MY CAREER
ON. HELPING BRING SOCIAL-SERVICES TO. BUT THE INFORMATION
SHARING AS WELL AND LOOK AT THE
SOCIAL TERMS. IT'S EXCITING TO
SEE THE STATE. AT THIS POINT-
WHAT WHAT I THINK WE'RE
LEVERAGING IN THIS APPROACH AND
THE BEAUTY BEHIND IT IS THERE
ARE SO MANY ALL ALREADY EXISTING
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND REALLY WHAT THIS
IS LEVERAGING THOSE- AND THE
WORD YOU MIGHT HEAR OVER TIME
IT'S INTERMEDIARIES WHICH ARE
THESE ENTITIES THAT ALREADY IN
THE BUSINESS OF. HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THAT MAN CANNOT ON
BOARD- ENTITIES PROVIDERS- OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE EXCHANGE OF
HEALTH INFORMATION TO YOUR POINT
OF UNDERSTANDING THE SECURITY.
AND THE AND- THAT AFTER THAT
HAPPENS THERE. SO IT'S REALLY A
NETWORK. OF NETWORK APPROACH-
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE STILL
TECHNO NOT MOST FOR SPIKE IT
DOES NOT- BUILDING. IT'S REALLY
INTO HAT A FRAMEWORK AND- DRUG
THE EXISTING. PIECES. YOUR
QUESTION S. OF AND I REALIZE
THAT THAT AND AGAIN WE'RE TRYING
TO DO I GUESS THE ARE USED
SECURITIES AND HOPEFULLY YOU GET
OUT WORK THERE. HASSOCKS STAND
BUT IS THERE. THAT I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW IT'S ABOUT CONNECTING
AND ONE OF THE THERE'S CERTAIN
MINIMUM LEVEL SECURITY TO ENSURE
THAT SOMEONE NOW I CAN ACCESS
ONE NETWORK NOW ACTUALLY ACCESS
EVERYBODY RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE
CONNECTING ALL THESE NETWORKS
TOGETHER. AND THAT'S WHERE YOU
SEE THAT THE EFFORTS IN TERMS OF
BOTH THE GOVERNANCE OF THIS OF.
THIS WORK THAT WERE. YOU GOTTA
BE RECOMMENDING. DIEM PLACE AND
THAT'S PARKS SO FAR. AS WELL AS
- PRIVACY'S. ARE RISKS BUILDING
. TROUBLE THAT THE SINGLE
GREATEST A- AS WELL AS THE
STANDARD ARE GONNA BE
RECOMMENDING ALL SIX. SO IT'S
GETTING EVERYONE ON THE SAME
PAGE IT'S ALIGNING WITH TAPPED.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. AS WELL.
THEN I GUESS THE PUBLIC CUTS FOR
AS PAUL PROTECT AS WELL AS
THERE'S ONE OTHER I DON'T I'M
MISSING MANY- QUICK JUST- THE
CONSUMER- PROTECTION PRINCIPLE
FOR ALL INFORMATION EXCHANGE AND
- ROLL OVER TO MUCH. AND I GUESS
PLANET HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH X. BETTER AT TO
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN THAT'S AND
THAT'S WHERE WHERE WE'RE HEADED
WITH SO MANY OF THE FRIENDS IS I
WAS MOVING TOWARDS. MOVING TO
OUR PERSONS APPROACH AND HAVING
DAY IN THE RIGHT BUT WE NEED IT
- IT IS IT'S THAT CAN BE TRUE
WERE LEVERAGED BY SOME. FOR A
LOCAL LAW AS WELL AS. ALL RIGHT
WELL I LOOK. TO WE TALK PUBLIC
THAT WE HAVE THE KIND INVESTMENT
NESTOR TO HAVE. PUBLIC HEALTH
TAKE IT. OF OUR TO THESE THIS
NETWORK OF NETWORKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THE NETWORK OF NETWORK TALK TO
OTHER AND HAVE THE TO BE ABLE
THOSE. THROUGH THE THROUGH
LANGUAGE ACQUISITION- DISTANT
NETWORK TALK- OKAY SOCIAL WE
HEAR NOW FROM THE L. A. O. YOUR
FINISHER'S MCMAHON DIRECTOR
MCCARTY. YES THAT THAT CONCLUDES
OUR REMARKS MANAGER THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THEN WE'LL
TURN TO TURN YOUR HEADACHES
THANKS TO SEE YOU AGAIN BACK
THIS YEAR WELCOME HAPPY NEW YEAR
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE- AND HERE WE
GO. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
EGGMAN AND A DOCTOR PAN OF THE
L. A. O. DOESN'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON THIS
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH VERY WELCOME
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANYTHING FROM
YOU. I AM. BERMAN ARE YOU HAND
IS RAISED. NO COMMENTS FROM
FINANCE AT THE TIME THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW. PROCEED WITH
THE PRESENTATION YOUR FOR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS UNDER THE
SERVICE OF THIS NUMBER TWO THEN
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE.
ELIGIBILITY ENROLLMENT AND
RETENTION SYSTEM. ARE YOU READY
FOR ME READY FOR A- HI MY NAME
IS CHANGED CONCERN THE OFFICER
INTEGRATION THE CARD IS PARTNER
DIRECTOR. AND I WANT TO GET A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF OUR PROPOSAL
THE OFFICE ASSISTANT INTEGRATION
REQUEST ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND AD GENERAL FUND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE THERE ARE GOING. SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE FEDERALIZATION OF CRITICAL
SERVICES WITHIN. A CARRIAGE
PROJECT. THIS BOOK EXPANDS JUST
. TO SUCCESS DEVELOP TEST ENABLE
FEDERAL AND STATE RANDY. SYSTEMS
CHANGES. I REQUEST ALSO A IN
WORK ALONG WITH JUST MAY. THE
RECENT CHANGES IN SYSTEM
INTEGRATOR. APPROVAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IT'S CRITICAL TO
ENHANCE OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
PERFORMANCE AND SERVICE LEVELS
OF CHARACTERS BY RESTRUCTURING
THE ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
OF THE PROJECTS STATE TEAM.
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES HIGHLY
EXPERIENCED LEADERSHIP STAFF
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE PROPOSED
DEVELOP IMPLEMENT AND RESOLVE
COMPLEX INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
ISSUES. POLICIES WHILE HEARING
TO COMPLEX COMPLIANCE RULES
REGULATIONS CONFIDENTIALITY
REQUIREMENTS EXECUTING IMPACTS
ACROSS LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURES. THE GOAL
OF THIS RECALL THE WILL TO
PROVIDE THE CONGRESS PROJECTS
SPONSORS. STAKEHOLDERS AND
CALIFORNIANS WHAT THE MOST OF
AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO ACQUIRE. AND
OBTAIN HEALTHCARE. RESHOOT COVER
CAL. OR CAL. ALL IN ALL STAR
APPEARANCE ANY FOR YOU MIGHT
HAVE I THINK WE'LL JUST MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND THEN
WE'LL COME BACK FOR QUESTIONS AT
THE VERY END. THAT'S OKAY.
NUMBER THREE I'M SORRY ELECTRON.
BENEFIT TRANSFER PROJECT. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
RENDON HANSARD DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AT- ASIDE FROM THE BENEFITS
ENROLLMENT TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT
DIVISION HAVE ONE REQUEST IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY FOR R. ICHI
PROJECT- WE ARE REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS- WITH LIMITED TERM
FUNDING FOR TWO YEARS. TO
SUPPORT INCREASED WORKLOAD- THAT
WE- EXPERIENCED OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS. AND APPEARS TO BE
ONGOING- RELATED. TO THE
PANDEMIC EFFORTS AS WELL AS
ONLINE PURCHASING WE ARE
REQUESTING THREE POSITIONS WE DO
HAVE A MEDIA- BUT WE ARE GOING
TO REQUEST TO YOUR FUNDING SO
THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ANALYZE THE WORKLOADS. I
DETERMINED THE ONGOING NATURE
AND COME BACK TO YOU WITH WITH
PERMANENT FUNDING IF NECESSARY.
OKAY QUESTIONS I THINK WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BELIEVE
THAT SAYS CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM
AUGMENTATION. MY NAME'S ADAM
DUNDRUM AGENCY CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER FOR KILEY JHS. BOZELLA
AS FOR POSITION AND SOME
CONTRACT FUNDING. ONE OF THE
POSITIONS OF STATUTORILY
REQUIRED WHAT IS THE CALIFORNIA
CYBER SECURITY INTEGRATION
CENTER THE PARTNERSHIP ACROSS
ALL STATE CAMERON HAN HANDLE IN
CYBER SECURITY. FIREMEN'S EACH
OF THE MAJOR AGENCIES HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE AS PART OF THAT
THIS REQUEST IS FOR THE POSITION
THAT WE NEED TO BE A PART OF
BODY SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT NOT
JUST STATE GOVERNMENT
CYBERSECURITY LOOKING ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE. OBVIOUSLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE'VE SEEN THAT THE
HEALTH INDUSTRY ITSELF
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE HOSPITALS
AND NONPROFITS OF ALL BECOME
TARGETS OF CYBER SECURITY. THE
OTHER POSITION IS FOR AGENCY
DIRECTLY WE CURRENTLY ONLY HAVE
ONE INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AT THE PRESS NINETY PROJECTS
ACROSS ALL THE MAINTENANCE
OPERATION FUNDING COST FOUR
BILLION IN PROJECT FUNDING. AND
THERE'S JUST TOO MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE THERE BY ONE INDIVIDUAL SO
IT'S REQUEST FOR ONE ADDITIONAL
POSITION AND THEN CONTRACT
DOLLARS TO HELP US STAND ACROSS
THE AGENCIES THAT EACH OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS AREN'T SOLVING THESE
PROBLEMS INDEPENDENTLY. WE CAN
DO IT IN A MORE COORDINATED
FASHION AND ADDRESS THE CONSTANT
INCREASING CYBER SECURITY
THREATS TO THE STATE- THE AGENDA
THAT YOU HAVE LAYS OUT THE
REQUEST VERY WELL SO WE'LL LEAVE
IT AT THAT AND TAKING. OR
LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE. NUMBER FIVE
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
EACH AND I'M WITH OFFICE OF.
SYSTEM TO- REP. THE ELECTRON
CARE. ABOUT PROJECT- RBC WORK.
THIRTEEN NO. DOLLAR WITH THREE
POINT NINE NINE IN JOHN FUND FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY.
AT A TOTAL OF ONE POINT ONE
MILLION FOURTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. FOR FISCAL
YEARS TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
THROUGH TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
FOR THE CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION
AND OPERATIONAL ACTIVITIES.
RELATED TO THE ELECTRONIC VISIT
VERIFICATION PHAE TWO PROJECT.
WE ARE REQUESTING ONGOING
FUNDING FOR NINETEEN POSITIONS.
AND CONTINUE CONTRACTS SERVICES
INCLUDING THE NEW- SYSTEMATIC
GREATER CONTRACT WAS SEND DATA
TECHNOLOGIES. FOR IMPLEMENTATION. OF DVD BASED TO- EXCUSE ME OF
THE EVIL FACE CONTRA WAS A AND-
TWENTY- EXCUSE ME AUGUST OF THIS
YEAR AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WE'LL GO THROUGH AUGUST-
TWENTY TWENTY SIX- WE HAVE TWO
OPTIONAL- TWO YEAR EXTENSIONS
THE CURRENT CONTRACT VALUE IS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
MILLION- WITH THE FIVE YEAR TERM
AND FIFTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION INCLUDING- THE OPTIONAL
YOUR EXTENSIONS. THE ON GOING
ACTIVITIES THAT WE STILL HAVE IN
FRONT OF US- ARE INCLUDE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HOME
HEALTH CARE SERVICES COMPONENT
OF THIS- EFFORT WHICH IS DUE TO
BE IMPLEMENTED BY JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE BASED ON
FEDERAL REGULATIONS WE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED- FOR
PERSONAL CARE SERVICES ON
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO OF THIS YEAR SO THAT PART IS
COMPLETE- BUT WE STILL HAVE THE
REMAINING IMPLEMENTATION
ACTIVITIES BETWEEN NOW AND
JANUARY IN ADDITION WE ARE DOING
OPERATIONAL AND PROGRAM SUPPORTS
FOR THE PCS COMPONENTS AND WILL
HAVE A VARIETY OF ONGOING
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THAT AS
WELL AS THE IMPLEMENTATION. I'M
AT A HIGH LEVEL- WE WILL BE
CONTINUING TO ON BOARD OF
PROVIDERS- AND RECIPIENTS
CONTINUE COMMUNICATION TO
PROVIDERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
STATEWIDE CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
PROGRAM SUPPORT FOR PROVIDERS
STAKEHOLDERS AND ASSIST USER AND
CONTINUING- THAT SUMMER YES.
JUST TO MAKE A CHANGE. I JUST
SHUT. DOWN I WILL THERE SEE IF
THERE ANY. QUESTION A IF YOU ARE
A. OTIS IF THEY HAVE ANY COMMON
OR- ALL POLL. BRIAN METZGER-
WEAVERVILLE THESE FOR AND HOW NO
CONCERN- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU NO COMMENT OKAY- I
DISAPPROVE. CAN YOU GIVE A
LITTLE- OVERVIEW OF HOW DO YOU
FEEL LIKE TAT THE ELECTRONIC
VISIT VERIFICATION HOW THAT HAS
GONE- AND WHAT IT WOULD BUMP
THAT HAVE YOU SEEN THAT DID NOW
YOU'RE TRYING TO FILL MORE
PLACES FOR AND I GUESS TO
EVERYBODY WHO IS TALKED ABOUT-
FILL IN EVERY MORE- POSITIONS.
HAS IT BEEN DIFFICULT TO HIRE
PEOPLE AND HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
RETAIN PEOPLE WANT YOU FIRED
THEM. SO I WILL I WILL ARTICLE
FIRST I'M NOT ND I'M A LOSS
WHEN BY THE TIME WE HAVE DH CS
IDEAS FROM A PROGRAMMING
PERSPECTIVE. ON FROM A SYSTEM
PERSPECTIVE OUR IMPLEMENTATION
OF PERSONAL CARE SERVICES NOT BY
THE JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DEADLINE. ON WHAT RELATIVELY
SMOOTHLY THE SENATE A CONTRACT
WAS AWARDED IN AUGUST AND WITHIN
A FOUR MONTH TIME PERIOD WE WERE
ABLE TO. LEVERAGE THEIR COST
SOLUTION MODIFIED FOR CALIFORNIA
AND COMPLETE THAT IMPLEMENTATION
- AS OF RIGHT NOW WE ARE
EXPECTING A SIMILAR ON THE
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM STANDPOINT. A
SIMILAR- YOU KNOW EXPERIENCE OF
FOR THE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE DEADLINE FOR HOME
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- FROM A
PROGRAM PERSPECTIVE I LOVE MY DH
YESTERDAY ASKED TO WAIT ON. ON.
THEIR THOUGHT. THAT'S A LOT OF
VIOLENCE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- WE HAVE.
FILLED THAT POSITION BUT ARE
ALLOCATED FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND AND
HAVE MAINTAINED. ON THOSE
POSITIONS AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE- OF PARTS AND THEY WERE
BUILT- TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION-
WE FELT LIKE IMPLEMENTATION IS
GOING WELL- WE LAUNCHED AS
LEARNING. AND I JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND CONTINUE
TO ON BOARD PROVIDERS. ACROSS
ALL OF THEM MEDICAID PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
WE ALSO ARE GEARING UP FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HOME
HEALTH CARE SERVICES COMPONENT
OF THE INITIATIVE. I WHICH IS
REQUIRED. TO GO LIVE IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND THE
POOR AND THE FROM THE PER SIDE
HAVE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
THE SYSTEM PRETTY SEAMLESSLY.
YES OUR CONTRACTOR SANDIA
TECHNOLOGIES IS ABLE TO PROVIDE
EXTENSIVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SO WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
TRAINING AVAILABLE TO THE
PROVIDERS. THERE'S A SELF
REGISTRATION PORTAL THAT WALKS
THE PROVIDERS THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF. REGISTERING INTO THE
CAL YOU CAN BE SOMETIMES AND I'M
AND THEN THERE'S EXTENSIVE
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED TO EACH
PROVIDER IF THEY ON BOARD. TO
HELP THE REST BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE SAN DIEGO THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. OKAY DR GRANT. OKAY NO
QUESTIONS. AND I THINK WITH THAT
THEN WE WANT TO SOME REALLY GOOD
SENSE AND WITH SINCERITY. I
DON'T KNOW I THINK THE CAL AGES
AS PRESENTERS AND STAFF FROM.
AND FINANCE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO EMS. WE WANT TO
WELCOME FOR THE- GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I AM LUISFRANKIE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY WHICH I WILL REFER TO
AS KIM SO. UNFORTUNATELY DON'T
DIRECTOR- ELIZABETH BASSINET WAS
NOT ABLE TO ATTEND THE HEARING
TODAY. AND ON HER BEHALF AS
REQUESTED I WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW. OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
RICK TRUSSELL ANSWERS CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION WILL PROVIDE THE-
OVERVIEW OF OUR BUDGETS AND
PROPOSALS. OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM.
WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE BY HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
DIVISION TWO POINT FIVE WITH THE
INTENT OF CREATING A STATEWIDE
SYSTEM WITH M. SERVICE POSSIBLE
FOR THE COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION OF ALL STATE
ACTIVITIES CONCERNING EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES. TO ENSURE THE
PROVISION OF EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE. AND SAYS A SMALL
DEPARTMENT WHICH BUT WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITIES.
FIRST PRE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHICH IS ONE PIECE OF
EMERGENCY CARE NETWORK THAT IS
INTEGRATED WITH HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
SERVICES. PREHOSPITAL NINE ONE
ONE SERVICES ARE WIDELY SEEN BY
THE PUBLIC IT'S A GUARANTEED
SERVICE FOR ALL. AND ONE OF OUR
MAJOR HEALTHCARE SAFETY NETS. IN
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
640-002-0070 ONE CERTIFIED EMTS
AND TWENTY THREE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE LICENSE
PARAMEDICS RESPOND TO ABOUT FIVE
POINT FOUR MILLION. NINE ONE ONE
CALLS FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES
ANNUALLY WITH THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED GROUND AMBULANCES
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN AIR
AMBULANCES. THEY TAKE THE OR
INJURED TWO ONE OF THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE AT U. CHAIR
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
THAT MAY ALSO BE. DESIGNATED AS
SUBSPECIALTY CARE CENTERS SUCH
AS TRAUMA CENTERS. SPECIFICALLY
ABSENCE RESPONSIBLE FOR
LICENSING PARAMEDICS AND
DISCIPLINE THOSE LICENSES WHEN
NECESSARY. COOPER PRACTICE
TRAINING STANDARDS AND
REGULATIONS FOR EMS LEVELS
INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST
AID. AN IMPORTANT INITIATIVE
FROM M. SO REGARDING THE ROLE OF
PARAMEDICS IS THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE PILOT PROJECT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE AND ALTERNATE
DESTINATION. WHICH TEST AND
EVALUATES THE USE OF PARAMEDICS
AND EXPANDED MOBILE HEALTH CARE
ROLES. THAT FEEL IDENTIFY GAPS%
IN LOCAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AND
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CARE AND
INTEGRATION OF HEALTH CARE. THE
RESULTS DEMONSTRATED THAT
PARAMEDICS CAN EFFECTIVELY AND
SAFELY WORK WITH PATIENTS TO
REDUCE REPEAT HOSPITALIZATIONS
DECREASED NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
USE. PERFORM OUTREACH TO HARD TO
REACH PATIENTS AND IDENTIFY
PATIENTS THAT CAN BE BETTER
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS. ALL
WITHOUT DISPLACING ANY OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. TEMPLE
HAS COMPLETED THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD OF THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS FOR A BEAT FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR WHICH TAKES THE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE PILOT PROJECT
TO PROVIDE ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRAIN AN EMPLOYEE COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICS LOCALLY. SECONDLY I
AM SORT OF ELEPHANT GUIDELINES
AND APPROVES PLANS FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SYSTEMS THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND OPERATED BY THE
LOCAL EMS AGENCIES THAT
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES
THERE ARE THIRTY THREE LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES THAT INCLUDE TWENTY SIX
SINGLE COUNTY AGENCIES AND SEVEN
MULTI COUNTY AGENCIES THAT SERVE
RURAL AREAS. NINE ONE ONE
AMBULANCE SERVICES PROVIDED BY
BOTH THE PUBLIC FIRE INTERESTS
THESE AGENCIES. AND PRIVATE
PROVIDERS. I AM SO DEVELOPS
REGULATIONS FOR THE DESIGN AND
QUALITY ESPECIALLY CARE SYSTEMS
INCLUDING THE TRAUMA SYSTEM WITH
SEVENTY NINE DESIGNATED CENTERS.
AFTER COVERAGE G. EFFORTS TO
CARE CENTERS THE STROKES SYSTEM
WITH A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DESIGNATED CENTERS THE CARD
EXTEND THE SYSTEM WITH A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN CENTERS AND THE
POISON CONTROL SYSTEM. ONE OF
OUR PRIORITY INITIATIVES TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
MS SYSTEM USING IMPROVE LOCAL
AND REGIONAL DATA. WITH THE
SUPPORT OF AB SHOULD ELEVEN
TWENTY NINE CHAPTER TEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE HAVE CONVERTED
ALL PROVIDERS TO ELECTRONIC
DOCUMENTATION OF PATIENT CARE I
CAN BE AGGREGATED ANALYZED AND
USED FOR SYSTEM EVALUATION AND
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT. WE HELP
LOCAL EMS SYSTEMS AND PROVIDERS
EXCHANGE CLINICAL DATA WITH
HOSPITALS SO PARAMEDICS CAN HELP
PATIENTS INFORMATION IN THE
FIELD AND HOSPITALS CAN RECEIVE
INFORMATION FROM YOU KNW MASS.
DURING A DISASTER THIS
INITIATIVE ALSO IMPROVES CARE BY
MAKING CRITICAL PATIENT.
INFORMATION AVAILABLE WHEN
PATIENTS ARE TREATED IN
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS. THE THIRD
MAJOR AREA OF THE M. SO
RESPONSIBILITY IS MEDICAL
RESPONSE TO DISASTER I AM SO
PARTNERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
STABILITY PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL RESPONSE EMERGENCY
SYSTEM WITH FEDERAL STATE. AND
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO PLAN FOR
THE MEDICAL IMPACT OF ANY TYPE
OF DISASTER OR HEALTH EMERGENCY
. EMSA HAS DEVELOPED RESOURCES
FOR A TIERED RESPONSE TO
DISASTER TO BROUGHT PROVIDE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL RESPONSE IN
THE FIELD. THE FIRST HERE
CURRENTLY CONSISTENT CONSIST OF
FORTY TO DISASTER AND MEDICAL
SUPPORT UNITS. WHICH SERVICE THE
LEAD VEHICLE FOR EMERGENCY
STRIKE TEAMS THE UNITS ALONG
WITH AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS ARE
REACHING USED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FOR MULTI CASUALTY
EVENTS FOR HOSPITAL EVACUATION.
AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS WERE
RECENTLY USED TO EVACUATE OVER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY PATIENTS
DURING THE TWENTY TWENTY
WILDFIRES AND TO TRANSPORT
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
PATIENTS OUT OF IMPERIAL COUNTY
TO RECEIVING HOSPITALS DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN SEARCH. SECOND
TIER CONSISTS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE TEAMS ARE
TELLING THAT. THEY CAN BE
DEPLOYED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS WITHIN TWELVE HOURS OF
ACTIVATION THANK AND SUPPORT ANY
LOCATION IN CALIFORNIA. IN
ADDITION PERSONAL CAN BE PULLED
FROM OUR DISASTER HEALTH CARE
VOLUNTEER REGISTRY THAT
CURRENTLY CONTAINS NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSE
PERSONAL OF ALL TYPES INCLUDING
THE LOCALLY ORGANIZED MEDICAL
RESERVE CORPS. APPROXIMATELY ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DISASTER
HEALTHCARE VOLUNTEERS IN MRC
MEMBERS HAVE SUPPORTED VARIOUS
MEDICAL MISSIONS DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN RESPONSE. EPCIS
MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTER PROGRAM
IS A SYSTEM OF MODULAR MOBILE
STRUCTURES THAT CAN BE USED TO
SUPPORT MEDICAL CARE AND AS A
COMMAND CENTER AND AS MEDICAL
SHELTERS TODAY FIFTY M. CEMENTED
STRUCTURES HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED TO
SUPPORT DISASTER RESPONSE
EFFORTS. AND EMPHASIS ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON
THE CALIFORNIA PHYSICIAN ORDERS
FOR LIFE SUSTAINING TREATMENT OR
POST HE REGISTRY ACT. A
PHYSICIAN ORDERS FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT OR PULSES A
PHYSICIAN ORDER THAT HELPS TO
GIVE THAT SERIOUSLY ILL AND
FRAGILE PATIENTS MORE CONTROL
OVER THEIR END OF LIFE CARE. IN
CALIFORNIA THE PULSE FORM ALLOWS
A PATIENT TO CLEARLY STATE WHAT
LEVEL OF MEDICAL TREATMENT IS
DESIRED TOWARD THE END OF LIFE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY THREE A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL SIGNED IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA POLLS E.
REGISTRY ACT WHICH REQUIRES
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH A STATE
WIDE ELECTRONIC POLST REGISTRY
SYSTEM TO COLLECT PATIENTS POST
INFORMATION AND DISSEMINATE THAT
INFORMATION TO AN AUTHORIZED
USER. AND SO HAS BEGUN THE IN
REGISTRY PROCESS BY BEGINNING
THE HELL WERE PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE PROCESS AS SOON AS
COMPLETED AND RECEIVED APPROVAL
OF STAGE ONE S. ONE B. EIGHT OR
OR THE BUSINESS ANALYSIS STAGE.
AND IS CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION ON STAGE TO. THE
ALTERNATIVE ANALYSIS STAGE
ADDITIONALLY AN RSL HAS BEEN
ISSUED SEEKING SUCH SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE IN THE AREA OF
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE TO
ASSIST THEM SO THROUGH THE
RESEARCH PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT AND
ENTERPRISE SOLUTION FOR THE
STATEWIDE POST REGISTRY. IT IS
ANTICIPATED THAT MS WILL
CONTRACT WITH THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT BY APRIL. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I'M SORRY APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND DINNER WITH I'VE
MY- OVER AND A LOT RICH. TO
DISCUSS AND PROVIDE BY. OKAY
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE BUDGET
ANYTHING FROM THE OLEO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. STATE
WHICH TOOK A CHECK IF YOU WANT.
THERE WE GO OKAY THANK YOU- AND
I THINK OKAY SO LET'S GO INTO
MISTER TRUSSELL. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS RICK ROSS
ON THE CHIEF OF THE MINISTRATION
FOR THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY AND I'LL BE
PRESENTING THE OVERVIEW OF OUR
BUDGET AND OUR PROPOSALS.
CURRENTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE INCLUDES
EXPENDITURE OF FORTY IN THE
AMOUNT OF FIFTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION. NINE HUNDRED TWELVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS OF THIS
AMOUNT THIRTY MILLION OR 65% IS
DELEGATED FOR START OPERATIONS
IN TWENTY POINT SEVEN MILLION OR
35% IS DELEGATED TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE. STATE OPERATIONS. OF
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION CONSISTS OF
64% GENERAL FUND. 12%
REIMBURSEMENTS 10% FEDERAL
FUNDING IN 414% SPECIAL FUNDS.
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FINDING UP
TWENTY POINT SEVEN MILLION
CONSISTS OF 54% REMEMBER MONTHS.
42% GENERAL FUND 3% FEDERAL FUND
AND 1% SPECIAL FUNDS. THE
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAS THREE
BUDGET PROPOSALS CONTAINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET UNDER
CONSIDERATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE
INCREASE PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE CAPABILITY. MS IS
REQUESTING A GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OF EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
FIFTY THOUSAND AND TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AN ONGOING. THE
REQUESTED ONE TIME RESOURCES OF
EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION WILL
FIND M. SUMMERS MEDICAL RESPONSE
FLEET. UPGRADES BY ADDRESSING
IDENTIFIED SAFETY AND
OPERATIONAL GAPS EXPERIENCE
DURING OUR RECENT RESPONSE TO
WILDFIRES EARTHQUAKES IN THE
PANDEMIC DISASTER RESPONSES. WE
ARE. OR CREST ANNUAL
SUBSCRIPTION FEES REQUIRED FOR
THE RADIO EQUIPMENT ARE. BEING
REPLACED IN OUR FLEET ASSETS.
I'M SPECIFICALLY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION IS DEDICATED DISTRICT
ASSET REPLACEMENT SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND TO FLEET ASSET SAFETY
UPGRADES. SIX POINT SIX MILLION
IN THE FIFTY THOUSAND ONE TIME
FOR RADIO CASH REPLACEMENT. TO-
COME ON COMPLY WITH THE NEW
CHRIS. THE NAME QB VEHICLE IN
THE AMOUNT OF THOUSAND DOLLARS.
MS ARE CURRENTLY HAS TWENTY
SEVEN RESPONSE VEHICLES ARE NOT
THESE NINE WILL BE REPLACED IT
WILL RECEIVE SAFETY UPGRADES IN
TWENTY FIVE WERE RECEIVED
COMMUNICATIONS UPGRADES ENSURING
COMPLIANCE WITH CHRIS. MS OUR
HAS WE HAVE. WORKABLE GENERATORS
IN OF THESE FOURTEEN WILL BE A
GREAT PLACE TO COMPLY WITH
CURRENT CAL EPA REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY ON THE HOUSE FORTY
TWO OAKLEY BASED DISASTER
MEDICAL SUPPORT UNITS STATIONED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND ALL OF
THESE DMS YOU VEHICLES WILL ALSO
RECEIVE A COMMUNICATIONS UPGRADE. ENSURING COMPLIANCE WITH CHRIS
SYSTEM- WITH THESE ADDITION
RESOURCES AND THE WILL BE ABLE
TO BETTER SUPPORT. AND IMPROVE
DISASTER MEDICAL RESPONSE
MITIGATION RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
DURING AND AFTER MAJOR
DISASTERS. BY IMPROVING
OPERATING OUR FLEET ASSETS AND
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT OR
FACILITATES CHANGED MOVING RAPID
STATEWIDE DISASTER MEDICAL
RESPONSE ALIGNED WITH FEDERAL
STATE REGIONAL LOCAL
COMMUNICATIONS INTER OPERABILITY
STANDARDS. AND PROPERLY
EQUIPPING MS OF FLEET VEHICLES
WERE APPROPRIATE SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS AND OPERATIONS
GEAR TO ENSURE FIELD RESPONSES
ARE SAFE. AND TIMELY. ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT PROPOSAL
NUMBER ONE OR WOULD YOU PREFER I
WAIT UNTIL THE END FOR QUESTIONS
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER YOU WAY TO
THE END. THANK YOU. PROPOSAL
NUMBER TWO IS A CALIFORNIA
POISON CONTROL SYSTEM FUNDING
AUGMENTATION. MS IS REQUESTING A
LOCAL ASSISTANCE AUGMENTATION OF
ONE MILLION FIFTY SIX GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
ONE MILLION FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. AN ONGOING
FUNDING OF ONE MILLION SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND. AND THREE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE THOUSAND REIMBURSEMENT.
AUTHORITY TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
POISON CONTROL SYSTEM. THIS
AUGMENTATION IS BEING REQUESTED
TO INCREASE SALARIES AND BENEFIT
EXPENSES RESULTING FROM
NEGOTIATED UNION BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS. AND WILL CONTINUE
THE STABLE FUNDING FOR DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS OF. CALIFORNIA
POISON CONTROL SYSTEM. AND
CONTINUE STATEWIDE ACCESS TO
POISON CENTER SERVICES IN THE
EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY. THE
REQUESTED FUNDING AUGMENTATION
WILL PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. BY MAINTAINING A
NETWORK OF TRAINED EXPERTS. WHO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WITH TELEPHONE
INFORMATION AND ADVICE ABOUT.
EXPOSURE OF HOMELESSNESS
HAZARDOUS OR TOXIC SUBSTANCES.
THE TOLL FREE HOTLINE TELEPHONE
INFORMATION ADVICE ABOUT
EXPOSURE POINT POINT OUT CERTAIN
POISONOUS HAZARDOUS OR TOXIC
SUBSTANCES. OR REMAIN AVAILABLE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY. AND
ALSO SEE PCS SERVICES WILL
CONTINUE TO BE PROVIDED ALL
COMMUNITIES. INCLUDING UNDER
SERVING INTERJECTIONS. IN OVER
TWO HUNDRED LANGUAGES VIA THE
KATHMANDU VIA THE CALIFORNIA
RELAY SERVICE FOR HEARING
IMPAIRED. OR SPEECH IMPAIRED
CALLERS. BY THE THIRD. IS THE
PARAMOUNT DISTANCE RE BOARD OR
AB FOR FIFTY. MS OUR REQUEST
THREE POSITIONS AND SEVEN
HUNDRED THREE THOUSAND. A MERCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND.
SPECIAL FIND IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT CHAPTER FOUR SIX THREE
STATUTES OF. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY. AB FOUR
FIFTY CREATES A SEVEN MEMBER
APPOINTED INDEPENDENT BOARD WITH
EMPHASIS STATUTORILY AUTHORIZED
TO DO THE FOLLOWING. REVIEW AND
DETERMINE WHETHER DOT MODIFY
REJECT AND RETURN FOR FURTHER
HEARING PROPOSED DISTRICTS
DECISIONS FROM MINISTRY OF LAW
JUDGES REGARDING PARAMEDIC
LICENSE HOLDERS. TAKING
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST A
CALIFORNIA PARAMEDIC LICENSE
HOLDER HERE AND OR ACT ON
APPLICANTS APPEALS FOLLOWING HIS
DENIAL OF THE LICENSURE. DEVELOP
CRITERIA FR THE BOARD TO
SUSPEND PLACE ON PROBATION OR
REVOKE A LICENSE. DEVELOP
CRITERIA CHANGE AND MAKING FINAL
DETERMINATIONS REGARDING APPEALS
OF LICENSURE ACTIONS. AND REVIEW
AND REVISE EXISTING CRITERIA FOR
THE SUSPENSION OF A PARAMEDIC
LICENSE. WITHOUT THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES POSITIONS
AND FUNDING AND THE WILL BE
UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
MANDATED REQUIREMENTS. OF EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY. THE END MY OVER
THANK. THANK YOU DR PAN YOU HAVE
QUESTION ON THE SEVENTH OF THE
FIRST OF ALL I REALLY- PUTTING
CONTROLS FOR IMPORTANT- THE
QUESTION I HAD. IN TERMS OF THE
UPGRADES ON THE VEHICLE AND
RADIO FLEET ASSETS- LOOKS LIKE
BASICALLY IT SO I GUESS. YOU
KNOW EACH OF THESE RADIOS I MEAN
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH
ELEVEN THOUSAND FOR THE OTHER
TYPE OF RADIO BUT- IS THERE
WHAT'S THE EXPECTED LIFESPAN OF
THIS OF THESE RADIOS SO I KNOW
LOOKS LIKE THIS IS A ONE TIME
MOST OF MY IS GOING TO BUY THEM
THE ONLY A FIFTY THOUSAND I'M
GOING FOR A SUBSCRIPTION. AT
WHAT POINT WOULD WE HAVE TO
REPLACE THESE RADIOS. I HEARD
OUR CHIEF OF THE DISASTER
MEDICAL SERVICES DIVISION IS MY
PARTNER FOR THIS PROPOSAL SO I
DEFER TO HIM ON THAT QUESTION.
YEAH THANK YOU RICK THIS IS
CRAIG JOHNSON CHIEF INVESTMENT
SERVICE DIVISION AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- QUESTION AND YOU KNOW-
TECHNOLOGY DOES CHANGE- LET YOU
KNOW BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
EXISTING RADIO SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR LEADS. AND MUCH OF
OUR FLEET DATES BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN- WE HAVE NOT
HAD TO REPLACE. YOU KNOW VERY
INFREQUENTLY OVER THE YEARS SO
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY EXPECT THAT-
THESE FLEETS OF COMMUNICATION
UPGRADES TO LAST YOU KNOW REALLY
FIVE SEVEN YEARS OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO ANOTHER WORDS AND I'M JUST
SINCE WE'RE BUYING A WHOLE BUNCH
THAT MEANS IN FIVE SEVEN YEARS
WE SHOULD BE EXPECTING TO
REPLACE THAT THAT'S THE USUAL
LIFESPAN. SURE. THAT THE REST OF
THE QUESTIONS OF THANK YOU. OKAY
AND I JUST A QUESTION I. USING
CONTROL AND HAVING TO AUGMENT
THE MORE HAVE WE SEEN AN A
PEOPLE CALL- AFTER INGESTING
THINGS. THAT WE WOULDN'T EXPECT
PEOPLE TO BE INGESTING THAT ARE
POISONOUS. DURING THE PANDEMIC
IN THE CIVIC I'M ASKING. SORRY I
DON'T REALLY HAVE THAT DATA IN
FRONT OF ME BUT FROM MY LAST
HEARING OF THE DATA SUBMITTED.
PROGRAM THE NUMBER OF A POISON
CONTROL CENTER CALLS HAVE NOT
INCREASES IN HAS NOT INCREASED
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYTHING FROM THE L. A. O. ON
THIS. NO AS THIS IS WHAT YOU
PAID FOR THE L. A. O. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE REVIEWED THAT
PROPOSALS FOR AND THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY AND
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. NO CONCERNS
THANK YOU. OKAY THEN I THINK
WE'LL THANKED THE AMOUNTS FOR
THEIR THEIR FRIEND PRESENTATION
WE HOPE THE LIVE DIRECTORS WELL
WE MISTER BUT YOU DID A FINE JOB
OF FILLING IN- AND NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO- THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE AND ACCESS
INFORMATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR PAN I'M ELIZABETH PLANS
BURKE DIRECTOR OF H. CHI THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION FORMERLY OCCUPIED
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT AND I
AM PLEASED TO START WITH THE
OVERVIEW OF OUR DEPARTMENT. H.
KAISE MISSION IS TO EXPAND
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS ENSURING
EVERY COMMUNITY HAS THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE THEY NEED. SAFE AND
RELIABLE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
AND HEALTH INFORMATION THAT CAN
HELP MAKE CARE MORE EFFECTIVE
AND AFFORDABLE. AS YOU KNOW LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET TRANSITION OPTION
AT THE AGE CRIED BIG KOWLEDGE
SHARING ARE GROWING
RESPONSIBILITIES AND EXPANDING
PORTFOLIO WAITED TIME TO RECAST
AND MODERNIZE THE OFFICE AS A
STATE DEPARTMENT. THREE CAST AGE
CRYING CREWS CREATION OF A NEW
HEALTH CALIFORNIA HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
COUNCIL WHICH WILL PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON STATEWIDE HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION TRAINING
NEEDS. FOR PRIMARY CARE NURSING
ORAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL AN ALLIED
HEALTH. FOURTEEN OF THE FIFTEEN
MEMBERS OF THE COUNCIL HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED- NAMES AND WE ARE IN
PLANNING TO HAVE OUR FIRST
COUNCIL MEETING THE SPRING. THE
NEW CALIFORNIA HEALTH WORKFORCE
RESEARCH DATA CENTER WAS ALSO
PART OF THE RECAST AND THAT WILL
SERVICE THE STATE'S CENTRAL HUB
OF HEALTH WORKFORCE DATA. WITH
NEW STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
COLLECT ADDITIONAL WORKFORCE
DATA. WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND LICENSING BOARDS ON
THE DATA COLLECTION QUESTIONS
AND PROCESSES TO GET THIS
IMPORTANT. SUPPLY SIDE
INFORMATION. THE BUDGET
DISCONTINUE THE FIVE OH ONE SEE
THREE STRUCTURE OF THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION FOUNDATION
WHILE MAINTAINING ALL OF THE
WORK FORCE PROGRAMS. THE STATE
OFFICE OF RURAL HEALTH AND THE
J. ONE VISA WAIVER PROGRAM FOR
INTEGRATED FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND H.
KAISE PRIMARY CARE OFFICE. TO
PROVIDE A CENTRALIZED APPROACH
TO WORKING WITH RURAL
COMMUNITIES ON HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
NEEDS- THAT THAT TRANSITION WAS
VERY SEAMLESS OMINOUS TAKEN
PLACE. THE REQUEST ALSO INCLUDED
SOME CHANGES TO H. GUYS DATA
PROGRAMS INCLUDING GREATER
FLEXIBILITY WITH THE OUTCOMES
REPORTING ON SURGICAL CARDIAC
PROCEDURES AND IMPROVED ACCESS
TO BIRTH AND DEATH DATA SO THOSE
WERE THE NEW PIECES ON THE
RECAST ON THERE ALSO SIGNIFICANT
AUGMENTATIONS TO WORK FORCE.
WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT IN A
MINUTE- BUT I WANTED TO ALSO
JUST GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
LONGSTANDING WORK. PREACH CHRIST
SERVICES CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING
DEPARTMENT FOR HOSPITALS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. WE
PROVIDE PLAN REVIEW AND APPROVAL
OF HOSPITAL AND SKILLED NURSING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. AND ISSUE
BUILDING PERMITS AND PERFORM
CONSTRUCTION OBSERVATION OF
HOSPITAL AND SKILLED NURSING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. H. CRIED
DEVELOPS BUILDING STANDARDS FOR
HOSPITALS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES CLINICS AND
CORRECTIONAL TREATMENT CENTERS
AND ADMINISTERS THE HOSPITAL
SEISMIC RETROFIT PROGRAM. WE
ALSO HAVE THE CAL MORTGAGE LOAN
INSURANCE PROGRAM CORRECT CAL
MORTGAGE WHICH PROVIDES LOW COST
FINANCING TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE
FOR HEALTHCARE ENTITIES TO
CONSTRUCT NEW FACILITIES ACQUIRE
AND RUNNING RENOVATE EXISTING
BUILDINGS AND A COMPLETE
SEISMIC- UPGRADES AND OTHER
PROJECTS. THE SENATE WILL
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES TO DEVELOP
FOR EXPAND SERVICES AND WE FOCUS
ON THOSE THAT PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR UNDER SERVED AND THAT RISK
POPULATE POPULATIONS TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
WORKING ON SOME OF OUR-
INFORMATION SERVICES WORK WE
COLLECT MANAGE AND PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE FACILITY LEVEL DATA
FROM NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA LICENSED FACILITIES
INCLUDING HOSPITALS LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES. CLINICS AND
HOSPICES. THESE DATA INCLUDE
FINANCIAL UTILIZATION PATIENT
CHARACTERISTICS AND SERVICE
INFORMATION. H. I ALSO PROVIDES
PUBLIC INFORMATION ABOUT
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS UNDER
THE SB SEVENTEEN CAL CALORIES
PROGRAMS- NONPROFIT HOSPITAL
COMMUNITY BENEFIT PLANS
HOSPITAL'S CHARGEMASTER
DOCUMENTS AUTHORIZED SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY REPORTS AND HOSPITAL
DISCOUNT PAYMENT POLICIES. WE
UNIT WE ANALYZE HEALTHCARE DATA
AND PROVIDE RISK ADJUSTED
INDICATORS FOR HOSPITALS AND
OTHER INFORMATION IN A WIDE WIDE
VARIETY OF DATA PRODUCTS ON OUR
WEBSITE. PAGE CHI CAN EXPECT
SPECIAL STUDIES ON TRENDS IN
QUALITY AND SAFETY OF AN ACCESS
TO HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA ON
TOPICS SUCH AS PREVENTABLE
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS.
READMISSIONS RACE AND ETHNICITY
DISPARITIES AND PATIENT SAFETY.
PAGE CAIRO DATA PROGRAMS
REGULARLY REGULARLY ENGAGE THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPROVE HEALTH
CARE QUALITY THROUGH STRUCTURED
AUDIENCE IDENTIFICATION
COMMUNITY OUT REACH AND
REQUIREMENTS ELICITATION. WE ARE
DEVELOPING THE HEALTHCARE
PAYMENTS BETA OR HBV PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA'S ALL PAIRS CLAIMS
DATABASE WHICH WILL SUPPORT
GREATER HEALTH CARE
TRANSPARENCY. INFORMED POLICY
DECISIONS SUPPORTING QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AND HELP AID IN THE
REDUCTION OF HEALTH CARE COSTS
DISPARITIES. AND LAST BUT VERY
MUCH NOT LEAST AND CERTAINLY I'M
NOT IN THIS YEAR WHERE WE FACE
SO MANY- HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
CRISES WE HAVE OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
WHICH IMPROVE ACCESS TO PRIMARY
CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
DENTAL CARE PROVIDERS IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. WE CONDUCT
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE RESEARCH TO
IDENTIFY AREAS OF UNMET NEEDS
AND UNDERSTAND THE HEALTH
EDUCATION PIPELINE. H. BECAUSE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE GRANT
PROGRAMS PROVIDE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE UNDER
REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS TO
PURSUE HEALTH CARE CAREERS AND
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IN AREAS OF UNMET
NEEDS. AS CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE NEEDS EXPAND H. GUYS NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR SUBSTANTIALLY
MORE WORK WITH VERY LARGE
INCREASES- AND THAT'S TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET YEAR INCLUDING
NEW AREAS OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- THE CHART ON PAGE
THIRTY THREE. YOUR STAFF
INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA SHOWS HOW
ARE FUNDING AND RESPONSIBILITIES
HAVE GROWN SUBSTANTIALLY I'M NOW
HAPPY TO HAND THE BATON TO KAREN
RIGHT SELL H. GUYS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
WHO'S BEEN WORKING INCREDIBLY
HARD TO IMPLEMENT OUR NEW
PROGRAMS AND WILL PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BUDGET ACT INVESTMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA. IF I
COULD JUST ASK ONE OF COURSE AND
IT'S NICE IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU
AS A DIRECTOR- JUST FOR THE
RECORD WE'VE HAD A LOT OF. MONEY
GOING OUT- I KEEP LOOKING I
SHOULD LOOK AT WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF MONEY GOING OUT REPEATEDLY
FOR THE NEW CONSTRUCTION THE
UPGRADE THAT BUILDING. A FOR NEW
FACILITIES TO BE ABLE TO MEET
OUR DEMAND- DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOUR LIKE WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
GO WITH THE PLANS AND THEN WE
KEEP HEARING ABOUT A BACK UP AND
HOW LONG IT TAKES. IS YOUR
DEPARTMENT AGENCY BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY WORK TO EXPEDITE- THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO THE
REHABILITATION TO BE ABLE TO GET
AS MANY. FACILITIES. UP AND
RUNNING AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SO WANT YOUR ABOUT.
BUILDING CURRENT. YES SO THERE
ARE RIGHT OF MILESTONES- IN
TERMS OF SEISMIC CONSTRUCTION.
SEISMIC REQUIREMENTS ON THE
NUMBER OF DEADLINES THAT HAD TO
BE MET BY TWENTY TWENTY AND
THERE ARE SOME EXTENSIONS AND
ANOTHER SET OF. REQUIREMENTS
THAT NEED TO BE MET BY TWENTY
THIRTY SO- I'VE BEEN VERY
IMPRESSED WITH OUR TEAM AND THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THEY TAKE
IN WORKING WITH FACILITIES TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE A
VERY PROBLEM SOLVING APPROACH-
AND WORKING WITH HOSPITALS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. SO
THERE ARE CERTAINLY SOME
CHALLENGES AND CO THAT HAS
SLOWED- SOME OF OUR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS BUT THEY'RE MOVING
ALONG AND AGAIN WE WORK WITH
WITH EACH FACILITY TO TRY TO
MEET THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. I
GUESS I GUESS I'M SPEAK MORE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT SOME OF THE-
REAL HEALTH. WHICH WOULD GO
THROUGH SOME ACUTE CARE AND SOME
MORE SKILLED. FACILITY TYPE.
PROGRAM SO ARE YOU ALSO. RE
CENTERING YOUR WORK ON SOME OF
THAT PRIORITY THAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW YEAH I'M HAPPY TO HAVE
IT IF CARL SHERMAN OR OR CHRIS
JOKE IS FUNDS TO HELP JUMP IN
SPECIFICALLY ON SOME OF OUR WORK
ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FACILITIES- WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THAT MADAM CHAIR AND OR
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU. CARLA
CHRIS ARE YOU ABLE TO. CALL YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT. YES SIR
THANK YOU ARE MADAM DIRECTOR
AND- MADAM CHAIR- AS- AS THE
ORGANIZATION CHANGES FROM ARCH
PART TWO H. CHI THE EMPHASIS ON
ACCESS TO CARE IS BEING APPLIED
TO THE BUILDING DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS THE OTHER TWO AGENTS
WITH IN H. CHI WE'RE LOOKING NOW
AT HOW WE CAN IMPROVE OUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE BOTH IN TERMS
OF HOW WE CAN DELIVER. THE- THE
PLAN REVIEW AND CONSTRUCTION
OBSERVATION IN A MORE CUSTOMER
CENTRIC MANNER BUT ALSO AT THE
SAME TIME HOW WE CAN WORK WITH
OUR CLIENTS THAT IN ADVANCE OF
THEM BRINGING IN THEIR PROJECTS
TO ENSURE THAT WHAT THEY BRING
TO US IS SOMETHING THAT'S
CAPABLE OF MOVING THROUGH THE
PROCESS MORE SMOOTHLY. SO WITH
THAT I BELIEVE WE'RE MOVING IN
THE DIRECTION OF THAT YOU'RE
ASKING US TO DO. AT THE RICH.
LIKE DID YOU USE THAT THE TERM
CUSTOMER SERVICE I'VE- NEVER
FORGET I WAS AMAZED AND I WAS IN
THE CITY COUNCIL MEETING YOU SAW
TALK TALK ABOUT THAT AS A
PRIORITY. AND A LOT OF EMPLOYEES
SEEM SURPRISED BY THAT BUT YES
THE PUBLIC IS OUR BIGGEST-
CONSTITUENT AND WHO WE NEED TO
BE SERVING. SO I BY APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS. AND WILL
CERTAINLY BE FOLLOWING UP ON
THIS. CONSISTENTLY BECAUSE AS WE
ALL KEEP TELLING EVERYBODY THAT
THERE'S THERE ARE THINGS COMING
IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING TO HEAR
FROM. OUR STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO WAIT ON THE STATE.
BUDGET PLAN. THANK YOU AND AGAIN
REPEAT THE OVERVIEW FROM THE
DIRECTOR- GIVEN THE FACT THAT
EACH GUY FORMALLY OSHKOSH YOU OF
THE WORK FORCE PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
THE SAME WAY THAT- CHAIR EGGMAN
TALKED ABOUT ON THE FACILITY
SIDE. AND WE'RE ALSO COLLECTING
A LOT OF DATA ON SERVICE THE
PAYMENT SIDE. AS WELL- ARE WE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE WORK FORCE SIDE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A BIG FOCUS ON
PIPELINE RIGHT HOW MANY PROGRAM
HOW WE TRAIN PROGRAMS TRAINING
POSITIONS YOU KNOW THAT CENTER.
ARE WE ALSO LOOKING. ON THE
PAYMENT SIDE SO THE PAYMENTS
SUFFICIENT TO RETAIN PEOPLE IN
THIS FIELD SO FOR EXAMPLE LET'S
JUST TAKE NURSING FACILITIES I
THINK WE HAVE SOME PROGRAMS TO
GET MORE CNA'S INTO NURSING.
HOMES BUT- WE ALSO KNOW PEOPLE
LEAVE THE FIELD IT'S A DOUBTS
LOCATES VERY TOUGH IT'S ADDRESS.
AND TO PROVIDE INPUT INTO FOR
NOT YOU KNOW- TERMS OF LOOKING
AT WELL I MEAN WE CAN FEED MORE
PEOPLE THE PIPELINE THAT PEOPLE
ARE LEAKING OUT THE OTHER SIDE
BECAUSE THE WORKING CONDITIONS
ARE GREAT. THE PAYS TOO LOW IT'S
OUR- THEN WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CATCH UP AND THEN ALSO TO ADVISE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS SO FOR EXAMPLE
MEDIC HOUSE MAJOR PAYER FOR
NURSING FACILITY OFFERS NURSING
FACILITIES. EIGHTY THERE YOU
KNOW THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO PAY PEOPLE
AT THE LEVEL THAT WILL HELP
RETAIN THEM. THOSE ARE THE- DOES
EACH KIND OF LOOK THE HOUSE IS
CONSIDERING THOSE TYPES OF
ANALYSES AS WELL SO IT'S
CERTAINLY IT'S GREAT TO FOCUS ON
PIPELINE ON WORKFORCE BUT THIS
ALSO RETENTION. YOU KNOW YOU I
KNOW THAT THEIR LIFE PHYSICIANS
PLAN TO RETIRE. IT HAD IT SO YOU
KNOW WE COULD LOSE A LOT OF OUR
WORK FORCE THAT AY TOO AND IT
AND I THINK THERE'S OTHER OTHER
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WELL
NURSING I'VE BEEN HEARING THAT
AS WELL. SO IS THERE ARE STILL
ORDERS TIED THOSE TYPES OF
ANALYSES- BEING CONSIDERED BY.
EACH TIME WHEN IT LOOKS AT WORK
FORCE. ABSOLUTELY CENTER PANS SO
FAR OF THE RE. DATA CENTER AND-
THE BUDGET. THERE WAS. IN A ONE
THIRD THREE LEFT YEAR INCLUDES.
AS AS I NOTED. INCREASED DATA
FROM THE LICENSING BOARD SO WE
NEED TO. HAVE BETTER SUPPLY SIDE
DATA A DEMAND DATA. SO WE- GOT
THAT MATT MEDICAL BOARD IS DONE
THE BEST OF THE SIXTEEN OR
EIGHTEEN- HEALING ARTS LICENSING
BOARDS BUT THERE WILL BE A- A
STANDARD SET OF. DATA THAT'S
COLLECTED WHICH DOES INCLUDE
RETIREMENT PLANS- CLINICAL HOURS
BECAUSE WE NEED TO NOT JUST LOOK
AT HOW MANY. PROVIDERS WE HAVE
IN THE VARIOUS AREAS BUT WHAT
THE RETIREMENT PLANS ARE WHAT
WHERE THEY PRACTICING. SO WE ARE
TRYING TO LOOK HOLISTICALLY. AT
RECRUITMENT. HIRING RETENTION
AND ADVANCEMENT RIGHT SO I THINK
A LOT OF THE TALK THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS- IN ADDITION TO HOW DO WE
HAVE BY PLAN PROGRAMS AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS IS HOW DO WE-
PROVIDE ADVANCEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS WHO WANT
TO PROMOTE WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE. SAID OF CAREERS IN
HOW DO WE- CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
THEM SO THAT THEY CAN PROMOTE SO
YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE ABOUT OUR
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE
C. N. A.'S WHICH YOU'LL-
HIGHLIGHTED- AND THOSE. ALL
BASICALLY WE ARE TRYING TO WORK-
ON EVERY HEALTHCARE
CLASSIFICATION- FROM PEER
SUPPORT WORKERS ALL THE WAY UP
TO DOCTORS AND PSYCHIATRISTS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE NEED IS SO
GREAT. I HAVE A PRE SHEET THAT I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT FOR
EXAMPLE- STUDY WAS DONE SHOULD
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS ONLY
SPENT 28% 28% OF THEIR TIME
DOING CLINICAL WORK THE REST OF
THE TIME WAS DOING
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD. DO WE
WANT TO DOUBLE OUR PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE IF WE COULD JUST HAVE
PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS BE ALLOWED
TO SPEND 50% JUST HALF THEIR
TIME DOING CLINICAL WORK WE
COULD ALMOST DOUBLE OR PRIMARY
CARE WORKFORCE. SO WE REALLY
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS OVERHEAD
PROBLEM TOO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OKAY
SO LET'S WORK MEN MOVE INTO-
CHILDREN USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE I THINK YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT NEXT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- I'M KAREN REYES OUT
IN. CHARLOTTE W. TRACTOR HOPE
YOUR WORK FORCE YOUR H. CHI AND
I'LL SHARE SOME INFORMATION
ABOUT OUR WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
THIS. YEAR I'M SORRY H. CARLY C.
AGE SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDS FOR THE CHILDREN USE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. INITIATIVE IN
THIS LAST BUDGET I'M THESE FANS
WERE SPLIT ACROSS NINE MODULES.
ON WHICH INCLUDED. CREATING A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. COACH AND
WORK FOR. USING THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH MARK. I'M INTRIGUED ME
ENDING TRAINING CAPACITY FOR
TRAINING PSYCHIATRISTS ND
SOCIAL WORKERS BUILDING THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PIPELINE. I'M LOOKING AT
BUILDING EARN AND LEARN
APPRENTICESHIP MODELS. ENHANCING
TRAINING JUST SERVE JUSTICE AND
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOU. AN
EXPANDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRAINING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. AND ALSO ENHANCING
AND EXPANDING OUR PAIR PERSONAL
TRAINING AND PLACEMENT PROGRAM
AND THEN FINALLY AUGMENTING OUR
EXISTING H. KAILANI PAYMENT
SCHOLARSHIP AND STATEMENT
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE OR
SOMETHING. AND SO WHAT I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF
THAT ON THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING IN THESE AREAS. AROUND
THAT- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACHING
COUNCIL WORKFORCE AND WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THAT
MULTI YEAR PLAN TO LAUNCH ANY
EMPLOYMENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COACHING COUNSELOR SYSTEM- AS
WAS TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
EDUCATION AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
THIS PLAN INCLUDES CONDUCTING
WITH. AND FAMILIES AND OTHER
PARTNERS AND- WE. ARE BEGINNING
THAT PROCESS NOW- WE HAVE A
EMPLOYED CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
TRAIN YOUR TRAINER PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIP SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM-
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
FOR PROVIDING THAT TRAINING TO
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS WE HAVE
ALREADY AWARDED ABOUT ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN SCHOLARSHIPS
THIS YEAR TRAINING OVER ONE
HUNDRED PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS.
WE ARE PREPARING TO OPEN GRANT
APPLICATION CYCLES THIS SPRING
AND EARLY SUMMER FOR THE
FOLLOWING ACTIVITIES. OUR
PSYCHIATRY EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION PROGRAM HE SAYS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRAINING
CAPACITY FOR PSYCHIATRISTS
INCLUDING CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
FELLOWSHIP. WE ARE OPENING A
GRANT CYCLE FOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONS CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM AS WAS MENTIONED THAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PIPELINE. WE WILL ALSO BE
OPENING OUR CYCLE FOR RIGHT AND
ENHANCING AND EXPANDING REPAIR
PERSONNEL TRAINING AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAM ESPECIALLY TO REALLY
TRAIN AND CERTIFY NUCLEAR
PERSONNEL SERVING CHILDREN AND
YEAR. AND FINALLY TO OPENING OUR
LOAN REPAYMENT AND SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
. UPCOMING AT ACTIVITIES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STRUGGLING
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK TO PLAN AND
TO AUGMENT AND BUILD AS YOU DNS
SERVERS SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE RECOGNIZING HOW
CRITICAL THAT IS RIGHT NOW AND
COMPLETE THAT PLANNED- BY JULY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE RE
CONDUCTING RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS
TO BUILD A SOCIAL WORK CAPACITY
EXPANSION PROGRAM UNDERSTANDING
THE NEED AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BUILDING- THE SOCIAL WORK OUR
WORK FORCE IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CLUB PLANS TO START THAT IN THE
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE PLAN
TO LAUNCH NEW EARNING LEARN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN LATE
SUMMER OR FALL. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND WE'RE MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO BUILD A WORKFORCE THAT
EFFECTIVELY SERVES SYSTEM AND
JUSTICE INVOLVED HERE. I CAN
RELATE TO THE OTHER INVESTMENTS
I AGE I RECEIVED AROUND
WORKFORCE- THIS LAST AS PER
YEAR. WE RECEIVED THE FOLLOWING
FUNDING FOR SONG BROWN WE
RECEIVE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
SONG BROWN- FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PRIMARY CARE NEW PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. WE ARE IN
DEVELOPING THE PLANS FOR
AUGMENTING OUR EXISTING SONG
BROWN PROGRAM WITH THIS NEW
FINDING THEM ALL OPEN THE GRANT
CYCLE IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ALSO RECEIVED- TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND SONG
BROWN NURSING PRE LICENSURE ARE
IN PROGRAMS- WE JUST COMPLETED
THE APPLICATION CYCLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND WILL BE AWARDING
TWENTY THREE PROGRAMS OVER NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN AWARDS- WE
ALSO RECEIVED EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
BUILD THE WORKFORCE SERVING
OLDER ADULTS. USING OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE HAVE ALREADY AWARDED
OVER ONE POINT THREE MILLION IN
FUNDING TO PROVIDERS SERVING
OLDER ADULTS THROUGH PROGRAMS
SUCH AS A STEVEN THEM THOMPSON
PHYSICIAN CORP ON REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BAR REPAYMENT PROGRAM. WE
WILL ALSO USE THESE FUNDS TO
AUGMENT OTHER EXISTING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS OUR HEALTH CAREERS
EXPLORATION PROGRAM. AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER TALKING ABOUT
THE CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
WORKFORCE WE RECEIVED- FUNDING
TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS BUILDING THE
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
WORKFORCE. WE HAVE AWARDED A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR GRANT TO AN
ORGANIZATION EMPOWERED AGING.
AMPLE IMPLEMENTED ACNA HOUSE
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAM. WE ARE
WORKING WITH A CONSULTANT WHO
HAS COMPLETED STAKEHOLDER
OUTREACH AND A NEEDS ASSESSMENT
LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS
AND OBSTACLES AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR BUILDING THE CNA WORKFORCE
WE'RE BEGINNING PRIORITIZATION
AND DESIGN WORK NOW TO DETERMINE
HOW TO BEST BUILT AND SUPPORT
THIS WORKFORCE. WE EXPECT TO
OPEN YOUR FUNDING CYCLES IN A
WAR JUST ONE PROGRAMS- IN THIS
YEAR. AND THEN FINALLY AROUND
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM WE RECEIVED
SIXTEEN MILLION AN ONGOING
FUNDING THAT ALLOWS US TO
ORGANIZE AND BUILD HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS UNDER THE- H.
PCAOB PORTFOLIO. WE ARE
DEVELOPING PLANS FOR A NEW
PIPELINE PROGRAM AND WILL OPEN
IN FUNDING CYCLE OF THE MID
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE ARE ALSO
AUGMENTING OUR HEALTH CAREERS
EXPLORATION PROGRAM FORMALLY
KNOWN AS ARE MANY PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT CAREER EXPLORATION
GRANTS. WE ALSO RECEIVED FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL SCHOLARS PROGRAM WE'RE
EXECUTING THIS GRANT AGREEMENT
WITH THE MANAGING ENERGY WILL
CONDUCT THIS PROGRAM- HAVE BEEN
TAKEN. WHAT DO YOU MEAN WHEN YOU
SAY SOCIAL WORKER. MANY RANGE OF
SOCIAL WORK PROFESSIONS- MASTER
SOCIAL WORK- BSW MSW THE SOCIAL
WORK POFESSION OKAY LICENSE
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS THANK
YOU THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO HEAR
BUT THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE I GUESS YOU KNOW WHICH IS
ONE OF MY PET PEEVES THAT WE
DON'T HAVE. PROTECTION AROUND
THAT TITLE SO WHEN WE SAY
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF SOCIAL
WORKERS THERE ARE. COUNTY
PROGRAMS ARE ALL KINDS OF
PROGRAMS AND HIRE PEOPLE AS
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE NEVER
BEEN. IN A CLASSROOM FOR A
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL WORK SO
MAYBE. MAYBE THROUGH THIS
PROCESS WE CAN MAKE SOME CHANGES
IN THAT BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN.
ABLE TO DO THAT IN THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE CORRECT IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOCIAL WORKERS AND IT IS
IT IS A- PROFESSION. THAT THEN
WE SHOULD ACTUALLY HIRE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE RECEIVED DEGREES IN
THAT PROFESSION- AND ALONG THAT
LINE I THINK I JUST DESPICABLE.
SO I THINK B. S. W.'S ARE ARE
FINE PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THE COACHES IN AN
ENTRY LEVEL PEOPLE. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. WORKING TOGETHER WITH
SYSTEMS IN OUR EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERS- COMING FROM A DIVISION
OF SOCIAL WORKER OR SOCIAL WORK
WHERE WE USED TO HAVE. OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MSW
STUDENTS AND A VERY SMALL BSW
PROGRAM. THAT HAS NOW FLIPPED.
WE HAVE VIRTUALLY INCREDIBLY
SMALL MSW PROGRAM AND A VERY BIG
BSW PROGRAM. BECAUSE OF COURSE
IT'S MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE TO.
HAVE A- BSW PROGRAM THAN AN MSW
PROGRAM BUT THAT PUT THE QUEUE
TO IMPACT THAN ON OUR SYSTEM SO
WHEN WE SAY WE HAVE TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT AT SCHOOLS
OFTENTIMES. IN ORDER TO DO THAT
AND MAKE THE BUDGET WE DO THAT
WITH THE- THE LESS EXPENSIVE
PROGRAM WHICH IS NOT MEETING OUR
NEEDS SO I WOULD JUST BRING THAT
TO YOUR ATTENTION WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING THAT.
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO TALK
ABOUT FUNDING THE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS
PEOPLE GET A BSW. THEN THEY GO
TO- AND PROGRAMS MOST IN THE
WORLD. AND GET AN MSW THAT
PERHAPS. WE WOULD LICENSE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO JUST
SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT. WHEN WE USE
LANGUAGE LIKE THAT AND I DIDN'T
MEAN TO PUT YOU ON THE SPOT BUT
IT IS A PET PEEVE OF MINE THAT.
WE USE THAT WORD WITHOUT REALLY.
MEANING OF THAT WORD. I'M SO
THIS MIGHT BE A VERY GOOD TIME
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE. IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT IT IS A WELL
TRAINED AND EFFECTIVE. WORK
FORCE AND NOT JUST BODIES
FILLING UP SLOTS- BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW I THINK HOW WE BURN PEOPLEOUT. VERY QUICKLY- I WILL START
PRINTING AND DOCTOR PAN HASN'T.
THANK YOU AND- AGAIN- PRECEDE
THE PRESENTATION I JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- SO AND I KNOW THAT-
IN THE PAST TO PASS A LITTLE BIT
AOUT THE HEALTH COACHES AND
COUNSELORS AND- IN TERMS OF
BETTER UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR-
ACTUAL ROLE WILL BE N. SO
RECOGNIZED IT. SO JUST BE SURE
THAT- WE KNOW WHAT THEIR ACTUAL
ROLES IS GOING TO BE IN JAIL
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THEIR- NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE FAIRLY
LIMITED TRAINING- YOU KNOW THE
TERMS WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS OF
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO. BUT THEN THE ALSO THE OTHER
PART IS- IN TERMS OF EXPANDING
TRAINING FOR PSYCHIATRY AND
SOCIAL WORKERS- THAT ALL MIXED
UP IN ONE LINE AND- SO SOCIAL
WORKERS AT THEIR OWN PARTY SINCE
I CHARACTERS HAVE THEIR OWN
EXPERTISE SO WE MIGHT WANT TO
PARSE OUT EXACTLY HOW MUCH OF
THIS IS. A PSYCHO CUT PSYCHIATRY
AND THAT'S FOR SOCIAL WORKERS SO
INSTEAD OF JUST SERVE BLENDING
IT ALL TOGETHER ONE ONE ONE SOME
SOFA SO MIGHT BE TO BREAK THAT
OUT MORE SPECIFICALLY. IN THE-
UPDATE. THE CENTERPIECE LOS. OF
THE REAL HEALTH COACHES. ON THE
THIS. OF THE- ARE UNDER- WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED IN SOME- GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH EDUCATION
PARTNERS SO KAREN I'VE SPENT.
MANY HOURS OVER THE LAST MONTH
LEARNING MORE ABOUT- EDUCATIONAL
PERSONNEL AND WHAT HOW THIS WORK
FORCE MIGHT BE MOST HELPFUL IN
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE IS
ABLE TO. PRACTICE AT THE TOP OF
THEIR LICENSE ARE AT THE TOP OF
THEIR- AREA OF EXPERTISE WE'RE
ALSO VERY COMMITTED TO ENGAGING
IN A CO DESIGN PROCESS WITH YOU
FROM CELLS. AND SO WE DO PLAN TO
SPEND THE NEXT FEW MONTHS REALLY
TRYING TO GET THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACH ROLE RIGHT SO. I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE A- YOU.
ARE THAT WAY WHAT THE EXACT WILL
WILL BE BUT WE HAVE BEEN- BUSILY
ENGAGED. IN LOOKING MODELS AND-
WITH STATE CALL. AND ALL I'LL
LET CARE. ED PLEASE PLEASE THAT
YES WE DO HAVE POTS OF MONEY ON
ON PSYCHIATRY AND SOCIAL WORKERS. THERE'S A PROPOSED MANY
JESSICA I KNOW HER DAD OKAY I
WAS SEARCHING FOR SOMEONE WILL
FOLLOW UP ON THAT JUST YET WE DO
HAVE SEPARATE PROGRAMS FOR THAT
WE HAVE AN EXISTING PROGRAM FOR-
EXPANDING TRAINING AROUND
PSYCHIATRY. OKAY I'M AND THEN
WE'RE DEVELOPING A NEW PROGRAM
AROUND BUILDING CAPACITY TO
TRAIN US SOCIAL WORKERS OKAY SO
YOU'LL GET BACK IN TERMS OF
EXACTLY HOW MUCH GOES IN EACH.
OKAY AND- I KNOW PEOPLE LIKE THE
- PRACTICE AT THE TOP OF THE
LICENSE BUT WE HAVE TO BE SURE
THAT SKILLS AND WHAT IS THE
TOPIC LICENSE PLATES THE MEANS
SO- I THINK WITH A- LITTLE MORE
CAREFUL ABOUT. USING THAT TIME
TERMINOLOGY. BUT YEAH AND DID
PRECIADO ANY BACK- IN THE END WE
DON'T YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM IS I
DON'T WANT TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO.
EXPECTATIONS BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE SO
SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY WELL IN THE
SHORTAGE. SOMETHING'S BETTER
THAN NOTHING BUT THAT DOES THAT
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS MEAN
SOMETHING IS. BE THE BEST OR
EVEN GOOD RIGHT SO- AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S ALWAYS A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE A HUGE
DEMAND AND WE HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THE MAN BEFORE. YOU KNOW
YOU TRY TO STRETCH THE PEOPLE WE
HAVE BUT AT SOME POINT TIME YOU
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT- JUST
BECAUSE THEY SAW SOMEBODY.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
SOMEBODY HAS THE CAPACITY OR THE
SKILLS OR TRAINING. TO DELIVER
THE KIND OF CARE THAT WOULD BE
BEST FOR THAT PERSON. AND MAYBE
BETTER THAN NOTHING BUT TAT'S
STILL YOU KNOW INSPECTION WE
START TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WHO FALLS INTO THAT CAMP RATE SO
IT'S USUALLY PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE
DISADVANTAGED TO GET. THAT
CETERA WHO END UP FINDING
THEMSELVES THE SHORTS HANDSTAND
STICKS OH NO YOU GOT TAKEN CARE
OF. HE SAID YOU GOT TO SEE
SOMEBODY. DIED WE GET IT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT TRYING TO
GET ACCESS TO THE APPROPRIATELY
TRAINED PERSON. NOT JUST ANYBODY
AND- I KNOW THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU'RE ATTENTION IS. AND
CERTAINLY I THINK THERE IS A
PLACE IN A ROLE FOR THESE
COACHES AND COUNSELORS. BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE AND THAT IS MENTAL
HEALTH IS COMPLEX IT'S NOT EASY
TAKE CARE OF. SKY CONDITION AND
SO- WE NEED TO BE SURE WE HAVE
ENOUGH QUALIFIED PEOPLE. ARE
AVAILABLE TO TAKE CARE OF.
OFTENTIMES COMPLEX SITUATIONS.
IN A MINUTE I WANTED IT ALL
DEPENDED AND PUT TENSION ON ON
BOTH SIDES BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE
ALL. WE NEED WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT. THAT VERY EDUCATED IN AND
PREPARED WORK FORCE BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO HAVE. A PEOPLE WITH A
LOT OF LIFE EXPERIENCE OUT THERE
AS WELL AND SO AND THEN I THINK
WE'VE ALL BEEN OUT PROGRAMS AND
SING. GREAT EXAMPLES OF PROMOTE
TORTOISE AND NAVIGATORS AND ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE LIKE THAT SO
THAT IS PART OF THE FULL
CONTINUUM AND I THINK. I THINK
THE EXCITING THING ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW. IS WE ARE
NOT JUST LOOKING AT ONE PART OR
ANOTHER POT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE. AS IT RELATES
TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND WE KNOW
THAT THE SOONER WE GET PEOPLE
AND IF THEY'RE YOUNG. THAT
SOONER THAN LATER. THERE ARE
FEWER PROBLEMS THAN LATER THAT
IMPACT. IMPACT THE END OF OUR
HEALTH. FOR OUR- HEALTH
SPECTRUMS. WE DO WE DO
APPRECIATE. YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE- THE FULL CONTINUUM OF CARE
AS WE TALK ABOUT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. FAMILY AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT ATTENTION. OKAY- THE BELIAU. THANK U. S. SENATOR EGGMAN A
KOREAN SHEET WITH THE L. A. L.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON
SORT OF THE OVARY PORTION OF
THIS. ITEM ON THE AGENDA. ANY
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON THIS PART
. NO COMMENTS THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND DID YOU
WANT TO GO THROUGH THOSE SPEND
SPECIFIC. THE MANAGER RIGHT WE
ATTEMPTED TO RESPOND TO ALL OF
THE- QUESTIONS ON THE OVERVIEW
AND ARE HAPPY TO PROCEED WITH
THE BCPS IF YOU'D LIKE ESTO QUE.
I'M PERFECT LET'S GO. I HAD
MONICA YOU OKAY GREAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MONICA ERICKSON
ADMINISTRATIVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS A NET
ZERO SHIFT BETWEEN STATE
OPERATIONS AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
AND TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION OF
WHICH TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION IS
ONGOING. H. KILEY REQUEST
ONGOING REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY
FOR TWO PROGRAMS THE FIRST
PROGRAM IS FOR THE COUNTY
MEDICAL SERVICES LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. AND MULTI YEAR
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE. AS WE
EXPECT H. GUYS WORK WITH CMS P.
WILL BE ONGOING. THE SECOND
PROGRAM IS FOR SONG BROWN THE
PROGRAM RECEIVES REIMBURSEMENTS-
FROM THE UC'S AT THE TIME OF
LICENSURE OR RENEWAL PHYSICIANS
CAN MAKE A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION. AND THE
UC'S WILL MATCH THIS
CONTRIBUTION NEARLY
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE STEADILY
INCREASING AND H. I WILL NOT
HAVE THE REIMBURSEMENT OF FORTY
TWO AND THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
SECONDLY WE WERE AN INCREASE IN
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH DATA AND
PLANNING FUND FOR THE MANY
GRANTS PROGRAM THE MANY GRANTS
PROGRAM IS KEREN STATED IS A BY
PULLING PROGRAM THE SUPPORTS
UNDERREPRESENTED. ECONOMICALLY
AND EDUCATIONALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS AND PERCENT OF
HEALTHCARE CAREERS DURING THE
PAST THREE CYCLES. H. I. HAS
RECEIVED BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHT
AND FORTY ONE GRANT APPLICATIONS
PER YEAR AND HAS ONLY BEEN ABLE
TO AWARD EIGHT. FINALLY WE
REQUEST A ONE TIME INCREASE THAT
WOULD ALLOW H. CHI TO REWARD
FUNDS RETURNED MY RESIDENCY
PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OF
RESIDENTS. IN ADDITON TO THESE
INCREASES WE REQUEST THE BUDGET
ALIGNMENT THAT WOULD MOVE TWO
POINT ONE MILLION FROM STATE
OPERATIONS TO LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
THIS SHIFT WOULD REFLECT THE
CURRENT OPERATIONS OF THE
PERSONNEL AND MANY GRANTS
PROGRAM IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THOSE. THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S
JUST GOING TO THE NEXT ONE. ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR DR AND ISSUE NUMBER
THREE I'M MICHAEL BALLOT EVERY
DIRECTOR FOR INFORMATION
SERVICES- IS NUMBER THREE SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY EXPANDS FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURE REPORTING FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES ALSO CALLED
SNACKS BY REQUIRING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT OPERATE A
STAFF TO PREPARE. ANNUAL
CONSOLIDATED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS ARE RELATED ENTITIES
AND HAVE THE STATEMENTS REVIEWED
BY A CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT
UNLESS THOSE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS ARE ALREADY AUDITED
STARTING WITH. THE SAUDI FISCAL
YEARS ENDING DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE H. CHI
WILL COLLECT REVIEW AND PUBLISH
THESE CONSOLIDATE REPORTS TO ITS
H.
REPORTS FOR COMPLETENESS AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR REPORTING.
STANDARDS AGE BY WALKING TO
AUDIT THE INDIVIDUL STAFF
FINANCIAL STATEMENT SUBMITTED
PURSUANT TO CURRENT LAW AND POST
THOSE ON ITS INTERNET WEBSITE
FOR PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY.
CONSOLIDATED REPORTS ONE THIRD
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL OPERATING ENTITY AND
RELATED PARTIES THAT SHARE 5%
COMMON OWNERSHIP AND THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO. THE
FACILITY THE REPORTS WILL ALSO
INCLUDE OTHER DISCLOSURES AS
WELL AS A VISUAL REPRESENTATION
OF THE ORGANIZATION STRUCTURE
AND RELATED ENTITIES ALSO NEXT
WHETHER THEY HAVE RELATED
PARTIES ARE NOT. WOULD ALSO HAVE
TO DISCLOSE ORGANIZATIONAL
VISUAL REPRESENTS. A
COMMENCEMENT BOTH RELATED AND
NON RELATED ENTITIES THE NEW
WORKLOAD TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROVISIONS CANNOT BE ABSORBED
WITH CURRENT AGE I RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT PROVISIONS OF THE LAW
AGE GUYS REQUESTING PERSONNEL
RESOURCES TO ADMINISTER ITS
REPORT SUBMISSION. REVIEW AND
EVALUATE REPORTS AND PERFORM
COMPLIANCE ACTIVITIES THIS
INCLUDES STOP PUSHING AND
FORCING FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING.
AND AUDITING REQUIREMENTS H.
GUYS ALSO REQUESTING ONE TIME
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSULTING TO ENHANCE THE
CAPACITY OF ITS DOING AGE AND
TECHNOLOGY SAID. TRUCKS ARE TO
ME THE NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WITH THAT. I HAVE A
TAPE. I THINK WE- MOVE ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOR. OH THREE THESE.
RIGHT AFTERNOON- I CHEAP MERION
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR H. GUYS
MORTGAGE ENSURE PROGRAM. AND-
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THAT THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS FOR BILL
NINETY. WHICH CREE SOME X. TAX
ON CIGARETTES OF TWELVE AND A
HALF PERCENT ON THE SALES PRICE
COLLECTED BY RETAILERS BEGINNING
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
OF THE TOTAL TAXES COLLECTED 5%
WILL GO TO H. GUYS HEALTH
PROFESSIONS CAREER OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM AND 10% WILL GO TO A NEW
PROGRAM TO BE DEVELOPED WITHIN
H. GUY. CALLED THE SMALL AND
RURAL HOSPITAL RELIEF PROGRAM.
IT'S CARRIED MINISTERS PROGRAMS
FOR BUILDING AT A DIVERSE
PROVIDER WORKFORCE SUCH AS
HEALTH CAREERS EXPLORATIONS
PROGRAM. I FIND PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE ACADEMIC
ENRICHMENT CAREER DEVELOPMENT
MENTORSHIP IN ADVISING JUST OF
COURSE STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED REGIONS AND
BACKGROUNDS TO PURSUE HEALTH
CAREERS MANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS
WHICH ACTOR REPORTED OUT ON
EARLIER. H. K. BELIEVES THAT
THAT THE 5% OF THE SB THREE
NINETY FIVE FUNDS THAT WILL BE
GOING. TOWARDS THIS PROGRAM CAN
BE ABSORBED. WITH EXISTING STAFF
. IN REGARDING THE NEW SMALL AND
RURAL HOSPITAL RELIEF PROGRAM.
THIS WILL AWARD FINANCIAL GRANTS
TO SMALL RURAL AND CRITICAL
ACCESS HOSPITALS THAT NEED TO
PERFORM SEISMIC UPGRADES WITHIN
THEIR FACILITIES TO ACHIEVE
SEISMIC COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
LAW REQUIRING GENERAL ACUTE CARE
FOR HOSPITALS TO COMPLY WITH
SPECIFIC SEISMIC SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS BY JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY THIRTY- THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL REQUEST FOR
POSITIONS AD FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE TIME.
CONTRACT FUNDING TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FIVE MICHAEL VALLEY AGAIN
DEBBIE DIRECTOR FOR INFORMATION
SERVICES ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH
FOUR REQUIRES AGE GUIDE
IMPLEMENTED DO DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOSPITALS
HOSPITALS ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
FILE AN ANNUAL EQUITY REPORT
WITH HR AND ALSO TO POST IT ON
THEIR INTERNET WEBSITE THE
EQUITY REPORT WILL INCLUDE
MEASURES ON PATIENT ACCESS
QUALITY AND OUTCOMES BY RACE
ETHNICITY LANGUAGE DISABILITY
STATUS SEXUAL ORIENTATION GENDER
IDENTITY. AND AIR THE REPORT
WILL ALSO INCLUDE A PLAN TO
PRIORITIZE AND ADDRESS
DISPARITIES FOR GLOBAL
POPULATIONS IDENTIFIED IN THE
DATA IN ADDITION TO THE NEW DATA
COLLECTION H. FIVE REQUIRED TO
CONVENE A PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
MEASURES ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WHICH PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF MEASURES AS
WELL AS PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THE OBJECTIVES AND TIMEFRAMES
FOR HOSPITALS DEVELOP THEIR
PLANS TO PRIORITIZE AND ADDRESS
DISPARITIES FOR BONTA POPULATION
. I WILL SUBSEQUENTLY COMMITTEE
A PUBLIC RULE MAKING TO SPECIFY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. FOR
HOSPITALS ANY WORKLOAD
IMPLEMENT. THESE PROVISIONS
CANNOT BE ABSORBED WITH CURRENT
H. I. RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE LAW H. GUYS
REQUESTING PERSONNEL RESOURCES
TO ADMINISTER THE REPORT
SUBMISSION REVIEW AND EVALUATE
REPORTS AND PERFORM COMPLIANCE
ACTIVITIES. AND ALSO TO STAFF
THE ADVISORY COMMISSION. ONGOING
ADVISE ALSO REQUESTING ONE TIME
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSULTING TO ENHANCE THE
CAPACITY OF EXISTING H. FIVE
SYSTEMS ARE STRUCTURE CAN MEET
THE NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT INCLUDES OUR MARKS ON
DECEMBER FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ISSUE NUMBER SIX AFTERNOON
RIDE BUT CLEAR CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
H. K. YOUR FOR THE HEALTH CARE
DEBT AND FOR BILLING AB TEN
TWENTY EXPANDED H. HAS
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR DATA
COLLECTION TO INCLUDE HOSPITAL
DEBT COLLECTION POLICIES IN
ADDITION. TO THE HOSPITAL
DISCOUNT PAYMENT IN CHARITY CARE
POLICIES CURRENTLY COLLECTED AND
POSTED AGE BECAUSE WEBSITE EIGHT
A REVIEW ALL COLLECTED POLICIES
FOR STATUTORY COMPLIANCE CHECK A
COMMENCING IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. ADDITIONALLY AB TEN
TWENTY CHARGES THIS CAT WITH THE
FORCE OF THE HOSPITAL FAIR
PRICING POLICIES ARTICLE THREE
NEW PUBLIC COMPLAINT PROCESS IN
A POSITION ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES BUT. TO FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER INVESTIGATION.
BECAUSE OF THAT WILL COMMENCE
TWENTY TWENTY. A. M. BEST DESK
WILL BE HOUSE THE LEAGUE OFFICE
BE THE FOR AGE CAP PROGRAM
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC MOST HIV AIDS CAL
PROGRAMS TO DATE HER WORK WITH
INSTITUTIONS BUSINESSES AND
CURRENT OR FUTURE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. TO IMPLEMENT ITS
EXPANDED DATA COLLECTION
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS EACH CASE
SIX SIXTEEN POSITIONS IN THE
FIRST BUDGET YEAR AN EQUAL
POSITIONS THEREAFTER. ESTIMATES
WILL LIKELY BALLING WITH
INVESTIGATIONS AND PERSONAL WORK
BOTH WERE DEVELOPED BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCES OF SISTER
APARTMENTS. OKAY INTERFACING
DIRECTLY WITH THE PUBLIC ON
CONTRACTUAL AND LEGAL COMPLIANCE
MATTERS. BE PLAYING A ROLE
MAKING PROCESS FOR THE EXPANDED
POLICY COLLECTION AND POSTING
REQUIREMENT HAS ALREADY
COMMENCED AND WILL BE COMPLETE
AT THE END OF THE YEAR. A RULE.
FOR THE NEWER FORTUNATE PUBLIC
COMPLAINT PROGRAM WILL BE IN
PLACE FOR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND
NOW WITH THAT. WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS BOOKING LEVINE. OKAY
I'M GONNA PUT WE'VE WE'VE LINE
JUST. THIS IS A LOT OF BIG
CHUNKS LET'S. STOP HERE- AND SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY AND A DOCTOR PAN
HAD EARLIER BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
SOME OF THE OTHER ONES. AND I
GUESS MY FIRST. QUESTION A
COMMENT- MYSTERE EXAM. IS ABOUT
- ALSO I THINK IT WAS NUMBER TWO
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT- JUST
MAKING SURE. ALL OF ALL OF THESE
INVESTMENTS LIKE THE PURE
PERSONAL TRAINING AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAMS ALL OF THOSE THAT WE
DON'T LOSE TRACK OF ALL THOSE AS
WELL AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONTINUE TO BUILD THE WORKFORCE-
WE'RE NOT WORKING IN SILOS WHERE
WE TRAIN PEOPLE OVER HERE AND
THEN THEY CAN'T GET A JOB IN
ANOTHER PART OF. IT AND- SURE
THAT. EVERYBODY WERE TRAINING
WE'RE DOING OUR VERY BEST- TO
MAINTAIN AND MOVE UP THROUGH THE
SYSTEM. AND THEN I GUESS AND
THERE'S ANOTHER ISSUE I WOULD
JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT HIS.
WHEN WE'RE BUILDING THESE
SYSTEMS ARE MORE TRAINING NEW
PEOPLE SUPERVISION IS UP UP MOST
IMPORTANT SO YOU NEED THOSE AT
THE HIGHER END OF THEIR- THEIR
DEGREES INNER AND THEIR AND
THEIR EXPERTISE TO BE APPROVED
BY THE SUPERVISION. ON THE
GROUND IT IN ALL OF THE
SETTINGS. BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE FULL
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE THAT THEY
NEED. TWO METERS AND ARE WE
DOING THAT I WOULD MAKING SURE
THESE PEOPLE STAY. I WOULD. LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AND DEFER THAT
QUESTION TO MY COLLEAGUE KAREN
WHO IS MORE OF THE PROGRAM
EXPERT ON THE SIDE KAREN. WELL
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WE'RE MAKING SURE
THAT AS WE DEVELOP. PROGRAMS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT CAREER
LADDERS- WHEN HE GETS IMPORTANT
THAT WE THAT WE WANT TO RECRUIT
AND RETAIN- M. BUILDING PATHWAYS
FOR PROFESSIONAL SO THAT WE ARE
CONNECTING. THE PROGRAM AND-
BUILDING CAREER LADDERS FOR OUR
HEALTH WORKFORCE. AND I LIKE
THAT AND I TELL EVERYBODY THAT
WE'RE I'M I'M OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY I THAT THAT'S WHAT I
TELL PEOPLE THAT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE BUILDING THAT
LATTER ARE WE DOING IT WILL GET
THE WRONGS HONORED. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE AIMING FOR THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS ARE REALLY TAKING A
FOCUSED LOOK AT THIS TIME YES
HOW DO WE BUILD AS WE'RE
BUILDING NEW PROGRAMS. HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE BUILDING
FOR THE PAST AS WELL ENTER INTO
THEIR- WHOLE CAREERS AND HOW HOW
THEY CAN ADVANCE AND BE RETAINED
WITHIN. THE HEALTH WORKFORCE.
OKAY COME BACK AND SHOW ME THE
LETTER AND ALL THE WRONGS. SOON. YES HOPING THAT FOR EACH ONE
OF THOSE- CERTAINLY OKAY. OKAY
THANK YOU DR DEPEND. I WOULD
JUST ECHO. SENATE ADMINS ALSO
SAID NO AND INTENDED IT'S ALSO
YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO THE
QUESTION I ORIGINALLY ASKED THE
DIRECTOR IS THAT OBVIOUSLY OPIUM
FOCUS ON PIPELINE BUT ALSO
ENSURING THAT- WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE RETENTION PIECE.
AND THE WORK ENVIRONMENT WHICH
THEY'RE IN RIGHT SO FOR YOU KNOW
THIS AGENCY H. GUYS ALSO GOING
TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE PAYMENTS
AND BUDGET DOWN AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND SO ARE WE CREATING AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE PAID IN A WAY AND
ARE TO THE WORK ENVIRONMENT ARE
WE GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH A
LOT OF HASSLES. IS IT GOING TO
BE A WORK OF ART SUPPORT OF THEM
DOING THE KIND OF WORK WHERE SHE
WANTED TO DO RIGHT PRIMARY CARE
DOCTORS ACTUAL PROVIDE CLINICAL
CARE NOT TO ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
WE MIGHT BE ABLE HEALTH WORKERS
TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE NOT PAPERWORK RIGHTS
SO- SO THAT THAT'S PART OF ALL
PLEA WHAT WE'RE DOING ANY ERA
AND THEN I THINK IT'S THIS IS
THE PREGNANT UPSETS IS. TWENTY
ARE. ONCE I USED TO WRITE. THE
PROGRAM WE HAVE TO BE THEY'RE
BEING. SO AND ALL WE HAVE
APPROPRIATE ACTIVITIES IN FROM
WHAT THEY CAN DO AFTER GROW.
THAT WE DON'T. SIMPLY PUT IN
SUCH. WHERE AND- IN OVER THEIR
HEADS- SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE
EXPECT THEM TO DELIVER MORE THAN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY TRAINED TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER- BECAUSE WE
COULD HAVE A SHORTAGE AND WE
JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE.
IT'S AROUND. SO THAT'S THAT THAT
LEADS TO BOTH BURNED OUT ON THE
PROFESSIONAL SIDE BUT ALSO LEADS
TO YOU KNOW CHALLENGES AND IN
DOWN BALLOT EQUITY AND- ACCESS
AND SO FORTH FOR. FOR THE
PATIENTS ARE BEING SEEN AS WELL
SO- BUT LET BIG ISSUES- BUT-
WITH H. K. HAVING. SO PIECES
THEN SERVE SURROUNDING ALL THESE
THING. HOPEFULLY YOU THE AGENCY
- AT THE AND THAT'S THAT'S
FORMER YOUR POWER NOT ONLY THE
WORK FOR. BUT ALSO ON THE- ON
THE PAYMENT SIDE AS WELL AS YOUR
BUSINESS AGENCIES CAN BE MORE
ENGAGED IN. AND THAT. WE ARE
EAGER TO WITNESS YOUR PROGRESS.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK.
OKAY SO LET'S MOVE ON THEN WITH-
NUMBER SEVEN. RIGHT BACK TO WORK
FORCE. WONDERFUL AND I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD SEGUE- MANAGER DR
PANDA TALKING ABOUT THOUGH THE
LARGE WORKFORCE PROPOSAL ON THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET SO JUST IN
pHEALTHCARE CRISIS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FACING THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY CAME TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP A PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE CARICOM
THE WORK FORCE. THE PROPOSED
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE POINT ONE
BILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
RECRUIT TRAIN HIRE AND AS WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALSO ADVANCE
UNETHICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE WORKFORCE WITH IMPROVE
DIVERSITY- AND COMPENSATION OF
COURSE THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
OF ALL OF THIS. TO KELLY JEFF
AND THE LABOR AGENCY CAME
TOGETHER TO RESPOND TO THE
WORKFORCE CRISIS I MEAN I THINK
WE'RE ALL HEARING IT EVERY DAY
THAT HOSPITALS ARE SHORT STAFFED
AND DESPERATE PAYING VERY HIGH
REGISTRY RATES FOR THE TEMPORARY
WORK FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WERE HEARING IT FROM-
WE COULD GO ON OR NOT BUT I
THINK THERE'S A REAL RECOGNITION
ABOUT THE SHORT SUPPLY AND ALSO
THE- OF A- TOOK TO DIVERSIFY THE
CURRENT WORKS. THE RACE
ETHNICITY LANGUAGES SPOKEN LGBTQ
STATUS AS. WELL AS PEOPLE OF
LIVED EXPERIENCE. THE H.
COMPONENTS IN THE FORCE HELPING
. FRAWLEY INCLUDED BILLION OVER
THREE YEARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND AND THEN A PORTION OF THE
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS TO
INVEST IN TRAINING A DIVERSE
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE. TO
ADDRESS HEALTH WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
AND INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE
INCLUDING FOR MEDICAL MEMBERS SO
AGAIN I'LL JUST GO THROUGH THE
BRIEFLY AND THEN SEE WHAT WHAT
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS YOU HAVE-
THERE IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER INITIATIVE. OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
RECRUIT TRAIN AND CERTIFY A NEW
VICIOUS GOAL OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND NEW COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO
AGAIN THIS IS. SENATOR EGGMAN
AND I HAD THIS CONVERSATION THIS
IS COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS FROM
A THOUGHT AS PEOPLE WITH PEER
SUPPORT FOLKS PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE YOU HAVE SO MUCH TO
OFFER- AND WE KNOW THIS IS A-
MAN ON A MEDIC CAL BENEFITS-
HOPEFULLY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL GET FINAL
APPROVAL ON. THIS SUMMER- WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT SPECIALTY
CERTIFICATIONS IN AREAS
INCLUDING CLIMATE HEALTH. UNLESS
S. AND DEMENTIA. AGAIN WRECKING
. THAT ARE REAL CRISIS AND NURSE
THERE'S A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
NURSING INITIATIVE. OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF OUR ENDS
L. B. AND C. N. A.'S CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES AND IN KEEPING
WITH SB SIXTY FIVE- CERTIFIED
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE AND FAMILY
NURSE PRACTITIONERS. AND WE HOPE
TO UTILIZE- SEVERAL OF OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS CHECK FOR THAT
SUPPORT- AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED
A VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE TRAINING- HELPING FOLKS
GET THEIR MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK
SO WE DO HAVE A CALIFORNIA
SOCIAL WORK TWENTY THIRTY
INITIATIVE. TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION TO SUPPORT SOCIAL WORK
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
STIPENDS AND SCHOLARSHIPS. FOR
PEOPLE TO CREATE A NEW
PIPELINES. SOCIAL WORKERS WE'VE
HAD SOME ENCOURAGING INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS- WITH SOME OF THE
PROGRAM WENT WITH CAL SWAG-
ABOUT THE IDEA OF A FOUR PLUS
ONE. AND ACCELERATED MASTER'S IN
SOCIAL FROM. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
TWENTY MILLION TO CREATE
TRAINING POSITIONS FOR
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PSYCHOLOGY INTERNS
AND FELLOWS AND PSYCHIATRIC
NURSES SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
INCREASE ON SITE TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO BUILD THE WORKFORCE
WHILE ALSO SERVING AS AN ACTIVE
RECRUITMENT TOOL FOR ADVANCEMENT
WITHIN THAT THE HHS WORK FORCE
LEADING TO A PROMOTIONAL
PATHWAYS AND INCREASED SALARIES
. WE ALSO HAVE A LOT FAILING
WILL HELP THEM INITIATIVE SIXTY
MILLION IN GENERAL FUD TO
EXPAND SCHOLARSHIPS AND LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS AND HEALTH
CARE AND SOCIAL WORK
SPECIFICALLY FOR MULTI LINGUAL
APPLICANTS SO ALL WHILE ALL OF
OUR EACH CARRY ON WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS SEEK TO INCREASE.
RACIAL LINGUISTIC DIVERSITY- WE
DID THINK IT IMPORTANT TO HAVE A
SPECIFIC INITIATIVE FOCUSED ON-
ON INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
MULTI LINGUAL PROVIDERS AND THAT
WITH THE PEOPLE OF INCREASING
LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIANS
. AND THEN- THERE ON OPIOID
TREATMENT THERE IS A PROPOSAL
FOR SHE USED TWENTY SIX MILLION
TO TRAIN PROVIDERS TO BUILD OUT
THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE WITH A FOCUS ON OPIOID
TREATMENT HOUSING WILL BE USED
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
LICENSE CONDITIONS. INCLUDING
PROVIDERS FOCUSED ON ON
ADDICTION FUNDING WILL ALSO
PROVIDE SUPPORT OF EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS ISSUES
TO TRANSITION THEM INTO ONGOING-
CONFINEMENT. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT ITEM.
THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- FREESHEET- THE
INVESTMENT AND- THE WORK FORCE
AND I WOULD MAKE NOTES- AND
BACKGROUND MATERIAL. THAT
THERE'S A FORECASTED REDUCTIONS
IN. PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS.
1025% BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WE HAVE FEWER PEOPLE ENTERING IN
AS PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS- THEN
THE ONES ARE PROJECTED RETIRE.
AND SO I THINK- WE MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT SO WE DO HAVE
PROGRAMS LIKE SONG BROWN AND SO
FORTH BUT I THINK. THERE'S AN
ISSUE THERE AND I THINK WE NEED
TO RECONSIDER SOME OF THE
POLICIES THAT THE VALUE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS. I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY. THE SIGNALS AND
SET AND- MEDICAL STUDENTS ARE
PAYING ATTENTION. AND WE NEED TO
REVERSE THOSE IF YOU WANT TO-
BRING BACK PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS TO CALIFORNIA. SO
HOPEFULLY WE WILL- THINK ABOUT
CONSIDER THAT BUT WE ALSO WANT
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN TRY TO
DO TO BOLSTER THAT THAT
WORKFORCE- THE OTHER. ISSUE ALSO
CITING AND KNOWS THAT IN THE
CATEGORY PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS-
RESIDENCIES ARE. FOR PHYSICIANS.
SO MAYBE IT'S PROBABLY BEST TO
CLASSIFY THESE AS POSTGRADUATE
ARE- TRAINING OR WHATEVER SO-
CERTAINLY THERE'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE FOR PSYCHIATRIC
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND PSYCHIATRISTS
NURSES. BUT IT'S A LITTLE
CONFUSING WHEN THE TERM WHEN THE
TITLE PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS AND
WE'RE MIXING AGAIN MIXING UP
DIFFERENT TYPES OF. PEOPLE IN
THAT CATEGORY SO IT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL TO ACTUALLY BREAK OUT.
HOW MUCH OF THE RESOURCES ARE
GOING TO SPECIFICALLY WHAT-
WHICH PARTICULAR PROFESSIONALS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
RULES AND DIFFERENT PLACES. YEAH
I KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT.
EXACTLY HI I SURE I SURE OF WHAT
EXACTLY SAID SO TO BE HELPFUL TO
BREAK SOME OF THAT OUT BECAUSE
THIS IS A PRETTY CERVANTES ONCE
. THE TWELVE MONTHS OF FUNDING.
THAT THE NEXT PROFESSIONALS. AND
I THINK- PER THAT AGAIN WE
SHOULD PROBABLY. SORT OUT WHICH
ONES WE NEED AND HOW MANY WE
NEED OF. OF THEM PRESENT
DIFFERENT ROLES- I'D I'D
ACTUALLY IS A POSITION I DON'T
THE I DON'T. KNOW PSYCHOLOGISTS
ARE VERY DIFFERENT THE DIFFERENT
THINGS AND I CAN'T REPLACE THE
COLLEGES AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
DOESN'T REPLACE ME SO. WE JUST
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THE DIFFERENT
ROLES- PEOPLE PLAY- IN IN IN THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WORLD- SO- BUT-
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT ABOUT THE
DECLINING- NUMBERS OF FIVE. I AM
A CARE PHYSICIANS BEING
PROJECTED TO BY THE WAY. ALSO
ARE ON THE FRONTLINES OF
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH CARE. AS
WELL- SO IF FOR A- AND
OFTENTIMES FOR MILD MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO ACTUALLY PROVIDE YOU KNOW
THE DIAGNOSIS AND EVEN THE
TREATMENT. THANK YOU DOCTOR AND
I'LL GET CARE RESOLUTIONS TO
JUMP IN AS WELL BUT JUST AT THE
OUTSET YOU KNOW WE WERE VERY
PLEASED TO GET THE FIFTY
MILLION. DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR
SONG BROWN- LAST YEAR AND PLAN
TO PUT THOSE DOLLARS TO GOOD USE
TO TRY TO EXPAND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE WORK OF THE NEW
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
COUNCIL. WE'LL BE VERY FOCUSED
WE- USE THE WORK OF THE FUTURE
WORKFORCE COMMISSION REPORT- IS
AS AS A VERY IMPORTANT DIED OF
OURS AND SO WERE WE YES WE'RE
AWARE. OF THE ISSUE AND TRYING
TO DO EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR
PROGRAMS TO TRY TO SUPPORT THE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. CARE IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD.
I WOULD PROBABLY JUST SAY
THERE'S OTHER DOCUMENTS I'D LOOK
TO NOT JUST THE COMMISSION
REPORT WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING
TO ACTUALLY PUBLISHED PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS- SO- AND AGAIN
RECOGNIZING THEIR ROLE AND BRIAN
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE AND CLEAN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. HEALTH CARE
BUT- I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONTINUING DEVALUATION OF
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS AND
SIGNAL THAT SENDS AND THAT'S YOU
KNOW SOME OF IT IS. WE CAN FIND
MORE PROGRAMS BUT- THAT THE AS
THE- HEALTH WORKFORCE CENTER.
SAYS THAT THERE'S INSUFFICIENT
NUMBERS. ENTERING SO YOU KNOW
WHY IS THAT. AND WHAT WHAT ARE
WE DOING THAT'S ACTUALLY
DISCOURAGING. AS ACTUALLY MORE
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND NEVER
ACTUALLY. FOR INCREASING NUMBER
MEDICAL STUDENTS OUT THERE BUT
YET THEY'RE NOT GOING TO PRIMARY
CARE WHY IS IT. AND WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF
POLICIES THAT WE'RE PUTTING INTO
PLACE ACTUALLY DISCOURAGES
PRIMARY. THESE MEDICAL SINCE
METRIC PRIMARY CARE.
PARTICULARLY WHAT A MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE AS WELL SO- SO THAT I
THINK SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CONSIDER. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SHOULD
YOU WANT TO GO NOW YOUR HANDS UP
DID YOU WANT TO GO NOW DO YOU
WANT TO WAIT TO THE WORK DONE
WITH THESE- IF IT'S OKAY
MANAGER- ELLIE- HAD JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THIS SPECIFIC
ITEM IF IT'S- SURE. THANK YOU-
SO FIRST- WE JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THE L. A. O. IS PLANNING TO
RELEASE AN ANALYSIS IN THE
COMING WEEKS OF THIS H. CHI
PROPOSAL AND THE OTHER
PROPOSALS- IN OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THAT ARE TOGETHER PACKAGE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AS THE CARE
ECONOMY WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PACKAGE- YOU KNOW BUT RIGHT NOW
WE ARE WE ARE READY TO MAKE A
FEW PRELIMINARY COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL- WE GENERALLY FIND THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS CURRENTLY AT A
VERY CONCEPTUAL STAGE AND SHE
DETAILS WILL NEED TO BE FLUSHED
OUT DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS.
ALTHOUGH IT HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED
THAT YOU GENERALLY A SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS EXIST
ESPECIALLY ACROSS GEOGRAPHIC
REGIONS- AND THIS PROPOSAL MAY
HELP TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THOSE
SHORTAGES YEAH WE GENERALLY FIND
THAT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD BENEFIT
FROM A CLEAR PROBLEM DEFINITION
OF WHAT THE SPECIFIC WORKFORCE
GAPS IT AIMS TO ADDRESS OUR-
THIS COULD INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE
DEVELOPING A TARGET NUMBER OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS TO BE ADDED
AND CLEARLY COMMUNICATING HOW
CLOSE THIS PROPOSAL WOULD GET US
TO THAT TARGET SORT OF
ADDITIONAL NUMBER OF PROVIDERS-
THIS WOULD ALSO SORT OF HELP THE
LEGISLATURE ASSESS WHETHER THIS
SPECIFIC SET OF PROVIDERS. ARE
THE IDEAL ONES TO TARGET IN THIS
PROPOSAL- THE SECOND COMMENT WE
WOULD MAKE IS THAT IT'S
CURRENTLY UNCLEAR AT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL RELY SOLELY ON
EXISTING H. CHI WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS OR IF IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE CREATION OF ENTIRELY NEW
PROGRAMS IN H. CHI- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
THAT IT CURRENTLY PLANS TO
PROVIDE THIS FUNDING THROUGH THE
STRUCTURE OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND WILL ASSESS AT A LATER DATE
WHETHER NEW PROGRAMS ARE NEEDED-
WE FIND THAT THIS HAS
IMPLICATIONS FOR. WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE STATUTORY VEHICLE
WOULD BE FOR IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROPOSAL ADMINISTRATION IS
CURRENTLY- PROPOSING PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROPOSAL LARGELY BASED ON THE
RATIONALE THAT FUNDING WOULD BE
PROVIDED THROUGH THE STRUCTURE
OF THE EXISTING PROGRAMS- GIVEN
THE POSSIBILITY THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE NEW GRAMS. IF THE LEGISLATURE WISHES TO
HAVE GREATER INPUT ON THE
ULTIMATE DESIGN AND STRUCK OF
THESE NEW PROGRAMS THAT NEED FOR
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION OR ARE
AN ALTERNATIVE VEHICLE- YOU KNOW
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL. ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF FUNDING THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED HERE- FINALLY WE
WOULD JUST MAKE NOTE THAT IT'S
CURRENTLY UNCLEAR HOW THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ALIGN OR
COMPLEMENT EXISTING WORKFORCE
EFFORTS IN H. CHI- FOR EXAMPLE
THE WORK FORCE COMPONENTS OF THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE WHICH- I'M
ALSO VERY BROADLY TARGET
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROVIDERS- WE
FIND THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
COULD CLEARLY ARTICULATE HOW
THESE PROPOSALS WILL TOGETHER
COMPLEMENT ONE ANOTHER TOWARDS
REACHING A TARGET GOAL OF
ADDITIONAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS- THIS WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
NO DUPLICATION OF FUNDING
BETWEEN THE TWO PACKAGES. AS YOU
KNOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT FUNDING
FOR THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT
STRICTLY FOR PROVIDERS WHO TREAT
ADULTS- THE ADMINISTRATION COULD
ALSO CLEARLY ARTICULATE HOW THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE EVALUATED. AND
HOW THESE EVALUATION ACTIVITIES
WOULD BE SYNTHESIZED WITH-
EVALUATIONS OF EACH BECAUSE
OTHER WORKFORCE PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE EVALUATION
EFFORTS ARE ARE- SILOS- AND
THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME AND- WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE. QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY
. I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
I AGREE WITH IT IS THAT I'M MORE
SICK IN YOUR I'VE BEEN DOING
HERE BUT WE'RE WHAT WHAT WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THIS AND WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT IT IT'S FAIRLY
NEBULOUS AT THAT SOME POINT AND
WE ALL KNOW WHICH IS NEEDED. BUT
I THINK WE NEED TO GET SOME
ACTUAL CONCRETE NUMBERS AND I.
BYE I TRUST. THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DEPUTY SOMEBODY RESULT- AND
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THAT. THAT THAT
LINE WITH ALL THE- THE SKID THE
SLIPPER. NO SKIN ON THE ON THE
BRONX OF THE LATTER. BUT I THINK
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
DEPEND I HAVE BOTH RAISED- WILL
BE MORE OVERSIGHT GOING FORWARD
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU. AS WE
FIGURE OUT SOME OF THESE TONY
ISSUES AND MAYBE YOU WANT OUR
HELP MAYBE WANT MORE FOR HELP
AND WE'RE HERE TO WE'RE HERE TO
HOT FOR HELPERS. OKAY OF ANY
ANYTHING AGAIN I WOULD AGREE
WITH THE L. A. AS COMMENTS- I
MEAN FOR COURSES AT AM OF.
BEFORE I GOT A LEGISLATORS
WORKFORCE RESEARCHER SO I MEAN
THIS MIGHT YOU KNOW ACADEMIC
SPECIALTY- AND- YOU KNOW I THINK
NEEDS TO BE A- YOU KNOW. NUMBERS
HER EIGHT AND PRODUCTION
SOMETIMES IT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
WRONG BUT I MEAN THAT I'VE
ACTUALLY TRIED TO PULL OUT THE
NUMBERS IN THE STATE THAT'S WHY
POINTED OUT IN TERMS OF THE
PRIMARY KERR FLIGHT. WITH SO WE
KNOW THERE'S A DECLINE SO WE'RE
GONNA DO ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW WE
KNOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGE DECLINE
MIGHT BE. SO SAME WITH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH EXACTLY HOW MANY BUT THEN
WE ALSO NEED THE SPECIFIC WHICH
TYPE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PEOPLE
DO WE NEED BECAUSE WHAT THE
DIFFERENT ROLES RIGHT SO WE
COULD NOT JUST ENOUGH THAT WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE HEALTH WORKERS
RIGHT WE NEED TO KNOW. WHAT EACH
PERSON'S GOING TO DO. THEIR WHAT
THEIR SKILL SETS ARE RIGHT DOWN
TO DO NOT KNOW SORRY ALL
INTERCHANGEABLE. YOU KNOW IT'S
AND IT'S AND- SO WE NEED TO HAVE
TARGETS- BASED ON WHAT THE
DEMAND IS AND THAT'S WHY I ALSO
ASKED ABOUT THE MAN'S
ASSESSMENTS AS WELL FROM. WHEN
HE CAME TO THAT YOU'D BE ABLE
HEALTH SO WE NEED TO WE CAN
MAKE. PATIENT. IN I BELIEVE- THE
ONE BIGGEST. JUST CAME OUT FOR.
RE BUT WE THE BUDGET CAME. AND I
KNOW THAT WAS DONE BY A
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT BUT I'M
ASSUMING. THERE IS GOING TO BE-
SOME DISSEMINATION SHARING.
ABOUT THAT BIG NEEDS ASSESSMENT
THAT WAS JUST COMPLETED- AND HOW
IT IS GOING TO APPLY DIRECTLY TO
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. IS
THAT CORRECT. ABSOLUT ABSOLUTELY
OKAY- DEPARTMENT FINANCE. OKAY
REQUIRED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANKS FOR THE VERY WELL TAKEN-
I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT AS AT
THIS STAGE ADMINISTRATION DOES
ANTICIPATE THESE PROGRAMS CAN BE
ADMINISTERED THEIR HIV CURRENT
PROGRAM SO NOW TRAILER BILL HAS
BEEN PROPOSED AT THIS TIME- BUT
AGAIN YOUR POINTS ARE WELL TAKEN
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE- HARGETT
PROVIDER GOALS AS WELL AS- I'M-
A MECHANISM FOR EVALUATION AND-
AN ADDITIONAL. INFORMATION ON-
HOW DO YOU- CURRENT PROPOSALS
ALIGN WITH EXISTING H. I.
PROGRAM. YOUR YOUR TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO YOU- WE
CAN PROVIDE THAT IN WRITING.
THANK YOU WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY-
THEN LET US MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT CLINICAL IN CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
CAROUSEL- SO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
TIME FUNDING OF FORTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND YOUR H. CHI JUST
SUPPORT ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES. ARGENIS
PROPOSAL- I WILL DIRECT TWENTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND TOWARD
EXISTING SCHOLARSHIP IN LAW
ENDOWMENT PROGRAMS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE PROVIDERS WHICH
INCLUDES PHYSICIANS NURSE
MIDWIVES PHYSICIANS ASSISTANTS
AND NURSE PRACTITIONERS THE
COMMITTEE PROVIDE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE- THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
THE FOLLOWING GOALS TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER AND DIVERSITY OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS PROVIDING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES. TO
SUPPORT HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
INCREASE. THE WORKFORCE SERVING
MEDICARE MEMBERS. FOR USE
BECAUSE HUSING PROGRAM INDUSTRY
. WHICH WILL ENABLE US TO
INCREASE AWARDS TO PRACTITIONERS
MORE QUICKLY THAN DEVELOPING A
NEW PROGRAM THESE PROGRAMS
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOAN REPAYMENT
STEVEN M. THOMPSON PHYSICIAN CAR
WANTING PAYMENT IN ADVANCE
PRACTICE HEALTHCARE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS. THE SECOND PART OF
THIS PROPOSAL DIRECTS TWENTY
MILLION TOWARDS ASSISTING-HEALTHCARE FACILITIES TO IMPROVE
SECURITY AND CYBER. PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING SPENDING TOWARDS
FACILITY SECURITY CYBERSECURITY
SECURITY PERSONNEL AND
RETRAINING STAFF. H. PRAYER WILL
WORK WITH THE MANAGING
ORGANIZATIONS IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM TO ADMINISTER THESE ONE
TIME FUNDS TO PROVIDERS OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES WE
RECENTLY LEARNED THAT CALLOW YES
AS EXCESSIVELY IN ADMINISTERED
GRANT PROGRAM FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE IN THE PAST HOUR
EXPLORING A POTENTIAL IN
ARRANGING INSTAGRAM AT WITH OUR-
WE ASKED TO UTILIZE THAT SYSTEM
THAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE. FOR
THIS COMPONENT OF THE FUNDING.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
REPETITIVE REPORT SPECIFIC
QUESTION A NOTE THAT AGAIN PRE
SHAPE THE PRESENTATION I GUESS
JUST MORE OF AN OBSERVATION AND
IT'S SO VERY NECESSARY- THAT-
THINGS THAT WE DO NEED TO FIND
UNFORTUNATELY IS ALSO MORE
PROTECTION AND SAFETY FOR THESE
FACILITIES SERVICE AND- LIKE I
THINK IT WAS- A CLINIC THAT WAS.
ACTUALLY BURNED DOWN IN ANOTHER
STATE UNFORTUNATELY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT- IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY RESORT TO DESTRUCTION
AND VIOLENCE AND- AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT. STATION SERVICE
SAFE AND STAFF ARE SAFE. IN
THESE FACILITIES AND THAT- WE
NEED DO NEED TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS AS WELL OF COURSE
THE VERY IMPORTANT VESTMENTS
AND- AND- THE STAFF AND THE- TO
BE SURE WE HAVE PEOPLE THERE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE THE STOCK.
IS VERY IMPORTANT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES HAVE PORTION KERR'S
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER NINE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY IS
ONCE AGAIN INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO GETTING IT DONE
THIS YEAR WE POSED TO TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE YESTERDAY WHICH
WHICH I KNOW HAS BEEN GIVING YOU
A LOT OF TIME TO REVIEW IT SO I
WILL GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSED OFFICE- AT A HIGH LEVEL
AS WELL AS GO THROUGH THE MAJOR
CHANGES IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FROM LAST YEAR. TO THIS
YEAR. YOU WOULD DISAGREE THAT
HIGH HEALTH CARE COSTS ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA. JUST LAST WEEK THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION RELEASED THEIR HEALTH
POLICY SURVEY. IN WHICH 83% OF
CALIFORNIANS INTERVIEWED. SAID
IT WAS EXTREMELY OR VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE TO WORK ON MAKING
HEALTH CARE MORE AFFORDABLE THIS
YEAR. THE IN THE IN THE SAME
SURVEY WERE CONCERNING RESULTS
SHOWING THE IMPACT ON AFFORDABLE
COST HAVE HONOR STATES
RESIDENTS. HALF OF CALIFORNIANS
49% SKIP TO POSTPONE SOME TYPE
OF HEALTH CARE IN THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS DUE TO COST. AMONG
THOSE WHO POSTPONED HERE FORTY
SEVEN PERCENT. THAT THEIR
CONDITION WORSENED AS A RESULT
WHICH IS AN INCREASE FROM LAST
YEAR'S SURVEY. OF 41% SO I
THINK- WHAT WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE
OF STATE. ACT UNAFFORDABILITY
HAS AND IT'S REALLY- IMPACTING
PATIENTS HEALTH. THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY OFFERS
A FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS HEALTH
CARE COSTS BY COLLECTING DATA TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND COST DRIVERS
AND DRIVERS OF DRIVERS OF HEALTH
CARE SPENDING AND DEVELOP
STRATEGIES FOR CONTROLLING THE
COST OF HEALTH CARE WHILE
MAINTAINING QUALITY AND EQUITY
OF CARE WHICH IS CRITICAL. AS
NOTED ON THE AGENDA A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATES HAVE SIMILAR
OFFICES AND WE BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S TIME HAS COME. THE
OFFICE WOULD ANALYSE THE
HEALTHCARE MARKET FOR COST TREND
THE DRIVERS OF SPENDING WITHIN
FORCE THE HEALTH CARE TARGET SET
BY A NEW HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY BOARD. AND WOULD
MEASURE KEY INDICATORS TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE ACHIEVING A HIGH
VALUE SYSTEM RATHER THAN A LOW
COST LOW VALUE SYSTEM BECAUSE
THE LAST THING WE WANT IS THAT
AS A RACE TO THE BOTTOM. SO I
WANT TO JUST GO THROUGH THE KEY
ACTIVITIES OF THE PROPOSED
OFFICE AND THE BOARD. SO THE
OFFICE WAITING FIRST OF ALL USE
TRANSPARENCY- INCREASED PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY ON TOTAL HEALTH
CARE SPENDING IN THE STATE. THE
OFFICE WOULD REQUIRE REPORTING
OF TOTAL HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURE
DATA AND THEN WOULD HAVE THAT
BROKEN DOWN BY SERVICE CATEGORY.
YOU KNOW HOSPITAL CARE PHYSICIAN
SERVICES JUST PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
XCERRA. THIS DATA WOULD BE
SUPPLEMENTED WITH FINANCIAL
REPORTS FROM PROVIDERS AS WELL
AS GRANULAR CLAIMS DATA FROM THE
EMERGING HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS
DATA SYSTEM. THE OFFICE WOULD
PUBLISH AN ANNUAL REPORT- IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE PUBLIC
MEETING ON HEALTHCARE SPENDING
TRENDS AND UNDERLYING FACTORS
ALONG WITH POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO CONTROL COSTS
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
EQUITY OF THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
. THE LANGUAGE OF THAT OUR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BUT
ESTABLISH A HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY BARGE WHICH WOULD
SET AN OVERALL STATEWIDE COST
TARGET AS WELL AS- SPECIFIC
TARGETS FOR DIFFERENT SECTORS OF
THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY- AND
DIFFERENT JEEP GEOGRAPHIC
REGIONS SO I'LL TALK MORE ABOUT
THE SPECIFIC MAKE UP AN
ACTIVITIES UP THE BOARD WHEN I
GO THROUGH THIS YEAR'S TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THE OFFICE WILL
ALSO ENFORCE COMPLIANCE BUT THE
COST TARGET- AND WOULD TAKE A
PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT
APPROACH- STARTING WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
PROGRESSIVELY INCREASED TO
INCLUDE TESTIMONY AT PUBLIC
MEETINGS. PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT PLANS AND ULTIMATELY
ONLY IF NECESSARY ASSESSMENT OF
FINANCIAL PENALTIES. THE OFFICE
WOULD PROMOTE AND MEASURE
QUALITY IN EQUITY THROUGH
PERFORMANCE REPORTING. TO AVOID
UNANTICIPATED CONSEQUENCES THAT
COULD RESULT FROM FOCUSING ON
COST ALONE PERFORMANCE ON
QUALITY IN EQUITY MEASURES WILL
BE MEASURES WILL BE MEASURED TO
GUARD AGINST NEGATIVE IMPACTS
THAT WE VERY MUCH WANT TO
COLLABORATE WITH- AND LEVERAGE
THE QUALITY IN EQUITY METRICS
BEING DEVELOPED ON A RIGHT NOW
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS THOSE
THAT ARE BEING USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND COVERED CALIFORNIA
. THE BOARD WOULD SET A
STATEWIDE GOAL FOR ADOPTION OF
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT MODELS THAT
PROMOTE SHIFTING PAYMENTS FROM A
FEE FOR SERVICE MODEL TO
PAYMENTS THAT REWARD HIGH
QUALITY AND COST EFFICIENT CARE
. THE OFFICE WERE ALSO MEASURE
AND PROMOTE A SUSTAINED SYSTEM
WIDE INVESTMENT IN PRIMARY CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO DOCTOR
PANS. EARLIER WE KNOW THAT
MODELS THAT INTEGRATE PRIMARY
CARE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO IMPROVE
ACCESS AND HEALTH OUTCOMES SO IT
MAY BE THAT THIS IS A WAY TO
ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL PRIMARY
CARE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE HEALTH PLANS ARE INVESTING
AT THE MEDICAL GROUPS ARE AS
WELL. SO THE OFFICE WOULD
MEASURE THE PERCENTAGE OF TOTAL
HEALTH CARE. EXPENDITURES
ALLOCATED TO PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL EALTH AND THE BOARD
BUT DROPPED SPENDING BENCHMARKS
. THE OFFICE BUT ALSO MONITORED
ADDRESS HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE.
COLLECTING DATA AND ANALYZING
CHANGES TO THE HEALTH CARE WORK
FORCE TO AVOID HARMFUL
REDUCTIONS TO THE WORK FORCE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA. AND FINALLY
THE OFFICE WOULD REVIEW PROPOSED
HEALTHCARE CONSOLIDATIONS GIVEN
THAT THIS CAN BE A DRIVER OF
COST THE OFFICE WOULD INCREASE
TRACK OF PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY ON
TRANSACTIONS THAT MAY IMPACT
MARKET COMPETITION. BY REVIEWING
MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS NOT
CURRENTLY REVIEWED BY ANOTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY SO DO YOU
MAY SEE IS ALREADY REVIEWING IT
WE OF COURSE WOULD NOT IF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE BUT
THIS IS TO FILL IN THE GAPS-
WHEN THERE'S NOT CURRENTLY A
REGULATORY AGENCY DOING OR IF
YOU. THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
WORKED WITH DR WHAT DOCTOR PAN
AND BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S LAST YEAR AND BASED ON
THOSE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE MADE SOME CHANGES. N THE
TRAILER BILL- I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE MORE SIGNIFICANT
OF THOSE CHANGES. ARE STARTING
WITH THE BOARD RATHER THAN THE
ADVISORY BOARD APPROACH THAT
LAST YEAR'S LANGUAGE TOOK ON
THIS YEAR THERE IS A HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY BOARD WHICH WILL
SAID HE POLICIES INCLUDING
ESTABLISHING THE COST TARGETS
THEMSELVES. AS WELL AS THE
METHODOLOGY FOR SETTING TARGETS
AND FACTORS TO MODIFY THE
TARGETS WHEN APPROPRIATE. THEY
WILL ALSO- SET FACTORS FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AND THE
SCOPE AND RANGE OF ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES. THE
BOARD WILL APPROVE THE
BENCHMARKS FOR PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPEND. THE
GOALS FOR THE ADOPTION OF
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT MODELS AND
STANDARDS TO ADVANCE. THE
STABILITY OF THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE- OUR LANGUAGEHAS
EIGHT EIGHT MEMBER BOARD WITH
SEVEN VOTING MEMBERS. THERE
WOULD BE FOR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SUBJECT TO SENATE
CONFIRMATION. I WOULD EACH BY
THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER AND THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY OR THEIR DESIGNEES
WOULD BE A VOTING MEMBER. AND
THEN WE WOULD HAVE THE CALPERS
CHIEF HEALTH DIRECTOR OR THEIR
DEPUTIES SERVING AS A NON VOTING
MEMBER. SO THAT'S THE BARGE. IN
TERMS OF THE HEALTH CARE COST
TARGETS- YOU KNOW WE'VE DEFINED
THAT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT SO THE
HEALTH CARE COST TARGETS ARE THE
TARGET PERCENTAGE FOR ANNUAL
INCREASE IN PER CAPITA TOTAL
HEALTH CARE EXPENDITURES. SO FOR
EXAMPLE AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA
MASSACHUSETTS AT THEIR COST
TARGET GROWTH RATE AT THREE
POINT 6% FOR THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS. COST TARGETS CANNOT
REQUIRE DECREASING COSTS- UNDER
THIS YEAR'S LANGUAGE ONLY SET A
GROWTH RATE SO WHERE IS LAST
YEAR'S. LANGUAGE GROUP- COULD
HAVE REQUIRED. USING COSTS ON
THIS YEAR IT'S ALWAYS SETTING A
MINIMUM GROWTH RATE. ANOTHER
IMPORTANT NEW PROVISION
ADDRESSES THE IMPACT OF LABOR
COSTS ON THE TARGETS UNDER THE
LANGUAGE COST TARGETS CAN BE
ADJUSTED FOR A PROVIDER OR
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT%
DEMONSTRATES THAT NON
SUPERVISORY LABOR COSTS ARE
PROJECTED TO GROW FASTER THAN
THE RATE OF ANY APPLICABLES COST
TARGETS. COST TARGETS WILL BE
DEVELOPED BASED ON A METHODOLOGY
WHICH WILL BE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE- AND THEY'RE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
METHODOLOGY PROMOTES STABILITY
OF THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AND
MAINTAIN FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION. WHAT'S GOING ON
SAID THE DEFINITION SECTION OF
THE LANGUAGE- THE DEFINITION OF
HEALTH CARE ENTITY CHANGE FROM
PAYER OR PROVIDER AND INCLUDES A
DEFINITION OF FALLING INTO. A
FULLY INTEGRATED HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS SPELLED OUT
AND WOULD BE INCLUDED AS A
HEALTH CARE ENTITIES SUBJECT TO
THE COST TARGETS. TOTAL
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES ARE
FURTHER DEFINED AN UPDATED TO
INCLUDE EXAMPLES OF NON CLAIMS
BASED PAYMENTS BECAUSE OF COURSE
WILL WANNA ACCOUNT FOR
PERFORMANCE PAYMENTS-
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND THE
LIKE. AND THEN IMPORTANTLY THE
PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATION
DEFINITION IS MODIFIED SO AND
THIS IS THE PART BECAUSE IT
INCLUDES- WHICH PHYSICIANS WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO THE COST ARE GETS
ON THE DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. SO DATA PHYSICIAN
PHYSICIAN ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDE
RISK BEARING ORGANIZATIONS.
IPA'S OR INDEPENDENT PRACTICE
ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL AS MEDICAL
GROUPS WITH SIXTY OR MORE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. FORTY OR
MORE SPECIALISTS HOW FOR A FIFTY
PROVIDERS IF IT'S A COMBINED
PRACTICE WITH BOTH SPECIALISTS
AND PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. FIND
DATA COLLECTION AND REPORTING.
THE OFFICE WOULD NOT COLLECT
DATA FROM EXEMPTS PROVIDERS
INCLUDING SMALL PROVIDER GROUPS
- AND THE OFFICE MAKE COLLECTED
FROM OTHER STATE AGENCIES
THROUGH DATA SHARING AGREEMENT
SO THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE CONTEMPLATED SIR
CERTAINLY WITH THE H. U. S.
SENATE APARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. THERE WAS A CONCERN
RAISED ABOUT PHYSICIAN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAY NOT HAVE
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS SO
THERE IS A PROVISION ALLOWING
THEM TO SUBMIT- ON AUDIT
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS THAT MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS. IN TERMS
OF MONITORING COMPLIANCE- THIS
IS ONE OF MANY AREAS WE DISCUSS
WITH DOCTOR PAN WE RENAMED
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN TO
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PLAN
THAT CERTAINLY ALWAYS ARE
INTENSE BUT WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT THAT'S THAT THE ENFORCEMENT
APPROACH- AND THERE'S ALSO A
WE'VE CLARIFIED THE SPECIFIC
ELEMENTS TO BE INCLUDED IN A
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PLAN AND
YOU'VE- ENFORCEMENT APPROACH.
THE OFFICE A LOT APPROVED
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PLANS
THE PROPOSED TO MEET COST
TARGETS IN WAYS THAT ARE LIKELY
TO A ROAD ACCESS QUALITY IN
EQUITY OR WORK FOR STABILITY- SO
THERE IS A LOT MORE TO TALK
ABOUT WITH THE OFFICE- BUT THOSE
ARE ARE THE AN OVERVIEW AND THE
CHANGES TO THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. HI
THIS YEAR'S A TWELVE. DIRECTOR
FOR THE PRECEDING THE
PRESENTATION- OBVIOUSLY IS. THIS
PEOPLE COMPLY TELL FROM YOUR
PRESENTATION THIS IS- THERE'S A
LOT OF POLICY IN THIS TRAILER
BILL SO IT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
THAT- AFFECTS THE- WHAT IS
CURRENTLY WAS ABOUT 1718% OF OUR
HEALTH OUR ECONOMY- SO OBVIOUSLY
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO. DO LAST YEAR- I THINK
THAT THERE ARE STILL SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN RESOLVE-
BECAUSE I TO LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THIS DONE AS AS YOU
SAID. AND AND- LOOKING FORWARD
TO AGAIN GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL
FEEDBACK FROM STAKEHOLDERS TO ON
THOSE UNRESOLVED ISSUES. AND YET
APPRECIATE THE- ON GOING
DISCUSSION SO. FRANKLY I THINK
IF WE HAD A THOROUGH DISCUSSION
OF THE TRAILER BILL WE WOULD BE
HERE FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER FEW
HOURS- WE GIVEN THE SCOPE AND
THE DETAIL BUT REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
LOOKING FORWARD TO. WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
YOU TO MINISTRATION INSPECTOR
DOLLY AND OTHERS. AND HOPEFULLY
CRAFTING I HAD A- OF. THAT
VERSION THAT- WE CAN ALL. BE ON
BOARD AND- IS THAT- MY GOAL ALSO
IS TO GET THIS DONE AND- SO
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION AND
I THINK I'LL JUST- LOOKING
FORWARD TO I CAN RESULT
UNRESOLVED ISSUES- AND. HELP
LEAVES ARE WRAPPING THIS ALL UP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
THIRTY PAN AND- DATA DURING YOU
KNOW I THINK ALL OF US RIGHT NOW
. IT JUST WAS RELEASED LAST
NIGHT SO IT'S A IT IS VERY EARLY
FOR US TO BE WEIGHING IN- AND SO
I'M SURE YOU ASSUME THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AND I
THINK. THAT WE ALL WE ALL WANT
TO SEE THIS HAPPEN- WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE IT IS DONE
RIGHT- ILIO. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR JUST OUT REALLY REALLY
QUICK- JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT ON
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY- YOU KNOW WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL THAT
WAS RELEASED LAST NIGHT-
INCLUDING FOR. FLAGGING SORT OF
THE KEY ANY KEY DIFFERENCES SUCH
AS THOSE THAT THE ADMIN JUST.
ADMINISTRATION JUST SORT OF
HIGHLIGHTED FOR US- WE WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE THAT WE PLAN TO
RELEASE AN ANALYSIS IN THE
COMING WEEKS. FOCUSED ON. AREAS
PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT FOCUS ON
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY ISSUES-
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE A FURTHER
ANALYSIS OF. THIS YEAR'S
OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE ABILITY
AFFORDABILITY PROPOSAL- YOU
KNOW- AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL LAST
YEAR WHEN THIS- PROPOSAL IS
BEING CONSIDERED YOU KNOW WE-
FOUND IT TO BE A REASONABLE STEP
TOWARD- ADDRESSING YOU SOME OF
THE HEALTH CARE COST ISSUES THAT
THE STATE IS FACING- BUT YOU
KNOW WE FOUND THAT CONTINUED
MONITORING OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE OFFICE WOULD BE CRITICAL
TO. ENSURE THAT IT WITH ITS-
ALTERNATELY SUCCESSFUL AT
CONTROLLING HEALTH CARE COSTS-
AND- YOU KNOW WHAT WILL TO SORT
OF LEAVE IT AT THAT HERE IN JUST
NOTE THAT. YOU KNOW A FURTHER
ANALYSIS IS COMING ONCE WE HAD.
A SORT OF LOOK AT THE DEAL.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO
PROVIDE A FINANCIAL ANYTHING.
OKAY THANK YOU FROM OKAY. I
THINK THAT'S IT. OR DID I MISS
SOMETHING. THAT'S ALL WE KNOW OF
A WRITER SO YOU KNOW WHAT I CAN
THINK ANYTHING ELSE ALRIGHT WELL
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION AND CERTAINLY THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NOW WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
CARE. AND WE SHOW. WELCOME FAST
WE SHOULD WHAT WE SHOULD WELCOME
THE DIRECTOR. BUT AFTER HEARING
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK WE CAN'T
THANK YOU. FOR H. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GET STARTED HERE SO I'M
VERY MUCH NOT BE THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE- WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DANCE
SOUTHERNER CHIEF DEPUTY IRECTOR
DANNEMEYER GOING TO TAG TEAM ARE
OVER BE OVER TEN BCPS. BUT I'LL
GET US STARTED WITH A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON OUR
HEALTHEQUITY QUALITY INITIATIVE
AS YOU ASKED FOR THANK YOU.
HERMANCE MISSIONS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS HEALTHCARE RIGHTS AND
ENSURE STABLE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. DMH C. LICENSE
AND REGULATE THE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO HEALTH PLANS TO
PROVIDE HEALTH COVERAGE TO
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. WE
REGULATE MORE THAN 95% OF THE
COMMERCIAL AND GOVERNMENT HEALTH
PLAN ENROLLMENT IN THE STATE.
AND OUR TOTAL PROPOSED FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE BUDGET. IS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR MILLION
AND SIX HUNDRED AND TWO
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS. PART
ESPECIALLY FUNDED BY ANNUAL
SACRAMENTO ON HEALTH PLANS AND
RECEIVES NO GENERAL FUND MONEY.
I'M UP QUICKLY JUST RUN THROUGH
OUR PROGRAMS I'M STARTING WITH
OUR HELP CENTER OUR HELP SIR
EDUCATES CONSUMERS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTHCARE RATES RESOLVES
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS HELPS
CONSUMERS NAVIGATE UNDERSTAND
THE COVERAGE IT ENSURES ACCESS
TO CORPORATE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. ADULT CENTER ALSO
ADMINISTERS THE DEPARTMENT'S
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW
PROGRAM TO RESPOND TO CONSUMER
DISPUTES WHEN HEALTHCARE
SERVICES ARE DENIED OR DELAYED.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THE GMAC HAS
ASSISTED MORE THAN TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITH
RESOLVING COMPLAINTS AND
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR HEALTH PLANS
SUCH AS COVERAGE DISPUTES ACCESS
TO PROVIDERS AND BILLING
INSURANCE. OUR NEXT OFFICE IS
THE OFFICE OF PLAN LICENSING I'M
HEALTH PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO
APPLY FOR AND MAINTAIN A LICENSE
TO OPERATE AS A HEALTH PLAN IN
CALIFORNIA. THE DMH SEE REVIEWS
ALL ASPECTS OF THE PLANT'S
OPERATIONS INCLUDING INCLUDING
BENEFITS AND COVERAGE CONTRACTS
WITH DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS
PROVIDER NETWORKS AND
COMPLAINING GRIEVANCE SYSTEM
SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THEY COMPLY
WITH CALIFORNIA LAW. AFTER WEISS
INJURE THE OFFICE OF PLANNED
LICENSING CONTINUES TO MONITOR
THE HEALTH PLANS AND ANY CHANGES
THEY MAKE TO THEIR OPERATIONS.
UP NEXT AS A OFFICES MONITOR
THIS OFFICE ASSESSES AND
MONITORS HEALTH PLAN CARE AND
DELIVERY SYSTEMS FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH THE KNOX KEEN ACT. THE
OFFICE OF PLAN WONDERING
PERFORMS ROUTINE AND NON ROUTINE
SERVICE OF A LICENSED HEALTH
PLANS TO ENSURE THAT MEET THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE LONG. AND
THE CONSUMERS GET ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE TO WHICH THEY
ARE ENTITLED. THE OFFICE OF PLAN
MONITORING ALSO MONITORS
PROVIDER NETWORKS AND
ACCESSIBILITY OF SERVICES
REVIEWS YOU KNOW HOW WHEN TIMELY
ACCESS COMPLIANCE REPORTS. AND
CONDUCTS ANNUAL COMPLAINTS
REVIEWS OF ALL PHONE SERVICE IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NETWORKS. OUR
OFFICE A FINANCIAL REVIEW
ACTIVELY MONITORS THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF HEALTH PLANS AND
MEDICAL GROUPS THE REGULAR
RECORDING FINANCIAL AUDITS AND
OTHER TOOLS. THE OFFICE ALSO
REVIEWS ANNUAL MEDICAL LOSS
RATIO FILINGS TO ENSURE PLANS
ARE PROPERLY INVESTING IN
RALEIGH HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
WE ALSO REVIEWED PROPOSED
PREMIUM RATE INCREASES AND THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKETS MAKE SURE HEALTH PLANS
ARE PROVIDING DETAILED
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC. THE
JUSTIFY THEIR RATES- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE DMH SEARS-SAVE CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION IN
HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS TO OUR RATE
REVIEW PROGRAM. AND FINALLY OUR
OFFICE OF ENFORCEMENT-
PROSECUTES VIOLATIONS OF THE
KNOX KEEN ACT THE DEAL MAKES THE
MANY YEARS OF WRITING TOOLS TO
ENFORCE THE LAW WHEN VIOLATIONS
ARE COVERED SUCH AS CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS FINANCIAL PENALTIES.
CEASE AND DESIST ORDERS FREEZES
ON A ROMAN AND INSTALLATION. OF
MONITORS OR CONSERVATORSHIP.
THAT COULD INCLUDE MY OVER. AND
ALL MY ON JUST QUICKLY PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ANNUAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLAN. ALTHOUGH COMMITTEE
AND QUALITY REVIEWS THAT WERE
PART OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. I'M
EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE THAT-
EARLIER THIS WEEK WHERE WE
RELEASED A LIST OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THEN SELECTED TO
PARTICIPATE ALL TWENTY TWO OF
THEM- OUR FIRST MEETING IS GOING
TO OCCUR ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FOUR- UP THIS YEAR THIS MONTH.
SO WE'RE EXCITED TO GET KICK OFF
THAT WORK- WE'VE ALSO SELECTED
AN EXTERNAL CONSULTANT SELLERS
DORSEY WHO WAS HELPING US
PREPARE FOR THE FIRST MEETING
AND WILL FACILITATE THE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS AND ASSIST
WITH SUMMARIZING THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A REPORT
LATER THIS YEAR. BASED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATIONS
ESTABLISH A PRIORITY SET OF
QUALITY MEASURES AND
HEALTHEQUITY QUALITY BENCHMARKS
FOR ALL SIR FULL SERVICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS. THE PLANS WILL ANNUALLY
SUBMIT A REPORT CONTAINING DATA
AND INFORMATION ON THE QUALITY
MEASURES AND THEIR- PROGRESS IN
MEETING THE ANNUAL BENCHMARKS-
THIS WILL START THE RECORDING
WILL START IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
FOR MEASUREMENT HERE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- THROUGHOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS PROPOSAL WE WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. H. TRYING
TO COVER CALIFORNIA CALPERS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. I'M
EXCITED THAT WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL OF
THOSE DEPARTMENTS OF WILL SERVE
ON THE COMMITTEE AS EX OFFICIO.
NONVOTING MEMBERS- SO WITH THAT
I WILL PAUSE AND SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OTHER WEEK
OTHERWISE WE CAN MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER PMR PCPS. I THINK BUSH'S
ORDER TO PRINT AS QUESTION GOOD
YEAH OKAY UP BEFORE GET TO THE
CITY SO. ACTUALLY TO ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT. SURE YOU'RE DOING
THAT EQUITY IN QUALITY WERE. AND
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT COMES
OUT OF THAT BUT I KNOW ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT COME UP AND PASS
HEARINGS. IS GETTING GOOD DATA
COLLECTION FROM THE PLANS I KNOW
THERE WAS ONE YEAR WHERE
LITERALLY. I THINK LIKE LESS
THAN. 10% HAVING OF PLANTS
PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE DATA WE
HAD TO GO BACK THOUGH YOU KNOW
THROUGH THIS. SO WHAT IS THE
STATUS OF OUR- DATA COLLECTION
FROM PLANTS TO BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE ENFORCEMENT OF START
TIMELY STANDARD ALRP. HE TURNED
OUT AS A STANDBY ACCESS
STANDARDS OTHER TYPE SO- SO
WILL- BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY WE CAN
ENFORCE THEM BEFORE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION SO-
AND SO I KNOW THAT YOU'VE THAT
THAT'S BEEN WORKING BUT IS ALSO
SEEMS TO BE YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LAG GOES. BECAUSE YOU DO THE
SURVEY. AND THEN YOU ANALYZE IT
AND THEN. NOW TO THE TO OLD
BEFORE YOU GO ABOUT DO ANYTHING
IT SO. WHERE WHERE WHERE ARE WE
NOW WITH- THE QUALITY OF DATA
WE'RE GETTING FROM PLANS FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE TAXES
STANDARDS. SURE ONLY FIFTEEN WAS
THE YEAR WE HAD- SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES AND COULDN'T EVEN REPORT
ON THE DATA- THE GOOD NEWS IS WE
HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA THAT IS COMING AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO. HAVE A
REPORT AND YOU GOT ANALYSIS
EVERY YEAR SOUNDS- I WILL SAY
THAT I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES WE MADE TO
THE METHODOLOGY WAS REQUIRE
EACH- THE PLANS TO HAVE A VENDOR
OR CONSULTANT REVIEW AND AN
AUDIT THAT THEY WERE COMPLYING
WITH THE- METHODOLOGY- SO
THERE'S SOME. OVERSIGHT THAT
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE- DOING WHAT
THEY SHOULD IN TERMS OF THE
COLLECTION REPORTING OF DATA SO.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE REPORTING THANKFULLY.
THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW AND NOW THE
OTHER I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
WAS IS THAT- AT THE FRANKLY THE
SOME OF THE AND- THE- THE
STANDARDS THAT LEAD TO
ENFORCEMENT- SO- BECAUSE- NO
COMPLIANCE. MAY BE REALIZED HERE
EXPECTED ONE BE 100% SIDE I
THINK. THE COMPLIANCE RATE
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE TO BE
BETTERED AND LIKE 80% OR
SOMETHING AND I GET THAT RIGHT I
MEAN IT IT'S- 70% OF THE 70% SO
THAT MEDIA 70% SO THAT'S IT
MEANS ALMOST ONE IN THREE YEAR
TIMES STILL FOR A CONSUMER. IF
THEY FAILED TO TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARD. I GUESS IT'S
TECHNICALLY ONE ENTRY LEVEL A
LESS THAN ONE THREE THEN THEN
THE PLANE WENT I MEAN SO. SO
WHAT ARE YOU FINDING FROM PLAN
TELL ME PLANS OR SORT OF WICKS
AN INMATE I THINK BE INTERESTING
TO KNOW MAYBE DON'T HAVE THE
SAFETY FINGERTIPS HOW MANY PLANS
ARE NINETY PERCENTILE AYE MERE
80% SO I'M HERE 70% SO
TECHNICALLY ALL THOSE PLANS ARE
QUOTE OKAY. BUT YOU KNOW YOU
DIDN'T START THINKING SEVENTY
PERCENTILE WELL. THAT'S ALMOST
ONE IN THREE TIMES THAT
SOMEONE'S NOT ACTUALLY BEING THE
STANDARD. SO IS IT IN SOME I
MEAN. SO WHAT ARE MOST OF PLAN
SITTING IN THAT EIGHTY THIS IS
ABOUT SEVENTY TO EIGHTY
PERCENTILE OR YOU KNOW IT I MEAN
I DO. IT WHEN WE DEVELOP THE
STANDARDS WE THOUGHT OF THEM AS
MINIMUM STANDARDS NOT STANDARDS
THAT WERE. YOU KNOW. IDEAL SO
CONTINUE SPEAK CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHERE PLANS ARE UNDERSTAND AND
IN RELATION TO THE STANDARDS.
SURE YEAH LOOK LET ME LET ME
TALK ABOUT THE SEVENTY PERCENT-
PARTMINER WHAT THAT MEANS IS
WHEN WE CONDUCTED WAR WITH THE
HEALTH PLANS CONDUCTED THE
SURVEY AND THEY CALLED A RANDOM
SAMPLE OF THE PROVIDERS- 70% OR
MORE OF THE PROVIDERS THAT
ANSWERED THAT CALL FOR THE
SURVEY- HOW TO BOOK AN
APPOINTMENT AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE LAW- THE TIME NEXUS
STANDARDS DON'T MEAN THAT- EVERY
SINGLE PROVIDER THAT YOU WANT TO
SEE- WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE AN
APPOINTMENT AVAILABLE ON THE
DATE. THE TIME WHEN YOU WANT TO
SEE THEM BUT IT MEANS THAT THE
NETWORK NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT OUR PROVIDED A POINT
WITHIN THOSE STANDARDS- SO THERE
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE A PROVIDER
MAY NOT HAPPEN APPOINTMENT WHEN
THEY'RE CALLED THEY MAY BE ON
VACATION THEY MAY BE WORKING
PART TIME. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS WHEN THAT
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS CONTRACTED
WHY THEY NOT MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
MEET THE STANDARD. BUT WE AND
WHAT WE EXPECT IS THAT THAT 70%
MEANS THAT THE NETWORK SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT IN A TIMELY
APPOINTMENT I WILL SAY THAT 70%
STANDARD WAS HORRIFIED ARE
REGULATION WHICH WAS RECENTLY
APPROVED WILL BE TAKING A FACT.
AND SO GOING FORWARD- WE WILL BE
ABLE TO HOLD THE HEALTH PLANS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT STANDARD IS
NOT BEEN CODIFIED IN REGULATION
FOR THAT SO- WE HAVE AN ANNUAL
REPORT WILL BE REPLACING THE
TWENTY TWENTY AND A REPORT HERE
IN THE NEAR FUTURE. I'M AND TAKE
A LOOK AT BE ABLE TO GET A SENSE
OF WHERE THE PLANTS ARE. IN
TERMS OF MAKING THAT THAT
STANDARD. OKAY WELL I TAKE A FOR
PRE PEOPLE REALIZE. AS A STEP
THAT. IS YOU KNOW WE'RE- LASERS
INTO CIRCUMSTANCES- BUT- WHEN
WAS WITH WE'RE DEVELOPING
WHETHER WE MODIFIED IN THE
FUTURE OR WHATEVER ELSE AND I
KNOW YOU WANT TO REGULATORY
PROCESS THAT WE ARE. SAYING THAT
. THAT'S ONLY 70% OF TIME THAT
THAT THE IF YOU'RE- ACTUALLY
TAKES EFFECT IN THAT AND I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY HOW FAR YOU LOOKED
EXTREME GO YOU KNOW AND THE
OTHER ACCOUNT. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
THAT 70% YOU KNOW HOW HOW FAR SO
THIRTY FIVE METERS OF ISSUESFOR
PERHAPS SOME POLICY REFINEMENT-
THEN I GUESS ONE OTHER QUESTION
I HAVE IS YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
COLD AND I KNOW THAT- DME SEES
BEEN BUSY WITH THE TRYING TO
ENFORCE A CODE STANDARDS. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE FEDERAL STANDARDS
CENTER OUT THERE OBVIOUSLY YOU
FORCE OR STATE STANDARDS- YOU
KNOW WHEN THE THINGS THAT
THERE'S A CERTAIN CERTAINLY
HITTING THE NEWS AND- AND ARE
YOU WORKING ON THROUGH
LEGISLATION I DID. ASSURING THAT
PEOPLE GET PAYMENT FOR PROTESTS
AND A TESTING- SO CAN YOU JUST.
PERHAPS SPEAK TO THE- WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING. AND TO ENSURING
PEOPLE GET THERE THE DATA TESTS
ARE AVAILABLE AND THAT THEY GET
THEM PAID FOR- SINCE THE YOU
KNOW. SINCE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SER SAID YOU GO
THROUGH YOUR INSURANCE PLAN- AND
THEN OF COURSE WE'VE HAD
LEGISLATION THAT PARALLELED.
SOME CENTER FEDERAL GUIDANCE. SO
NOW. MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK SINCE
SINCE THE TURN OF THE GAME
REIMBURSED BY HEALTH PLANS FALLS
IN YOUR LAP- SO- THE TERMS
PEOPLE BE SURE THEY CAN GET
THEIR THEIR TESTS. AND NOT HAVE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS. YEAH NO
ABSOLUTELY AND I WILL SAY THAT
BECAUSE IT IS BEEN KEEPING US
VERY BUSY WITH ADELINE STAGE-
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE WERE
PROVIDED ME THE UTMOST
PROTECTION TO CONSUMERS. THE
GOOD NEWS IS WE DO HAVE THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT NOW THAT
HEALTH PLANS COVER WORK FOR
COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS THAT
THEY'RE COVERING UP TO EIGHT OR
AT LEAST EIGHT AT HOME COVERAGE
US- ND REIMBURSE YOU NOT GOING
TO SAY TWELVE DOLLARS OR SERVE
NO ONE SAYS CHECK OUT- SO ALL OF
THE HEALTH PLAN SHOULD HAVE A-
OF. A PROCESS ON THEIR WEBSITE
OR BY CALLING THE HEALTH PLAN-
CHECK TO PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
CONSUMERS ABOUT HOW TO GET
REIMBURSED FOR THOSE AT HOME TO
US. WE CONTINUE TO HAVE COVERAGE
FOR OTHER TYPES OF TRUST AS WELL
AS VACCINES- I WILL JUST SAY IF
ANYBODY NEEDS INFORMATION WE
HAVE FACT SHEETS AND INFORMATION
OR WHAT OUR WEBSITE AT HEALTH
HELP DOT CA DOT GOV- IF ANYBODY
IS HAVING ANY CHALLENGES GETTING
REIMBURSED EITHER FOR THEIR AT
HOME CHEST WORK FINDING OR
GETTING- EITHER BECAUSE THEY
TEST FOR A VACCINATION PAID FOR-
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM FIRST TO
CALL THEIR HEALTH PLAN AND THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ASSIST THEM
BUT IF NOT OUR HELP CENTER IS.
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO HELP
CONSUMERS NAVIGATE WHAT ARE
SOMETIMES VERY COMPLICATED
PROCESS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY'S GETTING
THE TEST BOX NATION THAT NEED.
APPRECIATE THAT SOME COMPLAINTS
ARE SOME OF THE PLANS THAT. THEY
ALSO PLAN TO MAKE IT EASY SOME
PLANS MAKE IT HARD GRADE SO YOU
GOTTA DOWNLOAD A PIECE OF PAPER
FILE THAT MALE ATHLETES AT THE
CHECK IT'S ADDRESS. I THINK SOME
CONSUMERS ARE TRYING TO FINALLY
EXPERIENCE WHAT WHAT DOCTORS OF
EXPERIENCE. REALIZE HOW PAINFUL
IT IS SO TO GET PAID SO- BUT
HOPEFULLY TEAMMATES IS GOING TO
WORK WITH THE HEALTH PLANS TO
TRY TO MAKE IT. EASIER. BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT. THE STAFF TO GO
THROUGH WHAT THE AFTER THROUGH.
AND TRY TO ENCOURAGE THEM ALL TO
MAKE IT. FOR TO GET ME. FOR THE
TESTS WE WANT PEOPLE TO GET TO
OF THE NEW WHAT THEY'RE- OFF
MOTHER BEAR. PEOPLE GET TESTS.
OF THE WITH THE READY. WE DO
WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE IN. YOU KNOW
INSPECTED THE FREIGHT TO GET
TESTS SO THEY DON'T KNOW AND
THEN SPREADING CONTINUE TO
SPREAD THE DISEASE. TO
APPRECIATE ANY EFFORTS IN THAT.
REGARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
I GUESS I WOULD JUST JUST
WONDERING IS IT AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE PLANS. WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH SCHOOLS ON MENTAL
HEALTH HOW INVOLVED HAVE YOU
BEEN IN THAT AND HOW IS THAT
PROCESS GOING. FIAT NOW IT IS I
WILL SAY WE'VE BEEN VERY
INVOLVED SO- THANKFUL FOR THIS
IS JENNIFER JONES LEADERSHIP IN
THAT AREA WE HAVE. AN
INDIVIDUAL- DEPARTMENTS AND BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE CONVERSATIONS
BOTH WITH ALL STATE AGENCIES BUT
OUR EDUCATION PARTNERS AS WELL-
OUR ROLE IN THIS OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE LISTENING AND LEARNING ALONG
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE- BUT OUR
ROLE WILL COME I THINK A LITTLE
BIT LATER ONCE WE HAVE KIND OF.
THE SERVICES THAT WILL BE
COVERED IN THE REIMBURSEMENT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMERCIAL AND ROWLEY'S DON'T
FIND A CLOTHES STORE- AT ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS SERVICES STRESSFUL SO
WE'LL BE WORKING VERY CLOSELY.
WITH OUR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. AS WELL. HER
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE SOME OF
ONE MEMBER WHAT WE'RE DOING. OUR
MEDICAL RELEASE AND FOR. IT'S AN
FOR CAL YOUR A 100% POSITIVE
WERE READY TO GO. MORE READY TO
GO LIVE AND ALL THOSE CONTRACTS
ARE GOING TO BE IN PLACE FOR ALL
THOSE EXTRA SERVICES THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE PROVIDING. ALL
LISTED BERMAN HEALTHCARE SERVICE
I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT WE ARE A
100% READY TO SUPPORT EVERYTHING
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND MAKING
SURE THE HEALTH PLANS ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE IN THE KNOX YUNEEC THAT
WE HAVE JURISDICTION OVER I LOVE
THAT PAYMENT THANK YOU DIRECTOR.
OKAY- MISTER JOHNSON YOU HAVE
ANYTHING BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE- OKAY. SO THEN LET US MOVE
ON TO- THE BCPS FLORIDA TURNED
OVER TO DAN AND I'LL BE BACK
ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATOR PAN PLEASE STAND
SOUTHERN ON THE CHIEF DEPUTY
RECORDS DO YOU SEE. I'LL PROVIDE
A BRIEF OVERVIEWS FOR ISSUE TWO
WHICH IS OUR OFFICE SUPPORT AND
LICENSING. WORKLOAD PROPOSAL.
DEEPLY SEIZE OFFICE SUPPLY AND
LICENSING IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING HEALTH PLANS COMPLY
WITH KNOX QUINA. THIS IS
ACCOMPLISHED BY REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS FOR LICENSURE
ANNUAL COMPLIANCE FILINGS UNTIL
MODIFICATIONS AND AMENDMENTS TO
EXISTING LICENSE. AB FIVE NINETY
FIVE WHICH WAS AN ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CHOIRS A
HEALTH PLAN THAT INTENDS TO
MERGE OR CONSOLIDATE WITH. OR
PURCHASE ANY ENTITY. INCLUDING
ANOTHER HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN
SECURE PRIOR APPROVAL FROM THE
DIRECTOR DO YOU SEE. AB NINETY
FIVE ALLOWS THE USE YOU CAN TO
CONDITIONALLY APPROVED THE
CHANGE OF CONTROL TRANSACTION
AND AUTHORIZES THAT THE REACH
YOU TO DISAGREE CHANGE OF
CONTROL TRANSACTION. THAT A
SUBSTANTIALLY LESSEN COMPETITION. OR CREATE A MONOPOLY IN
CALIFORNIA. MISTER A DVC TO
CONDUCT COMPLY. LEGAL AND NOW
WHICH DETERMINE. OF THE EFFECT
ON ROLLING'S WHETHER THE
TRANSACTION INVOLVES A TERRIBLE
AMOUNT OF ASSETS. IT WHETHER IT
WOULD ADVERSELY AFFECTED WILL
LEASE OR THE STABILITY OF THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
THIS
INDEFINITELY. WE GOT ISSUE THREE
THE OFFICE OF PLAN MONITORING
OUR WORKLOAD PROPOSAL THE BBC'S
OFFICES RIGHT WATCHING
PERFORMERS MEDICAL SERVICE OF
LICENSE HELP IS IT REVIEWS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS STE THE
NUMBER OF LICENSE HEALTH PLAYS A
COVER LIVES THE DMC'S
JURISDICTION HAS STEADILY
INCREASED FROM ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE LICENSE HEALTH PLANS
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION COVERED LIVES IN
200-015-2100 THIRTY TWO LICENSE
PLANS AT TWENTY SEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION COVERED LIVES IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. AS A RESULT
AS A RESULT OF THESE INCREASES
THE WORKLOAD FOR THE OFFICE BAND
ROCK BUDGETING HAS ALSO
INCREASED DVC IS THE VISA CREDIT
SERVICES REQUIRED FOR ROUTINE
MEDICAL SERVICE NO LESS THAN
ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS THIS ALSO
CONDUCT WE ALSO CONDUCT FOLLOW
UP STORIES AND NON ROUTINE
SERVICE WHEN NECESSARY REVIEW
APPLICATIONS FOR INITIAL
LICENSURE MATERIAL MODIFICATIONS
AND AMENDMENTS. TO HELP HIS
LICENSE. THE OF EACH OF SERVICE
EXTREME AN INCREASE WORKLOAD.
PLEA TO FILING. CHANGE TO HELP
OPERATE. AND PROCESSES AND MORE
FREQUENT REVISIONS JALKANEN
DOCKINS A RESULT IN DEFICIENCIES
FOUND DURING ROUTINE MEDICAL
SERVICE. IT SHOULDN'T DVC
DIVISION PROVIDER NETWORKS IS
REQUIRED REVIEW HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER NETWORKS USUALLY NEED
TO NETWORK ADEQUACY STANDARDS
ESTABLISHED IN THE KNOX KEEN
ACTS WHICH INCLUDE ENSURING THAT
WORKS FOR THE RIGHT TYPES OF
PROVIDERS NECESSARY TO LOOK OVER
SERVICES PROPER UNDER POLICY
UNDER THE ROLE THESE CONTRACTS.
GEOGRAPHIC ACCESS REQUIREMENTS.
AND PROVIDED TO WILL THE
RATIONS. INDIVIDUAL PROVIDER
NETWORKS AS EXPERIENCE IN 92%
INCREASE IN NETWORK FILINGS FOR
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. INCREASING FORTY OF 48%
BUT YOUR MODIFICATIONS FROM
FIFTY TO. 200-015-2772 THOUSAND
TWENTY. TWENTY PERCENT. AN
ANNUAL NETWORKING VIEW ENTIRELY
ASK ACCESS REPORTING. FROM ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT IN 200-015-2100
THIRTY IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
THERE IS A PROVIDER THAT WAS
ALSO SEEN INCREASING NUMBER OF
CHINA. GAMES FOR OUR IN OUR
HEALTH PLANS FROM TWENTY TWO IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO SIXTY
SIX IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
FURTHER ADDING TO THE RESOURCES
REQUIRED. TO CONDUCT THAT WORK
FOR THE CURRENT STAFFING AND
CONSULTING FUNDING LEVELS ARE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE CONTRACT MANAGEMENT.
TIMELY RIDING OF SURVEY REPORTS
TO BE STRINGENT LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS ARE CONDUCTED ALL
THE REQUIRED MEDICAL SERVICE
NETWORK B. AS A MANNER
CONSISTENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENT. TO ADDRESS THIS WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS USE REQUESTED
LEVIN POSITION. AND EXPENDITURES
ALREADY FOR MANAGED CARE ONE
THREE MILLION TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND JUST CLEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AT THREE
MILLION ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
THOUSANDAND WE THEREAFTER. TO
ADDRESS THIS WORK ON. THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES ANNUAL EXPENSE
REPORTING RELATED TO CARE PLAN
OF EASTERN CITY THOUSAND IN
CLINICAL CONSULTING SERVICES TO
ASSIST WITH THE COMPLETION. OF
HEALTH PLAN MEDICAL SERVICE.
INVESTIGATORS OF THIS OVERVIEW.
OKAY THANK YOU WANT TO OFFICE OF
FINANCIAL REVIEW. I BELIEVE THE
NEXT WITH THE HELP CENTER WERE
CLOSED OKAY. SO RANDY SHE'S HELP
CENTER EDUCATES CONSUMERS ABOUT
THEIR HEALTHCARE RIGHTS RESULTS
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. HELPS TO
CONSUMERS NAVIGATE AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR COVERAGE IS
JUST CONSUMERS ARE GETTING
TIMELY ACCESS TO. HEALTH CARE
SERVICE MELTZER ALSO PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDERS TO
ENSURE THEY RECEIVE TIMELY AND
ACCURATE PAYMENTS THIS INCLUDES
INDIVIDUAL AND MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS EMERGENCY AND NON
EMERGENCY SERVICE COMPLAINTS D.
WAS HE ESTABLISHED AN
INDEPENDENT DISPUTE RESOLUTION
PROCESS SHORTFALL RESOLVE THOSE
DISPUTES. THE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF HEALTH PLAYS A ROLE
THE SUBJECT TO THE DICTATES HE'S
JURISDICTION OUTSIDE HIS
WORKLOAD IS PROGRESSIVELY
INCREASE. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE OFFICERS INCREASE
OF 46% IS STANDARD COMPLACENT
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEWS
PRODUCE NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
SHE'S THREE YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. A PROXY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. WITHIN THIS
INCREASED TO HELP SERVE AS
RECENTLY HAS SEEN RECENT MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY REQUIREMENTS TRY A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH RELATED COMPLAINTS MORE
THAN DOUBLING FOR PROSTATE. ONE
THOUSAND PIECES IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN JUST OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
THE RESOURCES TO QUESTIONS
PROPOSAL WILL HELP KEEP PACE
WITH HEALTHCARE MARKETS CHANGES
IN GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF ISIS
HELP ISN'T COVERED LIVES WITH
YOU DIGITAL RESOURCES. L. PLAYS
BEING. WITHOUT THE RISKS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES HEALTH
PLANS MAY NOT BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE PROPER TIME FRAMES
WHICH MAY RESULT IN ROLLING OUT
. RICK DAVIS HE'S REQUESTING
TWENTY ONE POSITIONS SIX
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR'S CARE
FUND A LOT OF THREE MILLION FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND GETS
HERE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AT
THREE MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
TWELVE THOUSAND AND WE
THEREAFTER TO ADDRESS THIS
INCREASED WORKLOAD. REQUEST
RESOURCES ALLOW THE DVC TO MEET
INTENDED TIME REVIEWING PROVIDER
SURE THANKS FACILITY TO MORE
ROBUST KEYS FUNDING PROCESS AND
BRING SUPERVISORY STAFF YOUR
MIND. DEPARTMENTS SCHOOLS. SOME
COMPLETION OF THAT REVIEW. HELP
HELP CENTER. HELLO BOND ISSUE
FOR FIVE WHICH IS THE MINISTRY
OF. OFFICE ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD BCP. DEC TO MINISTRY OF
SERVICES DIVISION SUPPORTS
DEMPSEY'S MISSION BY ENSURING
THE GAMES YOU PROGRAM IT IS HAVE
THE RESOURCES SERVICES AND TOOLS
REQUIRED TO FULFILL THEIR DAY TO
DAY GETS DAVIS HE'S EXPAND HER
THIRTIES INCREASE FROM EIGHTY
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO APPROX
THREE HUNDRED FOUR MILLION
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
CONSISTENT WITH ESCROW. IT
NUMBER OF ALL POSITIONS AT A
CRUCIAL FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
EMPLOYEES IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TO FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EMPLOYEES. IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THIS PROPOSAL BY THE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT AT
ADDRESSING INCREASED WORKLOAD
RESULTING FOR BETRAYING IT GOODS
AND SERVICES REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT LEGISLATIVE MANDATES.
PROCESS A REAL TRANSACTIONS IT
WILL BE A NEW PERSONAL LAWS
REGULATIONS PROVIDE ADEQUATE
PROJECT MANAGEMENT. REENGINEERED
AUTOMATE CRITICAL BUSINESS
PROCESSES AND MODERNIZE
APPLICATIONS TO ENSURE ADA
COMPLIANCE AND IMPLEMENT
POLICIES FOR TWO IT PROCEDURES
TO ADDRESS SYSTEMIC RACISM.
HITCHER COMPLIANCE WITH EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY LOS. DO YOU SEE IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSITIONING FROM TRADITIONAL I
CODE SUFFERED ABILITY TO LOCAL
MARKETING WORKS OUT. WHICH
REQUIRE LITTLE OR NO CODING TO
BUILD APPLICATIONS ACROSS THIS
MOVING FORWARD. D. IS REQUESTING
PROPOSITIONS AND EXPENSE
REPORTING THE MAYOR'S CARE FUNDS
THREE MILLION 500-200-0020 TWO
TWENTY THREE. THREE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DAILY TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY THREE NINE AND
TWO POINT TWO FOUR MILLION AND
WE THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK. THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES EXPENDITURE
THIRTY FOR THE MEN'S CARE FUND.
FOR CONSULTING FUNDING
CONSULTING FUNDING AMOUNT OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION ANNUALLY. FROM
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE UNTIL
TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE. TO SYSTEM DEEMS HIS
OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
TO MEET CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS
IS FORCING DAVID SEES
FINALIZATION EFFORTS. LASTLY
THIS PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
THREE OR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
FUNDING AND WE FOR CLOUD
SUBSCRIPTION COSTS RQUIRE
HONORED LOCAL SUFFERS A SERVICE
BUSINESS CHALLENGES TECHNOLOGY.
THAT CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW S. B.
C. P. OKAY. I THINK I DON'T SEE
A MACHINE JONES WITH HIS HAND
OPENER I THINK WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIX TELEHEALTH. I
SHOULD WHO. AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
AN EXTRA PROTECTION OF DECENT
CHOICE IN TELEHEALTH PROVIDER
ACT STATES PURPOSE OF TELEHEALTH
IS TO ALLOW PATIENTS TO INTERACT
WITH THEIR HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
WITH SAFETY OR CONVENIENCE
MEXICAN PERSON TREATMENT.
DIFFICULT IMPOSSIBLE. BILL ALSO
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO FOUNDER
RAY REPORTS FOR THE NBC
REGARDING THE UTILIZATION OF
CORPORATE CELL HEALTH SERVICES.
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO ENSURE
THAT CORPORATE TELEHEALTH
PROVIDERS SAID PATIENT RECORDS
TO ROLL THESE PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
AND SECTION THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR POINT ONE FOUR ONE TWO
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE.
ESTABLISHES A MAJOR REQUIREMENTS
FOR HEALTH PLANS BUT IT OFFERED
WILL YOU SERVICES THROUGH A
THIRD PARTY CORPORATE TELEHEALTH
PROVIDER. INCLUDING DISCLOSURES
TO ENROLLEES UNAVAILABILITY OF
RECEIVING SERVICES THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS PATIENT RECORDS DIRECT
ACCESS TO THIRD PARTY COVERAGE
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS IN A
RECORDING BY HEALTH PLANS.
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS CHICKEN
KERR IS THE USE OF LOCAL IN
NETWORK SERVICES INSURE PATIENT
RECORD CONTINUITY ON HEALTH
PLANS HEALTH PLAN ENROLLEES
ELIZE SERVICES FOR CORPORATE
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS. AB FORTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES A TEAM
SEEDED TRAFFIC LEGAL MEMORANDUMS
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
AB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN PROMULGATE
A REGULATION TO CLARIFY THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH PLANS.
TO GO TO BE A PERSON UNTIL
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. THE NETWORK
ADEQUACY REGULATIONS PERTAINING
TO THE REQUIRED FILINGS
INVESTIGATED TAKEN COURSE OF
ACTION IS APPROACHED AS
APPROPRIATE I GUESS HEALTH PLANS
THAT DO NOT COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS. REVISED TELEHEALTH
CHECKLIST TO INCLUDE NEW
DISCLOSURE IN THOSE REQUIREMENTS
AND DRAFT A SUMMARY AND GUYS
FROM FROM ALL PLAY LETTER. IT
HITS THE TIMELY ACCESS NAY NO
NETWORK ADEQUACY SYSTEMS TO
COLLECTED TELEHEALTH DATA FOR
ANGEL NETWORK AND TIMELY ACCESS
REVIEWS. AND REVIEW THE
ADDITIONAL DATA SOME OF MY
HEALTH PLANS TODAY WE SEE. UNDER
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTION.
ONE THREE SIX SEVEN POINT ZERO
THREE FIVE. DVC IS ACROSS THREE.
EXPENDITURES ALREADY FOR THE
MANAGED CARE ON AN AMOUNT OF ONE
MILLION ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND. TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. 1-005-700-0234 AND SIX
HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND DAILY
THERE AFTER TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
CARS AB. FOUR FIFTY SEVEN. IT'S
REQUEST INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS LIMITED
TOWARD RESOURCES AND JUST FOR
YOUR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. TO
CONDUCT LEGAL RESEARCH ISSUE
WIGGLE MEMORANDUM THE PUBLIC
REGULATION. AND FINALLY THIS
REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES FRAZIER
THIRTY FROM MANAGED CARE OF THE
MAGNITUDE NINETY THOUSAND.
INTERFERE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FOR CONSULTING SERVICES TO
IMPLEMENT ADDITIONAL COLLECTION.
AND THREE INTER FORTY THREE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR FOR CONSULTANT FUNDING TO
ENHANCE A TIMELY ACCESS. NETWORK
ADEQUACY ADEQUACY SYSTEMS TO
COLLECT DATA TELEHEALTH DATA FOR
A NEW NETWORKING TIME AXIS WEEKS
. CLOSE WITH OVERUSE. EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN. OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE DEDUCTIBLES. AND
I'M GONNA LET YOU DOWN REST HIS
VOICE SAYS I'LL TAKE OVER OKAY-
STILL TRYING TO MOVE QUICKLY
THROUGH THE REST OF I'M HERE SO
SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT ADDS NEW
PROVISIONS OF THE KNOX KEEN ACT
THAT REQUIRES HEALTH PLAN
CONTRACTS ISSUED AMENDED OR
RENEWED AFTER JULY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR- IN INDIVIDUAL OR SMALL
GROUP MARKET TO MONITORING OR
WHAT WAS APPROVED BALANCE
TRANSFER ANNUAL DEDUCTIBLE AND
OUT OF POCKET MAXIMUM- THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO
PROVIDE ENROLLEES BUT THEIR-
BALANCE TOWARDS THEIR DEDUCTIBLE
OUT OF POCKET MAXIMUM FOR EVERY
MONTH IN WHICH THAT BENEFITS FOR
YOU. UNTIL THE ACCRUAL BALANCE
EQUALS THE DOCTOR FOR OUT OF.
POCKET MAXIMUM AMOUNT- SERVICE
REQUIRES THE DIEM. TO RIGHT. TO
CLEAR THIS AND- OF THAT SYSTEM
THAT THEY HAVE TO USE TO TRACK.
OUT OF POCKET MAX LOCAL RULES
THE STANDARDS- FOR HEALTH PLANS
COMMUNICATE THIS INFORMATION TO
ENROLLEES- AND HOW THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO MONITOR THEIR ROLES.
WILL ESTABLISH DEREGULATION WHAT
CONSTITUTE A VIOLATION OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND POTENTIAL
PENALTIES. WILL ALSO ANNUALLY
REVIEW HEALTH PLAN DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING EVIDENCE OF COVERAGE
DISCLOSURE FORMS SUMMARY OF
BENEFITS AND SUBSCRIBER
CONTRACTS ENSURE COMPLIANCE. AND
WILL ANNUALLY REVIEW REVIEW PART
OF PROVIDER CONTRACTS IN PLANT.
LAND CONTRACTS TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY- WE'RE REQUESTING TO
POSITIONS OF EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUND OF FIVE HUNDRED NINETY ONE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
THOUSAND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
AND THAT CAN CAUSE IF SHE SEVEN-
I CAN KEEP MOVING ON THE ISSUE
H. YES- RELATED TO SB TWO TO ONE
THAT'S OKAY YES PLEASE. OKAY SO
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE DMH SEE
INSURERS AND ROLEN'S HAVE
CONSISTENT ACCESS TO TIMELY AND
MEDICALLY NECESSARY HEALTH CARE
INCLUDING SCHEDULED APPOINTMENTS
REFERRALS TO SPECIALISTS. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO OF THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTOR DID YOU
MAKE CENTER TO DEVELOP TIMELY
ACCESS REGULATIONS AND
CONSIDERATIONS OF SPECIFIED
INDICATORS. SUCH AS WAIT TIMES
FOR INITIAL HEALTH CARE
OINTMENTS- OF THESE REGULATIONS
BECAME EFFECTIVE IN TWENTY TEN
AND REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO
SUBMIT ANNUAL COMPLIANCE REPORTS
TO THE DAMAGE SEEK TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE. AND
PERFORMANCE WITH THE TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS- SB TWO TWO ONE
INCORPORATED SOME OF THE TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS ADOPTED BY THE
RIGHT IN REGULATION BY THE DMACC
AND TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AND INSURANCE CODE. S. TWO TWO
ONE REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS ARE OF
JULY OF THIS YEAR TO ENSURE THAT
ITS CONTRACTORS PROVIDER NETWORK
CAN OFFER NON URGENT FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS WITH THE NON
PHYSICIAN MENTAL HEALTH CARE OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PROVIDER.
WITHIN TEN BUSINESS DAYS OF THE
PRIOR REPORT APPOINTMENTS OR
LONGER FOR TREATING PROVIDER
DETERMINES A LONGER WAIT TIME
WILL NOT HAVE A DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT ON THE HEALTH OF THE
ENROLLEE. SB TWO TWO ONE ALSO
REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS TO ARRANGE
COVERAGE OUTSIDE OF THE PLANTS
CONTACTED NETWORK IF MEDICALLY
NECESSARY CARE IS NOT AVAILABLE
WITH THE NEW HEALTH PLANS
NETWORK. UNDER S. B. TWO G. ONE
THE GMAC IS REQUIRED TO
PROMULGATE A REGULATION TO
CLARIFY REQUIREMENTS AND
STANDARDS FOR THOSE FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS FOR NON PHYSICIAN
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND SUBSTANCE
USE ABUSE PROVIDERS. SET FORTH
PARAMETERSAND STANDARDS FOR
ADEQUATE CAPACITY AVAILABILITY
AND SUFFICIENCY OF THE PROVIDER
TRACK TYPE SUBJECT OF TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS I WILL BE
REVISING OUR METHODOLOGY- TO
INCLUDE A NEW METRIC TO
DEMONSTRATE THE AVERAGE WAIT
TIME FOR EACH CLASS OF
APPOINTMENT. WILL BE DEVELOPING
STANDARDIZED METHODOLOGIES FOR
REPORTING TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE WITH TWO TO ONE- AND
ANNUALLY REVIEWING HEALTH PLAN
DOCUMENTS FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
THE TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS
STANDARD REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDED. WE WILL ALSO
INVESTIGATE AND TAKE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION RECESSED ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES AGAINST PLANTS ARE NOT
COMPLIANT. AND ENSURE HEALTH
PLANS THAT USE A TERROR NETWORK%
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE THE
TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS OF THE
LOWEST COST SHARING CHEER. UP
MORE REQUESTING SIXTEEN
POSITIONS AND EXPENDITURE
REPORTING FROM MANAGED CARE FUND
OF ABOUT THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. AND AN ADDITIONAL
THREE POSSESSIONS IN ABOUT FOUR
AND A HALF MILLION IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. FOUR MILLION
IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND
ABOUT WORKS WAIT THREE MILLION
IN. TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX YEAH
I'M GOING. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW AS TWO TWO ON I
COULDN'T MOVE ON TO ISSUE IT BY
SIXTEEN. OKAY UNDER EXISTING THE
KNOX KEEN NOT ALLOW THE WHOLE
PLAN TO REQUIRE. THERAPY THERE
IS MORE THAN ONE DRUG IS FOR THE
TREATMENT OF A MEDICAL
CONDITION. AND AUTHORIZES A
HEALTH PLAN DO YOU UTILIZE STEP
THERAPY. AB THREE FORTY SEVEN
REQUIRES A HEALTH PLAN OR
INSURER CHECKS EXPEDITIOUSLY
GRANT A REQUEST FOR STEP THERAPY
EXCEPTION AT THE PRESCRIBING
PROVIDER DETERMINES USE OF THE
DRUG. REPORT REQUIRED UNDER STEP
THERAPY IS INCONSISTENT WITH
GOOD PROFESSIONAL PRACTICE FOR
THE PROVISION OF A COVERED
SERVICES. WHILE TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION WHEN ROLLING SHE
NEEDS MEDICAL HISTORY OF
PROFESSIONAL JUNCTION. WHEN
INFORMATION NECESSARY FOR THE
HEALTH PLAN TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION IS NOT INCLUDED
WITH THE REQUEST FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION OR STEP THERAPY.
THE PLAN IS REQUIRED TO NOTIFY
THE PRESCRIBING PROVIDER WITHIN
SPECIFIED TIME FRAMES. ONCE THE
HEALTH PLAN RECEIVES THE
REQUESTED INFORMATION THE APPLE
THE GOAL TIME PERIODS OF
PERVERTED MIND A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION OR STEP THERAPY I
REQUEST WHICH BEGAN. UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF AB THREE FORTY
SEVEN THE ROLE IN THE APPEAL TO
THE HEALTH PLAN THROUGH THEIR
EXISTING GRIEVANCE PROCEDURES
AND PROVIDER STAND ISSUED
APPEALS AS PERMITTED UNDER THE
HEALTH PLANS EXISTING.
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
PROCEDURES. ARE WHAT STATE AB
THREE FORTY SEVEN REQUIRES THE
DAMAGE TO THE CROP PROMULGATE A
REGULATION TO CLARIFY THESE
REQUIREMENTS DEVELOP NEW MEDICAL
SURVEY QUESTIONS AND PROCEDURES
ARE ADDRESSED THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS- REVIEW THE NEW
INTERNAL APPEALS PROCESSES
PROCESSES AND REVIEW ANY REVISED
GRIEVANCE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. REVIEW REVISED
PRESCRIPTION DRUG POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. REVIEW CONTRACTS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
AGREEMENT INCLUDING PLAN TO PLAN
AGREEMENTS- BUT INCLUDE
UTILIZATION REPEAL. OF WILL ALSO
REVIEW PRODUCT FORMULA RECENT
PRESCRIPTION DRUG BENEFIT CHARTS
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH THE STEP
THERAPY AN APPEAL REQUIREMENTS
AND ANNUALLY REVIEW HEALTH PLAN
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING EVIDENCE OF
COVERAGE DISCLOSURE FORMS.
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT DATA AND
HEALTH PLAN. SURVEY DATA TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE. FIRST AS
ALWAYS WE WILL AND TAKE IN ARE
OR ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
AGAINST HEALTH PLANS THAT ARE
NOT IN COMPLIANCE. WE'RE
REQUESTING TWELVE POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
MANAGED CARE FUND OF ABOUT THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- AND ON GOING TO ADDRESS
THE STATE REQUIREMENTS. I WILL
KEEP GOING NUMBER TEN HE SAID
OKAY YES PLEASE ALRIGHT. OF WHAT
SAY SO NEXT STEP HERE WE HAVE A
BELIEVE IT'S ISSUED CHEN. WELL
I'M HERE SB TWO FIVE FIVE SB TWO
FIVE FIVE I'M HONEST I'M GONNA
SWITCH HERE TO MY BINDER. OKAY
LET'S SEE HERE SO- UNDER SB FIVE
FIVE AND ASSOCIATION OF
EMPLOYERS- ARE A VERY NARROW
EXCEPTIONS TO ALLOW. US IN
ASSOCIATION EMPLOYERS TO
PURCHASE LARGE GROUP- COVERAGE
THERE ARE CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE
MET. IT'S A VERY NARROW
EXCEPTION OR- ONE GROUP ENTITLED
TO CALL THE PRODUCERS HELP
BENEFIT PLANS- AND SO WE HAVE-
SOME SB TWO FIVE FIVE AND SEVEN
WRITER SEVEN ONE EIGHT ARE VERY
SIMILAR. BUT UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL- HEALTH
PLANS CAN'T MARKET ISSUE AMEND A
RENEWAL A LARGE GROUP COVERAGE
TO WHAT WE CALL A MULTI MULTI
EMPLOYER WELFARE ARRANGEMENTS-
AND ONCE THEY HAVE REGISTERED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT RIGHT. ON
JUNE FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
SO UNDER SB TWO FIVE FIVE WE ARE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A
REGISTRATION PROCESS BY JUNE OF
THIS YEAR WILL CREATE-
REGISTRATION FORM ALONG WITH THE
TRACKLIST APPLICATION FORM AND-
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS. WILL ALSO
ANNUALLY REVIEW EACH MEANWHILE
WERE YES YOU ARE FOR ON GOING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE SPEECH BY FIRE- TO MEET
THE CITY REQUIREMENT WERE
REQUESTED ONE POSITION AN
EXPENDITURE FOR. TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TWELVE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND IN THE WINTER AFTER.
YEAH MOVING ON TO ISSUE OF AS
ONE EIGHT VERY SIMILAR TO ESTATE
FIVE- THERE'S A NEW X. THAT WE
ALLOW. AND SPECIFIC A SEARCH
HEALTH PLAN B. BUT IF PLACE THE
- CHICKENS CONTINUE SELLING MARC
FOR COVERAGE TO ITS LIFE SCIENCE
COMPANY MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA-
UNLIKE SB TWO FIVE FIVE WHICH
DOES NOT HAVE A SUNSET DATE SB
SEVEN ONE EIGHT WELL SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX- SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE GMH SEE WE WILL HAVE A
REGISTRATION PROCESS WILL HAVE A
CHECK LIST IN A FORM FOR THEM TO
REGISTER WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THEN ANNUALLY WILL ALSO
REVIEW- ONGOING COMPLIANCE UNTIL
THE SUNSET DATE OF JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY SIX. WE'RE
REQUESTING IS EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY FROM THE MANAGED CARE
FUND OF THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND AND. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THREE HUNDRED
ONE THOUSAND TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR THREE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN- AND- THE SUNSET DATE FOR
TRIBUNE. WITH SB SEVEN ONE EIGHT
I THINK THAT'S THE LAST ONE.
OKAY LMAO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR BEN JOHNSON WITH THE L. A.
L. JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT FOR
ALL THE RESOURCE REQUESTED-
RESOURCE REQUESTS UNDER DMH SEE
WE'VE CONDUCTED OUR PRELIMINARY
REVIEW AND DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANYTHING. NOTITIA COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU IN MY REMARKS WOULD BE
. WE'RE DOING A LOT ON HIRING
PEOPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
BOMB FOR COMPLIANCE- BUT OF
COURSE THAT BEGS THE QUESTION OF
THE WORK FORCE ISSUE THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THROUGHOUT
THIS. THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING
THAT ARE NOT QUITE ENOUGH PEOPLE
OUT THERE PROVIDING THE CARE
BUT- BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
THAT THE PLANS ARE MAKING SURE
THEY GET THEIR CARE SO. THERE IS
A CONTRADICTION IN THERE THAT
DOES NOT LOST ON ANY OF US. AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND
TENACITY ON THIS BUDGET PLANS
DIFFERENT THING THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION I THINK ON
THE HOPE CENTER- I KNOW YOU'RE
ADDING TO POSITIONS FOR THE CALL
CENTER- I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ACTUAL TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT WERE TO GO FOR. THAT FIRST.
VISIT DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ACTUALLY. STATUS I'M JUST
CURIOUS IN TERMS OF FEAR CENTER.
WHAT SHE CALLED THE- WITH
COMPLAINTS AND- YOU TELL PEOPLE
CALL HEALTH PLAN FIRST BUT- HOW
BUSY IS THAT CALL CENTER. D. AND
G. DO YOU HAPPEN TO KNOW THE
NUMBERS OF THE CALL VOLUME WE
COULD CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP. AFTER
IN THE CALL CENTER I KNOW YOU'RE
ASKING FOR TWO MORE BUT HOW MANY
STAFF CURRENTLY. SO WE HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED STAFF THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN OUR HELP CENTER
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR MORE THAN
THAT. SO CAN I KNOW IF YOU HAVE
THE NUMBER HANDY OF HOW MANY
WERE ASKING COULD NOT BE. RIGHT
NOW. JUST GIVE ME A- ONE MOMENT.
OR TWO FOR THE CALL CENTER SOME
MORE FOR OTHER YOU KNOW FOR A
COMPLAINT MANAGEMENT ETCETERA
CELLS DISAPPEAR WE SO JUST
QUICKLY WELL WELL LOOK SET UP WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF OFFICES ARE
SECTIONS WITH OUR HELP CENTER WE
HAVE OPPOSITE NUMBER OF
ATTORNEYS THAT ARE DOING LEGAL
RESEARCH WE HAVE CLINICAL STAFF
WE HAVE STAFF THAT ARE
PROCESSING OR INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEWS AS WELL AS
COMPLAINTS AND I. THINK YOUR
ORDER WE ALSO HAVE OUR PROVIDER
COMPLAINT UNIT WHERE WE ASSIST
PROVIDERS WITH ISSUES THAT. ARE
HAPPENING- DAN. IT ONLY HELPS
YEAH WE HAVE PRICE BE TWENTY
FIVE STAFF. IN OUR CONTACT
CENTER IN ST PAUL OKAY ALL RIGHT
NEAR INTO MORE OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
YEAH I DID IT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL
KNOW- WHAT THE TREND IN TERMS OF
COMPOUND COMPLAINTS I MEAN I.
HAVE SOURCE SUGGESTED THAT ALSO
WITH OUR OFFICE OF INSIGHTS WHO
HAS STOCKS OF PATIENT ADVOCACY
AND THEN AND THEN THE OTHER PART
IS AGAIN APPRECIATE TO I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE THESE NARROW
EXCEPTIONS AND SO. IT CERTAINLY
AT THE SUNSET IMPORTANT FOR
WHOEVER SITS ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AT THAT POINT TIME TO BE SURE WE
HAVE. GOOD FEEDBACK ON WHERE
THOSE EXCEPTIONS GOING TO TURN
INTO A PROBLEMS ARE THEY WORKING
OKAY- AND TO APPRECIATE THAT THE
MODERATE OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S
IT. YEAH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DIRECTOR AND STAFF WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU SO I THINK WE WILL NOW
TRANSITION TO OUR FINAL
PRESENTATION- FOR. TWO ONE TWO
ONE. THAT'S RIGHT OKAY THE. TO
JUST FOR- COORDINATION SAKE WE
SHOULD TELL EIGHTEEN T. WILL
NEED THEM LONGER THAN WE
CURRENTLY HAD SCHEDULED. OKAY
THANK YOU- SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
MR- TO BE DOING A BRIEF. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE
TO BE HERE TODAY. WELCOME SO
JUST YOU KNOW IN RESPONSE TO THE
COMMENTS AND OUT OF RESPECT FOR
YOUR TIME AND RECOGNIZE THAT
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY FUNDS
PROVIDE YOU WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE COMMISSION
CONSISTENT WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER PRESENTATIONS TODAY AND
THEN ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS PARTICULARLY AROUND
THE AUGMENTATION THE NOW STUDENT
SERVICES ACT- TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE BCPS AS WELL AND THEN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. IN TERMS OF A VERY BRIEF
OVERVIEW THE COMMISSION AT YOU
KNOW RELATIVE THE DEPARTMENT
THAT YOU'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
COMMISSION IS VERY SMALL. WE
HAVE ABOUT FIFTY STAFF AND SOME
CONTRACTORS THAT WE WORK WITH.
OUR BUDGET FLUCTUATES WITH
REGARD TO MOSTLY ONE TIME FUNDS
ARE STATE OPERATIONS IS ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND NOW I'M GOING SUPPORT. WE
HAVE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDING. AND THEN ONE TIME FINES
BECAUSE OUR ANNUAL BUDGET TO
FLUCTUATE. FOR THINGS LIKE THE
MEDICAL STUDENT SERVICES ACT OR
OTHER- ONETIME GRANT PROGRAMS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE GOVERNOR
AUTHORIZES. THIS YEAR THAT LOCAL
ASSISTANCE BUDGET IS ABOUT
SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS. THE
COMMISSION IS AN OVERSIGHT BODY
AS EVIDENCED BY OUR NAME. WE DO
A RANGE OF THINGS WE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS IN PARTNERSIP WITH
OUR COUNTY AND OTHER LOCAL.
AGENCY PARTNERS- WE REVIEW AND
APPROVE COUNTY INNOVATION PLANS.
WE PROVIDE THROUGH SOME OF THE
ONE TIME FUNDS THAT YOU
AUTHORIZED WHAT WE WOULD WHAT WE
REFER TO AS INCENTIVE FUNDING
WHICH REALLY TRYING TO THINK OF
THESE DOLLARS. AS LAST ABOUT
JUST COURSE SUPPORT BECAUSE OF
THE DIFFICULTY OF SUSTAINING
THOSE PROGRAMS AS COURSE APART
AND INSTEAD THINK OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AS WAYS WE CAN USE ONE
TIME UNLIMITED FUNDS TO CREATE
FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR SYSTEMS
CHANGE IT'S JUST TO PREVENT. AND
THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE A ROLE.
WITH IN TERMS OF DATA ANALYSIS
AND RESEARCH. ARE VERY QUICKLY
THE PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE THAT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. WE HAVE A
VERY EXCITING PROJECT ON EARLY
PSYCHOSIS IN CALIFORNIA A
PROJECT TO BRING AN EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICE ON YOUTH DROP IN
CENTERS- THE NEWLY AUTHORIZED
WORK TO STRENGTHEN OUR FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROJECTS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THAT- AND LEADERSHIP
ON THAT WE HAVE AN ARRAY OF
STRATEGIES AROUND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DIVERSION SUICIDE
PREVENTION STIGMA REDUCTION IN
AWARENESS. OUR TRIAGE SPD TO
PROJECT TO FOCUS ON BUILDING OUT
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR PEOPLE
WHERE WE ASK OUR SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. AND WE
HAVE A VERY ROBUST INVESTMENT IN
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY WHICH
CONSISTENT WITH THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU HEARD THROUGHOUT THE
DAY TODAY IS VERY IMPORTANT. IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT PEOPLE
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE ARE PART
OF THE SOLUTION AND DISCUSSION
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN OUR SYSTEM AND THERE
AT THE TABLE AS WE TALK ABOUT
POLICY IN OTHER PROGRAMMATIC.
DECISIONS THAT ARE BEING MADE.
THAT'S MY VERY QUICK VERY BROAD
OVERVIEW. ABBOTT ANSWERING
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. IN
TERMS OF THE FACT THAT OVER YEAH
. WHEN YOU WERE YOU WERE VERY
EFFICIENT- YOU HAD A LONG DAY
MANAGER YOU NOT TELL ME ANYTHING
MISTER- LET'S LET'S MOVE ON TO
BE SHEEPISH WONDER THAT DOCTRINE
IS THAT OKAY AND I DON'T SEE- NO
LOWER BACK THEY DON'T HAVE YOUR
HAND UP MISTER. OKAY HERE WE GO
ALL RIGHT THEN LET'S MOVE RIGHT
INTO. ISSUE NUMBER TWO. YEAH I
DO WANNA JUST IN TERMS OF THAT
QUESTION AT THE AUGMENTATION OF
THE MILL HALL STUDENT SERVICES
ACT. SHOULD NOTED THAT WE
STARTED OUT THE YEAR WITH THIRTY
SEVEN LOCAL PARTNERS AND AS OF
EARLIER THIS WEEK- WE ADDED
SEVENTEEN MORE LOCAL PARTNER SO
OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WERE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH FIFTY FOUR OF THOSE TO
BUILD OUT MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES. PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
CAN BE HERE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
AND LOCAL SPROUT LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES THERE ARE FOUR THAT
WE'RE STILL WORKING WE HAVE TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE BARRIERS THAT
THEY'RE FACING IN TERMS OF
ACCESSING THOSE FUNDS AND BEING
ABLE TO DEPLOY THE KINDS THAT'S
COMMON HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS. THAT
WE'RE BUILDING OUT IN OTHER
COMMUNITIES. I'M SORRY I
APOLOGIZE. THAT I DID MENTION
THAT IN THE BROAD OVERVIEW. IN
TERMS OF THE SEVENTY IN HIS
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE THE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM. YOU KNOW
THIS IS. A PROPOSAL TO IMPLEMENT
THE AGREEMENT THAT WAS DISCUSSED
LAST YEAR FOR WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
TO PUT TOGETHER AN INTERAGENCY
AGREEMENT SO THAT THE COMMISSION
CAN EXPAND UPON THE WORK THAT
IT'S ALREADY BEEN DOING. IN THE
AREAS THAT THAT WILL BE
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE BROADER ADMINISTRATION. IN
TERMS OF THOSE EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT WILL BE SUPPORTED
WITH THE APP THAT THE BROAD
FINDING THAT WENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AND THERE'S 10% THAT WILL BE SET
ASIDE FOR THE COMMISSION WE WILL
BE SERVING ON THE- ADVISORY
COUNCIL THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
PUTTING TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY HOW
THE SUN SHALL BE USED. YEAH AND
THAT FUNDING THAT WOULD TRANSFER
TO THE COMMISSION WOULD BE USED
TO. SUPPORT THAT BROUGHT
INITIATIVE WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
FROM THE WORK THAT WE'VE ALREADY
DONE AND BUILD UPON THAT WHERE
RELEVANT. I WOULD ASK THE
PERMANENT FINANCE TO RESPOND IF
YOU HAVE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE FUNDING. BUT IN TERMS
OF THE GOALS OF THE STRATEGY I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND. BERMAN I THINK
WE'RE OKAY NOW. I MOVED TO THE
IF YOU THREE. YES THANK YOU SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR A SMALL
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO
SUPPORT SOME ADDITIONAL STAFF.
AS WE'VE WORKED WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS TO BUILD OUT THIS KNOW
HOW STUDENT SERVICES ACT THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES THAT
ARE BECOMING VERY APPARENT
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT WORKFORCE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY TODAY- WE'RE
REALLY SEEING TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES AS OUR SCHOOLS ARE
CAN BE A HEALTH PROGRAMS ARE
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS BEGIN TO COMPETE. FOR
LIMITED POOL OF STAFF AND THAT
THAT'S THAT'S- YEAH EVEN BEST A
LOT OF TIME IN ADMINISTRATION IS
INVESTING A LOT OF TIME AND
ENERGY TO ADDRESS I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT. WE ALSO WANT TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE KINDS OF
PROGRAMMATIC INVESTMENTS. THAT
ARE MOST EFFECTIVE SO THAT WE
CAN BEGIN TO IDENTIFY THE
CONTINUOUS SERVICE SAYS THAT
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL PARTNER
SHOULD BE INVESTING IN ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE GET.
ROUTINELY FROM OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS IS HOW CAN THEY MAKE
BEST USE OF THESE FUNDS. AND WE
DO NOT YET KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT
WHAT THE RIGHT MIX OF SERVICES
IS OUR FOR THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN
THE RIGHT CONDITIONS. IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS AND COMMUNITY SETTINGS
IN THE HOME- DEPENDING ON ON
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE WHO THE
INDIVIDUAL IS. SO WE'RE SEEKING
ADDITIONAL STAFFING SUPPORT TO
BE ABLE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
CAPACITY TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT AND THE OUTCOMES THAT
WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE. WITH
INVESTMENT THAT YOU'VE PROVIDED
UNDER THE MEDICAL STUDENT
SERVICES ACT. THANK YOU. MOVE
MOVING ON IF I AM FOR IS THE
EVALUATION OF CLOSER PARTNERSHIP
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIP MODEL
IT WAS ESTABLISHED UNDER SB FOUR
SIX FIVE AGAIN THANK YOU
LEADERSHIP ON THAT AGAIN WERE
BREATHTAKING STAFF SUPPORT TO
IMPLEMENT THE- THE PARAMETERS
ARE TESTED FOR SIX FIVE. ZERO
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
STAFF POSITION AND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CONTRACTS
FUNDING TO DO THE ANALYTIC WORK
AS NECESSARY TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
FSB'S SO I RECOGNIZE THAT THAT
RUNS AT SOMEWHERE IN THE BILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR FINDING RANGE AND
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
BEST UNDERSTAND IF WE'RE GETTING
ARE THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK AND IF NOT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. OKAY AND THAT.
IF I'M NOT IF I'M NOT READING
THIS WRONG THAT COMPLETES YOUR-
PORTION IS THAT CORRECT.
ABSOLUTELY TRYING TO BE VERY
EFFICIENT HERE YOU ARE VERY
EFFICIENT AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT- THAT I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU DO AND I THINK
THIS IS THE YEAR THAT YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS REALLY GOING TO
START SHINING PEERS WERE ALL
TALKING ABOUT OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND I AND I'M
SURE YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THAT FOR YEARS LONGER THAN WE
HAVE AND SO WE'RE FINALLY
CATCHING UP WITH YOUR CHORUS AND
SING ALONG WITH YOU- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND AS WE-
CONTINUE TO REALLY TRY TO FIGURE
OUT. IF THE BEST WAY THE BEST
USE OF OUR RESOURCES. THEN TAKEN
THEN THEN TO DIRECT MORE
RESOURCES. TO WHAT WORKS BEST TO
HELP- MOST VULNERABLE. AND AGAIN
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ALL DAY
LONG IT IS A FULL CONTINUUM OF
CARE. AND THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING ON SOME OF THE FRONT AND
PSYCHOSIS IT JUST VITALLY
IMPORTANT- THE THAT THAT PART
GETS DONE IN THE BEGINNING. AB
SO I. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS. AND
I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE SEEING
SOME. SOME UPDATES OF THE OF
THAT ENTIRE PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
COME WITH A LOT MORE OUTCOMES
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH I THINK
WAS ONE OF THE THINGS LACKING
WHEN IT WAS FIRST PUT- BYE BYE
EVIDENCE OF IT'S BEEN AROUND FOR
A LONG TIME AND WE'RE STILL
STILL NOT REALLY SURE WHERE ALL
THE MONEY'S GOING. AND IF IT'S
EFFECTIVE SO WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE WORK THAT'S GOING ON WE WILL
BE VERY INTERESTED. IN FOLLOWING
UP AND HEARING A LOT MORE ABOUT
IT. I'M GOING TO START TO PANIC
HE HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YES- AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND- THE AND
CERTAINLY- I THINK THERE'S
TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN WHAT
YOU'RE DOING SO HOPEFULLY- WHILE
WE MAYBE. TRY TO BE BRIEF HERE
THAT DOESN'T WAY STE- THAT'S IN
TERMS OF THAT'S AN INDICATION OF
THE IMPORTANCE THAT- WEEK WE GET
TO THE WORKS OF ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF THESE SELF
PARTNERSHIP GRANT PROGRAMS-
BECAUSE THAT. IS A POSE THE
QUESTION TO- AND NOW. AROUND
HERE HEALTH INITIATIVE. NO HAVE-
OFTENTIMES RESULT BETWEEN THE
COUNTY AND THE EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS RIGHT AND- OF
COURSE THE KIDS TO GO TO SCHOOL
AND THEN THEY GO HOME. AND THE
CAT IS SO- SO IN TERMS OF- YOU
KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE- PUTTING SOME
FUNDS FOR IMPORTANT FUNDS TO
HELP INDUCE EVALUATION AS WELL
AS US. THESE PROGRAMS. HAVE BEEN
WHICH WAY DO YOU THINK YOU'RE A
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING IN
THIS AREA CAN HELP INFORM THE-
THAT BEHAVIOR HELP ME ON THE U.
FEVER HEALTH INITIATIVE AND WHAT
DO YOU THINK YOU MIGHT BE
GETTING SOME. RESULTS THAT YOU
MIGHT FEEL THIS. TO SHARE NÂNG
WITH THEM BUT ALSO WITH US AS
WELL. AND BEST PRACTICE MODELS
YEAH SO THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION
THE COMMISSION HAS A RECORD DUE
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND I THINK
ON MARCH FIRST THAT WILL
PRIMARILY FOCUS ON WHERE WE ARE
IN TERMS OF THE DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES SOME OF OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS HAVE HAD A COUPLE OF
YEARS TO BEGIN TO ROLL OUT THE
STRATEGIES AND SO WE HAVE SO
THERE'S THE OPTION TO LEARN
MORE. FROM THOSE PARTNERS THAN
THOSE WHO FOR EXAMPLE WERE
AWARDED FUNDS JUST EARLIER THIS
WEEK SO- SO I THINK YOU KNOW THE
- WHAT YOU SHOULD EXPECT FROM US
FIRST. IS JUST SOME
CLARIFICATION OF WHERE WE ARE.
AND THE KINDS OF CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING AND THE REALITIES
THAT ARE THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WE
BEGAN TO TRY TO AS YOU SAID SORT
OF STRENGTH IN AND ADDRESS SOME
OF THE STYLING. BETWEEN THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AT ITS CORE
THAT WAS THE COMMISSION'S
INTENTION. IN TERMS OF RELIGION
IS FUNDS AS WE WERE VERY
EXPLICIT THAT THERE NEEDED TO BE
ROBUST PARTNERSHIP SO WE CAN
ADDRESS THOSE SILOS. BUT HOW
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WERE FORMED
AND HOW AND WHERE THEY FOCUS
NEEDED TO BE WORKED OUT LOCALLY
SO THAT THEY WERE RESPONSIVE TO
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. THE STRENGTH OF
THAT APPROACH IS THAT ALLOWS US
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE DOLLARS
ARE RESPONSIVE AND TIMELY. THE
LIMITATION IS IT MEANS YOU'VE
GOT FIFTY FOUR DIFFERENT
APPROACHES WHICH MAKES IT VERY
HARD. TO CREATE A CONSISTENT
UNDERSTANDING. FROM FROM THE
NOTION OF A SINGLE PROGRAM IT'S
A PROGRAM IN TERMS OF THE
FUNDING SOURCE AND THE STRATEGY
THAT WE'RE ROLLING OUT. BUT IT'S
NOT A PROGRAM IN TERMS OF THE
KINDS OF SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
DELIVERED AND SO IT'S GOING TO
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO COMPARE
APPLES TO APPLES SO TO SPEAK.
ACROSS ALL OFTHESE DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES THAT'S GOING TO BE
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
THE FACTOR OF TIME- WHERE WE
HAVE ROLE THESE DOLLARS OUT I
BELIEVE ACROSS FIVE DIFFERENT.
STUFF FUNDING CYCLES SO WE'RE
STILL WORKING TO- KIND OF CATCH
UP. AND LISTEN AND LEARN FROM
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
FARTHER ALONG WHILE ALSO TRYING
TO SUPPORT THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE JUST GETTING STARTED.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME THIS YEAR
WORKING WITH THE TWENTY COUNTIES
THAT DID NOT APPLY TO PRIOR
FUNDING CYCLES TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE BEARS THEY FACED.
ENTER INTO THE HAIR BACK. THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM SO
THAT WE HAD THE FEWEST
REQUIREMENTS WE COULD. PUT IN.
INTO THAT PROGRAM WHILE STILL
COMPLYING WITH THE REQUIREMENTS-
IS THE STATE FUNDING RULES- BY
JUST AS THE FEDERAL AND THE
FEDERAL. FUNDING RULES IN THE
INSTANCES WHERE REASONS ON THE
FUNDING. SO I. SENATOR I THINK
IT'S GONNA TAKE A COUPLE OF
YEARS AT LEAST. TO REALLY. BE
ABLE TO CONNECT AN INTERVENTION.
TO AN EDUCATIONAL OUTCOME. BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN'T LEARN
SOMETHING. ABOUT HOW EFFECTIVE
THESE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES ARE
IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING THE SILO
ING ISSUE. THAT IS OFTEN AT THE
CORE OF WHY. MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES ARE STARVING NEED
ACCESS TO CARE AND SO I THINK
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO REALLY BE
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE CAN SAY.
AROUND ISSUES LIKE GOVERNANCE
AND INCENTIVES BARRIERS TO CARE
THE NEED FOR TRAINING AND THE
IMPACT THAT THOSE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS ARE HAVING. IT'S A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION TO THEN
SAY EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES ARE ON
THE UPSWING BECAUSE WE'VE MADE
THERE THESE KINDS OF INVESTMENTS
IN MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLBEING-
YOU KNOW IN SAY. MIDDLE SCHOOL
FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
AT NIGHT OF APPRECIATE THAT IN A
IN AND REALIZE THAT- YOU KNOW
TAKES TIME TO DO VALUATION AND
I'VE SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE. THE
PROCESS MUST HAVE GONE ON LONG
ENOUGH FOR YOU TO EVALUATE AND
SEE EXACTLY SOME DATA- SO. BUT I
GUESS I ALSO HOPE THAT- IS WE'RE
RUNNING THESE THINGS IN PARALLEL
WE TALK ABOUT THE URGENCY OF
BEING ABLE TO TRUST THINGS FOR
EXAMPLE WENT. HOPEFULLY AND
MAYBE USING QUALITATIVE
APPROACHES AT LEAST WE CAN LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT HOW LEAST THAT.
THE PROGRAMS HAVE COME TOGETHER
HOW THEY MANAGED TO YOU KNOW GET
THE STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER HOW TO
GET EDUCATION COUNTY TO WORK.
SOME OF THE PER EVEN SOME OF THE
PROCESS LESSONS MIGHT BE VERY
HELPFUL AS WE'RE TRYING TO ROLL
OUT THE OTHER INITIATIVE AS WELL
SO- SO I REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE BIG EVALUATION THAT THE
PRIDE ONE THAT NOW THAT THE-
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED EVALUATION.
I CAN'T TAKE PLACE FOR MANY
YEARS. BUT THERE MIGHT BE SOME
INTERIM STUFF ESPECIALLY ON THE
QUALITATIVE SIDE THAT. WE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER INVESTING IN
THAT WAY TO HELP INFORM. LIKE
HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE COUNTIES IN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS TO WORK
TOGETHER RIGHT AND SO- DOING
QUALITATIVE VALUE BEYOND THE
RESEARCH ON. THIS DONE PEOPLE
HAVE COME TOGETHER NOW WE DO ON
THE SUCCESSFUL THERE
COLLABORATION END UP. BY AT
LEAST WE THE- MANAGED AS WORK
TOGETHER BY EVEN THAT MIGHT YET
HAVE A BEAR SOME- SOME. USEFUL
INFORMATION FOR US MOVING
FORWARD. ABSOLUTELY THAT HE SAID
THAT VERY WELL BUT IT'S MUCH
BETTER THAN I DID NO ONE ONE NO
I WANT TO JUST COMMENT ON. IS
ACROSS THESE FIND WE HAVE A
COUNTIES THAT ARE EITHER FUNDING
OR PLANNING TO FIND. A YOUTH
WELLNESS CENTERS ON THEIR
CAMPUSES I HIGHLIGHT THAT
BECAUSE JUST AND IT JUST PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC KIDDING WE
SPONSORED AND IDEA LAB WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM FIVE DIFFERENT
COUNTY. FOCUSED ON SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH AND THE IDEA THAT ROSE TO
THE TOP OF ALL OF THEIR
DISCUSSION SUPPOSED TO CREATE
SAFE SPACES ON CAMPUS WHERE
STUDENTS CAN BE THEMSELVES FOR
THEY COULD. DE STRESS AND RELAX
AND CATCH THEIR BREATH. THIS IS
ALSO CONSISTENT WITH WORK OUT
OF- SOLANO COUNTY. THAT WHERE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE CAME TOGETHER
AND SAID WELLNESS CENTERS ARE
THE BEST WAY THAT SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES CAN SUPPORT THAT
THEIR THEIR STUDENTS. AND SO
ACROSS SEVENTEEN KEY ACROSS
EIGHT COUNTIES ARE INVESTING IN
TWENTY WELLNESS CENTER FOR
PLANNING A SITE VISIT- WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE YOU COME ALONG. WE
SEE THESE AS TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES TO BOTH LISTEN TO
THE VOICE OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO
DESIGN THEM IN WAYS THAT IS VERY
USE RESPONSIVE. AND NOW WE WANT
TO UNDERSTAND AS YOU SAY IT'S A
VERY QUALITATIVE MAINS WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE TAKEAWAYS THAT CAN
INFORM. FURTHER CONVERSATIONS IN
OTHER COMMUNITIES SHOULD THIS BE
A BEST PRACTICE THAT WE CAN
SCALE. EVEN WHILE WE'RE
BEGINNING TO UNDERSTAND HOW
PARTICIPATION IN THE DEVELOPMENT
AT WELLNESS CENTER MIGHT CHANGE
MENTAL HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. SO YEAH FOR EXAMPLE AS
AN EXAMPLE I THAT COMES TO MIND.
IN RESPONSE TO YOUR COMMENTS
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I DON'T SEE ANYTHING FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR AND
DILIO. OKAY SEE HEAD SHAKING AT
ME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION SURE WE
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE TO OUR FINAL ISSUE. IS
COVERED CALIFORNIA. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR DR PAN HI KATIE
RAVEL POLICY ELIGIBILITY IN
RESEARCH DIRECTOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA HERE TO TALK ABOUT
OUR TO CLOSE OUT ISSUES- THE
BULK OF OUR ISSUES ON OUR REPORT
BRINGING CARE WITHIN REACH I DO
HAVE SOME SLIDES THERE. HAPPY TO
JUST ADDRESS ISSUE ONE QUICKLY
AND THEN TURN TO THE SLIDES- A
THE FEDERAL AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
IS WELL SUMMARIZED- IN YOUR
COMMITTEE AGENDA BUT IT DID
REFORM THE INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET. AND ESTABLISH
PUBLIC MARKETPLACES. FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH PLANS WITH
INCOME BASED FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOWER PREMIUMS AND
OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T HAVE
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE THROUGH AN
EMPLOYER. THROUGH THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM THROUGH MEDICARE COVER
CALIFORNIA IS CALIFORNIA'S
INSURANCE MARKETPLACES
ESTABLISHED UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT. WE CONTRACT WITH HELP
TWELVE HEALTH INSURANCE CARRIERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LANDS
OFFER A PACKAGE OF WHAT'S KNOWN
AS ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS.
CONFERENCE OF SERVICES TO FIND
AT A HIGH LEVEL IN THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND THEN OUR
MEMBERS CHOOSE FROM SEVERAL
COVERAGE OPTIONS THAT VARY IN
THE AMOUNT OF MONTHLY PREMIUMS
THEY PAY VERSUS OUT OF POCKET
COSTS AND WE'LL DIVE DEEPER INTO
THAT AS WE GET INTO THE REPORT-
OVER A TEN YEAR HISTORY WE'VE
USED THE TOOLS OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT IN OUR STATE
AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION. TO
PURSUE OUR MISSION WHICH IS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS TO IMPROVE HEALTH
CARE QUALITY LOWER COSTS REDUCE%
AND REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES BY
BEING AN INNOVATIVE COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACE AND EMPOWERING OUR
CONSUMERS TO CHOOSE PLANS AND
PROVIDERS TO GIVE THEM THE BEST
VALUE. AND THE LAST THREE YEARS
HAVE BEEN- EXCITING FOR US AS
STATE AND FEDERAL ACTION HAS
BUILT ON THE FOUNDATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT TO PROVIDE
MORE SUPPORT KERN ROWLEY'S TO
HELP THEM AFFORD COVERAGE. AND
WE ARE PROUD IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
IMPLEMENT THE NATION'S LEADING
CALIFORNIA PREMIUM SUBSIDY
PROGRAM ALSO A BACKGROUND IN
YOUR AGENDA. THE FIRST STATE IN
THE NATION TO PROVIDE PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES TO MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO AREN'T ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL SUBSIDIES UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. AND IN THE
LAST YEAR IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN THE
RECESSION THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
FEDERAL PREMIUM SUPPORT FOR
INDIVIDUALS AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
UP IN THE COVER CALIFORNIA
MARKET PLACE AND SIGNIFICANTLY
REMOVED THAT PREMIUM
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR LOWEST
INCOME. ENROLLEES AND REMOVE THE
INCOME CAP THAT PREVIOUSLY
BARRED MIDDLE INCOME ENROLLEES
FROM ACCESSING FEDERAL PREMIUM
SUPPORT AND WITH ALL OF THIS A
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL INVESTMENT
IN AFFORDABILITY- OUR ENROLLMENT
HAS PUSHED TO RECORD LEVELS WERE
AT AN ALL TIME HIGH. OF ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN RALEIGH'S
IN OUR PROGRAM THIS IS MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
AT ENROLLEES ARE HIGHER THAN AT
THE START OF. TWENTY TWENTY
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. MANAGER I
THINK THE PROBABLY ISN'T PLACE
FOR US TO MOVE TO ISSUE TO START
. TALKING THEIR UP- I GUESS
ADDITION MICE IF WE CAN GET THAT
LINK TO ME YOU PROMISED AT THE
BEGINNING WE WANT TO SEE THE
SLIDES. THEY ARE DONE AS IS THE
REPORT BUT I PROMISE YOU SEE THE
HIGHLIGHTS IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME. I WILL CALL THEM BACK NOW
. AND I THINK THAT COMMITTEE
AGENDA WELL TRAINS- SOME OF THE
FEDERAL UNCERTAINTY AND THAT'S
STILL NEED POLICY ENVIRONMENT
RIGHT NOW SO YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE
SOME CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN.
BETWEEN COVER CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATION ADMINISTRATION OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS THIS
WEEK HAVE THAT CERTAINTY MORE
CERTAINTY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO I TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE FEDERAL
PREMIUM SUPPORT. THEY CAME IN
WITH THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
BUT DESPITE THAT IMPROVE PREMIUM
SUPPORT WE HAVEN'T REALLY MOVE
THE NEEDLE O CARSHARING
SUPPORTED STILL LIMITED TO OUR
LOWEST INCOME ENROLLEES. REALLY
THE BULK OF THE SUBSIDY BECAUSE
GENITALS FOR UNDER TWO HUNDRED.
102% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL AND THEN SOME LIMITED
SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS UP
2210050% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL THE SLIGHTEST OBVIOUSLY
DATED DENSO JUST HIGHLIGHTS. AND
SOME OF THE EFFECTS THAT ARE
ENROLLEES FEEL AS THAT FEDERAL
SUPPORT DECREASES. AND
DEDUCTIBLES THAT THE EXPERIENCE
FOR IN PATIENT CARE RISE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY WERE ABLE TO KEEP
THOSE DEDUCTIBLES LIMITED TO IN
PATIENT CARE- BY THE RISE FROM.
SORT OF MODEST LEVEL OF SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS UP TO THE THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS AS INCOME. INCREASES
AND THAT'S FEDERAL SUPPORTS
DISAPPEAR SIMILARLY ON THE CAPS
THAT LIMIT ARE YOUR MAXIMUM
EXPOSURE IN THE YEAR. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY HITTING SOME OF THOSE
COPAYS AND SERVICE AS A PRIMARY
CARE FOR GENERIC DRUGS. SO I
DEFINITELY IMPACTS. OUR
ENROLLEES AND THEIR CHOICES AND
HERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF THAT SORT
OF OUTCOME OF NASH AND- THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT OFFERS A
VARIETY OF COVERAGE LEVELS WE
CALL THEM THE OLYMPIC MEDAL
TEARS THEY RANGE FROM BRONZE TO
PLATINUM- AS THE NAMING
CONVENTION IMPLIES THOSE GO
FROM- LOW GENEROSITY HIGH
GENEROSITY IF YOU'RE IN A BRONZE
PLAN IN VERY LOW MONTHLY
PREMIUM. BUT SIGNIFICANT COST
SHARING OR DEDUCTIBLES AND ARE
PROBLEMS PLAN. AT SIXTY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL A DOUBLE FOR A FAMILY
SO AS THOSE FEDERAL SUPPORTS
DISAPPEAR FOR COST SHARING. OUR
ENROLLEES ARE CHOOSE BRONZE AT A
SIGNIFICANTLY. HIGHER SHARE AND
THEN WE HAVE THAT WE HEARD SOME
DATA STATEWIDE DATA FROM
DIRECTOR LANDS BURKE ON. THE
IMPACTS OF ENROLLEES FEELING
AFFORDABILITY IN TELLING CARE
JUST A DATA POINT IN THIS SLIDE.
TOMORROW NUMBER DATA ABOUT OUR
ENROLLEES WERE ENROLLED IN IN
BRONZE AT REPORTING DELAYING
CARE AT THREE TIMES THE RATE OF
OUR ENROLLEES WHO ARE AND OUR
MOST GENEROUS PLAN. ON ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS COME WITH THEIR OWN
WONKY TERMS SHOW OVER NINETY
FOUR IS OUR MOST GENEROUS PLAN
THAT'S FOR OUR OUR LOWEST INCOME
ENROLLEES PROVIDES THEM AS A
VERY STRONG OUT OF POCKET COST
SHARING SUPPORT. DO YOU SEE THE
EFFECTS OF THIS ARE IN
AFFORDABILITY FOR OUR MEMBERS
THIS WITH THAT I THINK THE
POLICY LANDSCAPE. THAT LED THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASK US TO LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE IN DEPTH. AND SO WE
DID RELEASE- BRINGING CARE
WITHIN REACH. APOLOGIES FOR THE
BABY PICTURE THAT WE PUT ON THE
SIDE OF THE COVER THE REPORT-
BUT THIS PROVIDE SPECIFIC
OPTIONS FOR HOW WE CAN USE OR
OTHER STATES COULD YOU STATE
FUNDING FOR FEDERAL FUNDING. AND
TO EXPAND CARSHARING SUPPORT WE
ALSO RELEASED A SHORTER ISSUE
BRIEF AND VERY DETAILED ANALYSIS
BY OUR ACTUARIES WHO SUPPORTED
US IN THIS PARK. AND WE WERE
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE BEEN PUT AN
ENGAGEMENT FROM A RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERS. AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND AGAIN IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT THE STATE
BUDGET ACT IN THE TRAILER BILL
FROM LAST YEAR- SO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT ASK FEDERAL
LEGISLATION. THE BILL BACK
BETTER ACT OR A SIMILAR FEDERAL
POLICY WOULD EXTEND THOSE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES THAT ARE IN EFFECT FOR
THIS CALENDAR YEAR. WE DO THAT
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF THE SUBSIDIES THAT
HELP LIKE I SAID HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT. AND THIS THAT HOUSE
PASSED VERSION OF BUILD BACK
BETTER WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH
AFFORDABILITY. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE TEN BILLION PER YEAR FOR
EACH YEAR THREE YEARS ON THE
SLIDE. IT WOULD ALLOW STATES TO
ROUTE TO LOWER THE COST SHARING-
AND PREMIUMS- SO VERY SIMILAR TO
THE CONCEPT THAT WAS INCLUDED-
WHEN THE STATE PUT AWAY THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION IN THE
STATE AFFORDABILITY FUND FOR
THIS PURPOSE. AND SO THAT'S THE
POTENTIAL FEDERAL POLICY
LANDSCAPE. AND GIVEN THAT OUR
REORT FRAME SORT OF THREE
SCENARIOS- ONE- OF. THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN SUBSIDIES EXPIRE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THERE'S NO FEDERAL
ACTION TO EXTEND THEM. AND THAT
WOULD OBVIOUSLY GIVE THE STATE
TRADE OFFS IN TERMS OF. HOW TO
SPEND THE AFFORDABILITY MONEY TO
LOOK AT CAR SHARING A TO LOOK
AT. AND WE LOOK AT THE STATE
PREMIUM SUPPORT PROGRAM. THE
NEXT OPTION IS THAT AND BUILD
BACK BETTER IN CONCEPT THIS
STUNNING PREMIUM SUBSIDIES IN
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
SUPPORTS WE HAVE SOME OPTIONS
THERE. AND THEN LASTLY AND THIS
WAS REALLY WHERE WE GET MOST OF
OUR WORK THIS IS I THINK WHAT
WAS ANTICIPATED WHEN THEY'RE OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE ASKED US
TO LOOK AT THE- A. R. P. PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES ARE EXTENDED SO WE
HAVE THAT. MUCH MORE GENEROUS
PREMIUM SUPPORT WE USED THE
STATE FUNDING TO COMPLEMENT THAT
AND REDUCE COSTS AND SO THOSE
ARE. THE THREE SCENARIOS. WE
FRAME WORK. I WON'T BELABOR
THIS. WE ARE DEFINITELY WORKING
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SO THAT ALL OF THE FACTS. ARE
VERY CLEAR ASHER PUBLIC AND
POLICY MAKERS ABOUT WHAT IT
WOULD NEED A CLEAN LISTING
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES. I'M JUST A HIGH LEVEL
OF HE DATA POINTS HERE. ON
AVERAGE OUR ENROLLEES WITH NEWS
ABOUT A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
HOUSEHOLD PER MONTH. AND IT
WOULD BE A TOTAL ANNUAL IMPACT
OF ABOUT ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN PREMIUM SUBSIDIES.
AND THE REPORT BREAKS DOWN-
THAT- THE POTENTIAL LOSSES.
ACROSS OUR INCOME GROUPS AND
JUSTICE BACKGROUND IF WE NEED TO
TURN TO THIS AND THINK ABOUT.
POTENTIALLY AT RESTORING ESTATE
PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM IN SOME
FORM OR FASHION. BUT I WILL MOVE
TO THE NEXT SCENARIO WHICH IS
REALLY. WHAT WE WANT TO LOOK AT
THE CAR SHARING POTENTIAL
QUESTIONING SUPPORT. OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS JAM PACKED WITH DATA I
DON'T WANT TO WALK YOU SERVICE
FOLLOWING HIGHLIGHTED YOU
THINGS. THE MAIN EXHIBIT IN THE
REPORT. WHAT WE TRIED TO DO HERE
pDIFFERENCES ON THE OPTIONS ARE
THAT CAN BE HELPFUL. AND AS YOU
DIG INTO THEIR AND YOUR TEAMS TO
THINK ABOUT. A POTENTIAL OPTIONS
FOR CALIFORNIA THIS IS THE
FEDERAL FUNDING SLIDES OF THE
DOLLAR AND THE COST. OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE HIGHER. AND
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN WHAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE. RESEARCH
NOW. AND I'LL JUST ON THAT TOP
ROW IT'S OUR MOST GENEROUS
OPTION. WE ACTUALLY PULLED IT
FROM SOME MODELING THAT WAS DON
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL BY
RESEARCHERS AT THE URBAN
INSTITUTE AS THEY WERE LOOKING
AT POTENTIAL AND NATIONAL
PROGRAMS TO EXPAND CARSHARING
SUPPORT MARKET PLACES. AND THIS
IS THE ONE OPTION WE MODEL THAT
WOULD PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT TO
MIDDLE INCOME CONSUMERS UP
26100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. AND THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY A
PRAIRIE STATE WANTED THE PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO PROVIDE SOME
SUPPORT TO MIDDLE INCOME. AND
PUT ASIDE FROM THAT- I WOULD
NOTE THAT SHE THINGS-
DEFINITELY. UPGRADE CARSHARING
SUPPORT WE HAVE OVER A MILLION
INDIVIDUALS. AND UNDER 210050%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
ELIGIBLE FOR SUPPORT TODAY. I'M
SO SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
UPGRADING. THEIR AFFORDABILITY-
WE DREW FROM THE STATUTE WHICH
DEFINITELY ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE IMPACT OF DEDUCTIBLES AND WE
WOULD USE THIS FUNDING TO
ELIMINATE DEDUCTIBLES IN THE
PLANS THAT PROVIDE DISCUSSION
SUPPORT. AND AS YOU SEE THE
NINETY FIVE NINETY FIVE EIGHTY.
M. THOSE ARE- SORT OF OUR
REFERENCE POINT FOR GENEROSITY
THE PLAN A 95% PLAN WOULD PAY ON
AVERAGE 95% OF THAT PERSON'S
AVERAGE EXPECTED COST WHAT IS
NOT MEAN TARGETS IS THE ABILITY
TO OFFER BENEFIT PACKAGES. THEY
GIVE YOU A FIVE DOLLAR PRIMARY
CARE VISIT OUR THREE DOLLAR
GENERIC DRUG PRESCRIPTIONS SO
AND THIS WOULD ALL GET-TRANSLATED INTO BENEFIT DESIGNS
AND THAT LOOK MORE FAMILIAR WHAT
IS AN EMERGENCY VISIT COSTS BUT. AS A PRIMARY CARE VISIT COST.
ON TO THIS REPORT. WE DID ROLL
UP TO THE AGGREGATE SO I'M
GETTING MEMBERS. UP TO A VERY
GENEROUS COVERAGE LEVELS. SO
THAT'S- SORT OF A SOME OF THE
WAY WE FRAME THE POLICY HERE AND
SOME OF THAT- THE WASTE COMPARE
OPTIONS. I'LL PAUSE OWNER- SHE
NEREO THREE THIS IS. LAW FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. EXTENDS PREMIUM
SUPPORT AMONG THE STATE LOOKS TO
ENHANCE CARSHARING SUPPORT WE
OFFER FOUR OPTIONS IN YOUR
REPORT- DRAWN LARGELY FROM THE
STATUTE. IN MOST OF THESE
OPTIONS TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS UP 24100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL CAN HAVE
CAR SHARING SUPPORT. AT LEAST
THE GOLD LEVEL SO PLAN PAYING ON
AVERAGE. IN THAT TOP ROW THAT
MOST GENEROUS YOU'D BE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND TO
REDUCE COST SHARING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
TODAY FOR FEDERAL SUPPORT. AND
SO WOULD DEFINITELY MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS. AND THEN OFFER
BRAND NEW SUPPORT TO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ABOVE
210050% UP 24100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL. TO PROVIDE THEM
QUESTIONING SUPPORT FOR THE
FIRST TIME. AND AGAIN ALSO
ELIMINATING DEDUCTIBLES. ALL
OPTION FIVE IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAT WOULD JUST FOCUS
ON INDIVIDUALS WERE ELIGIBLE
TODAY AND PROVIDE THEM AN
UPGRADE. AND YOU MIGHT SAY THAT
THAT LOOKS KIND OF EXPENSIVE-
CONSIDERING THAT IT IT DOESN'T
EXPAND A LEGIBILITY. I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE HAVE- AND
QUITE A FEW ENROLLEES IN THAT
INCOME RANGE SO YOU'D BE
INVESTING IN. A LOT OF PEOPLE
THEY'RE JUST ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL SUPPORT DAY- STEPPING
DOWN ONE A LITTLE BIT LESS ANA.
UPGRADE FOR EXISTING ELIGIBLES
THAT WOULD REALLY FOCUS ON
EXPANDING THAT BENEFITS TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TODAY-
AND THEN WE DID IT BECAUSE OF
THE EMPHASIS STATUTE IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAD WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THE IMPACT.
AND DEDUCTIBLES MAY PLAY IN
DETERRING BY DETERRING FOLKS
FROM SIGNING UP. FOR DETERRING
THEM FROM USING IT CARE WANTS TO
SIGN UP. WE DID PROVIDE JUST AN
ISOLATED OPTION THAT SAYS WHAT
IF WE JUST USE FUNDS. TO
ELIMINATE DEDUCTIBLES IN OUR- IN
OUR COST SHARING REDUCTION PLANS
SO THAT NOBODY IN THIS PLANT HAS
TO WORRY ABOUT HAVING A
DEDUCTIBLE FOR ANY SERVICES. AND
IN THAT CONNECTION. AN ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE LOWER THAN SOME OF OUR
OTHER OPTIONS. AND NOT JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF A WORD ABOUT THE
RANGE OF COSTS HERE- THESE COSTS
WOULD VARY BASED ON OUR EXISTING
ENROLLEES. MOVING FROM THE PLANS
THAT THEY'RE IN SOME OF THOSE
OLYMPIC MEDAL TIERS BRONZE GOLD
AND PLATINUM. INTO THE SILVER
PLANS WHERE WE OFFER THESE COST
SHARING REDUCTIONS SO IT WOULD
REQUIRE INDIVIDUALS TO MOVE
PLANS- COVER CALIFORNIA TO DO
OUTREACH- AND ALSO. I THINK
PASSED TO- I DO SOME WORK WITH
OUR YOU IN ROLE USED TO GET THEM
INTO THOSE SOBRE PLANS TAKE
ADVANTAGE THAT. THANKS A LOT THE
RANGE OF CARS YOU SEEN TRULY.
AND EXISTING IN. AND TRYING TO
GET THEM INTO PLANS THAT WOULD
GIVE THEM EACH OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSE. OUR LAST SUBSTANCE
FLIGHT HERE CONSIDERATIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION ON TIGHTENING WE
DID APPRECIATE THE MARGINAL
STATUTE TO D. DELVE DEEPLY INTO
OPERATIONS I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
THE DETAIL HERE. BUT WE DID DO
THAT HAS A VERY GOOD DISCUSSIONS
I THINK- THAT GIVEN US. A GOOD
HEAD START ON PLANNING HERE
OBVIOUSLY IF WE TRY TO LAUNCH A
PROGRAM FOR TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD TO
COMPRESSED TIME FRAME AND WILL
NEED A LOT OF DECISIONS. IN THE
FIRST HALF OF THE CALENDAR YEAR-
THAT SAID WE THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE WERE CONSCIOUS OF THE FEDERAL
UNCERTAINTY SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO- PROVIDE OPTIONS
ARE FINE OPTIONS AS WE GET MORE
CLARITY ABOUT FEDERAL FUNDING.
AND BUT WE WILL BE WORKING IN
THE- I'M ON OUR SIDE- TO DO AS
MUCH PREPARATION AS WE CAN SO
THAT IF WE DO HAVE. AND FEDERAL
FUNDING YOU CAN MOVE QUICKLY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT- AND IF
WE DON'T WE CAN BE READY. FOR
POTENTIAL STATE OPTIONS. BUT
THAT'LL STOP THE SLIDES WILL.
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WOULD NOTE TO THE PUB THAT WE-
MAKE SURE WE LIST THOSE SLIDES
BECAUSE SINCE IT WAS OF MUCH
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT IS BEEN-
PUT PUT UP ON THE WEBSITE- BY
APPRECIATE. YOUR PRESENTATION
AND I THINK- YOU KNOW WE
CERTAINLY HOPE THE FEDS ARE ABLE
TO HELP OUT. BUT I KNOW FROM FOR
ME AND I KNOW THE PRO TEM AND I
SERRANO THE BUDGET CHAIR. WE
HAVE A- THE- BIG EMPHASIS. ON
REDUCING POVERTY AND HELPING AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE SO. I
CAN SEE IS. IF WE NEED TO DO.
MOVING VERY QUICKLY TO BE ABLE
TO. HELP AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN WE DO NOT WANT THE
COST OF HEALTH CARE. TO BE
SOMETHING THAT KEEPS PEOPLE.
FROM MAKING SURE THEY GET THAT
PREVENTIVE CARE- AND THEIR DAILY
NEEDS DONE SO IT DOESN'T COST
US. WAY MORE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
SO I APPRECIATE- IRAQ IS LIGHT
AND THAT YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK AT
THIS. AND THAT HOPEFULLY IT
MEANS YOU CAN BE WE CAN BE READY
TO ROLL AS SOON AS WE NEED TO-
AND- THEN WE CERTAINLY COMMITTEE
THAT WILL BE WORKING- THE
FACTORY SO WE CAN MAKE SOME
DECISIONS AS SOON AS WE NEED TO
MAKE THEM. LOOK BETTER YOU CAN
CHECK. I DO HAVE SEVERAL.
MISHAPS WE CAN HEAVILY- ELEMENT
. HOUSING FINANCE AND THEN I'LL
ASK THIS. W. MOREOVER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE
WILL BE ABLE TO FIND A MORE IN
DEPTH ANALYSIS IN THE COMING
WEEKS BUT I DID WANT TO RAISE A
FEW ISSUES FOR CONSIDERATION NOT
ALL FORCE OBVIOUSLY IS THAT IT'S
ABOUT OFFERING SERVICES SOME OF
THESE ARE NOT EXTENDED WOULD
MOST LIKELY BE THE MOST
IMPACTFUL WAY- OF. IMPACTING
AFFORDABILITY- AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT FEDERAL SUBSIDIES ARE
CONTINUED I AM CONSIDERING
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABILITY OPTIONS
ARE FEW THINGS A LOGICAL WHEN
YOU CONSIDER FIRST IS- WHAT THEY
CALL ON- I DRESS IN. INCOME IT
WOULDN'T BE AN WHAT THE WILL THE
ON WITH THOSE GOALS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE GOAL IS TO
PROMOTE FOR ILLEGAL IT CAN
BECOME CONSUMERS FOCUSING ON
APPROACHES THAT TARGET.
CONSUMERS WITH INCOMES BELOW
210050% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE. WHAT
IF THE GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
ABILITY FOR THE BUT THE TWO AND
50% OF THAT P. L. ON INCLUDING
DOES NOT CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR
THE TOTAL COSTS AND REDUCTIONS.
ON THE SIDE TO SOME OF THE ONES
MOST LIKELY TO ENROLL IN THE
BRONZE KINDS CURRENTLY A
DIFFERENT APPROACH MIGHT BE MORE
APPROPRIATE AND THEN FINALLY THE
BATTLE COULD BE TO DRIVE NEW
ENROLLMENT FOR THE SHIFT IN ROLE
IS TO MORE- GENEROUS. PLANS NEXT
FAILED. WEATHER THAN TOP THE
TIME FRAME IS FOR THE- OF
PROGRAM. SO THE CHILDREN COULD
CONSIDER- A ONE TIME PROGRAM. TO
FOR HIM OR SOMETHING GONNA GO.
WHEN YOU ARE GOING TO PROGRAM
ARTISTIC LIST RESEARCH. BUT NO.
FOR BUT EXTRACTION THE MEASURE
COST TO IMPLEMENT THAT PLAN AND
COMMUNICATE THE PROGRAM TO
POTENTIAL. CONSUMERS- WHEN THE
LARGER SAME ALLEN TALKING FOR
COMPARE ON PROBE. AT ALL RESULT
IN A INJURY. FOR WHICH CAUSE
COULD COULD BENEFIT FOR THE PLAN
OR EVEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT MY ROLLING INTO IT. GOING
TO BE WHAT LEVEL OF FUNDING TO
PROVIDE. SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ADDITIONAL COSTS IN THE
REDUCTIONS COULD FIND ASSISTANCE
WITH PAYING FOR THESE ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABILITY OPTIONS THERE'S
ALSO A ONE TIME FUNDING OF THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS SENATE
SIGNED. TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT
COULD BE EXTENDED I WANNA LET
YOU TURN BASIS OR IN THE FUTURE
LEADERS AND THEN FINDING THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER A-
APPROVING ADDITIONAL. GENERAL
FUND REVENUE TO PROVIDE. SO FOR
THESE FOR A- AND THEN FINALLY-
WILL NOT AROUND TYPE OF
KHASHOGGI TARGET THE OPTIONS AND
REPORT GENERALLY FOCUS ON
ELIMINATING OR REDUCING
DEDUCTIBLES OR MOVING CONSUMERS
ENGINE ONE GENEROUS PLANS CAN
IMPACT POSSIBLE TO ALWAYS
INCLUDE THE DEDUCTIBLES. AND THE
MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES.
THE MOST OF THE PLAN OPTIONS THE
BORDER INVOLVED NOT MOVE A LOT
OF TROUBLES. IN THIS ORDER IN
HOLLAND IN PATIENT CARE- I.
JOHNSON WHERE THE GENITALS OF
HIGH. END COVERED CALIFORNIA. I
THINK IT'S TOO MUCH NOT MUCH PAY
CARE OF BENEFIT TO FROM THE READ
OR A DOUBLE HOWEVER THAT IF YOU
DO. A CARE CAN AND PAYING VERY
HIGH CALL. AS A RESULT OF THESE
DOCTORS AND IN ADDITION TO
CONSUMERS PERCEIVED COSTA
DOUBLES CAN BE A DETERRENT TO
ENROLLING PLANS OR SEEKING CARE
INCLUDING SERVICE FOR SERVICE'S
SADDAM DID. NOT NECESSARILY HAVE
TO DOUBLE. IT ALSO IS COSTLY
THAN OTHER THAN SOME OF THE
OTHER OPTIONS THAT WOULD NOT.
REQUIRE THE FULL ELIMINATION OF
DEDUCTIBLES. THERE'S ONLY ONE
OPTION IN THE REPORT THAT. WOULD
MAINTAIN DEDUCTIBLES THAT WOULD
SHIP CONSUMERS INTO THE MORE
GENEROUS PLAN WHICH WOULD WE
GENERALLY WE DO TO DOUBLE THE
ORDER CALDERON MARKETING
EXPENSES BUT THEY WOULD STILL
HAVE TO PAY SOME CHARITABLE.
THIS WOULD SUBJECT TO LOWER
COSTS OF IT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY ON THE LEVEL OF
BENEFIT IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABILITY THAT THE OPTIONS
ARE REMOVED HOLES WOULD HAVE.
BEEN K. BERMAN FINANCING HAVE
ANYTHING. BURKE OTHER CORPORATE
APARTMENT OF FINANCE. ONLY THE
OTHER THE ADMINISTRATION IS IN
THE PROCESS OF EXAMINING THE
OPTIONS PROVIDED IN THE REPORT
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO MONITOR
THE FEDERAL SITUATION- AND WILL
BE DEVELOPING AN OPTIONS
DEPENDING ON THE FEDERAL ACTIONS
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TALK TO
PAM. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
PRECIADO THE PRESENTATION AND
THE DIFFERENT OPTIONS- GUESS.
WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK
WE ALSO SHOULD BE CONSIDERING IS
THAT- BECAUSE ABILITY OF THE
MARKET RATE AND SO COVER
CALIFORNIA'S AN ACTIVE
PURCHASER- IT'S NEGOTIATING THE
RATES. AND THE MORE UNCERTAINTY
THERE IS- USUALLY THE MORE
EXPENSIVE THINGS KEPT HER EIGHT
BECAUSE EACH OF THE PLANS HAS TO
BACON THE UNCERTAINTY INTO THEIR
RATES AND OF COURSE IF THERE'S
MORE UNCERTAINTY YOU'RE GOING TO
BE MORE CAUTIOUS AND- SO I.
THINK THAT- YEAH WE NEED TO TAKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT- I ALSO WAY
TALK ABOUT STABILITY. I THINK
WOULD BE CHALLENGING FOR EXAMPLE
TO PUT. FUNDS IN ON ONE YEAR AND
THEN NOT HAVE THE FUNDS THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AND THEN PULL
BACK ALL RIGHT SO OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. SO
PRECIADO THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN RIGHT NOW I DON'T KNOW WE
CAN WHO KNOWS WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO BUILD BACK BETTER WEATHER
SOME COMPONENT WHAT HAPPENS IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT SAFE
PASSES A BILL THAT BETTER WITH
ONLY ONE YEAR ADDITIONAL TO
THAT. AND SO I THINK WE ALWAYS
NEED TO THINK ABOUT WHAT'S OUR
STATE CAPACITY I MEAN UNLESS DAY
ACTUALLY PASS SOMETHING SAID YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THESE OF THESE YOU KNOW OUT FOR.
FOREVER OR AT LEAST FOR YOU KNOW
SO MANY MANY YEARS- SO THAT IT'S
FARTHER ON THE HORIZON. I GUESS
I WOULD URGE SOME CAUTION IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO SAY YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WE'RE GOING TO.
COMMIT STATE RESOURCES TO MAKE
UP FOR. AS MUCH AS WE CAN. WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF. THE PROGRAM
ENDS AND DOESN'T GET FUNDED
SELLERS WHY DON'T WANT TO DO IS
HAVE PEOPLE YOU KNOW GO IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
WERE YANKING THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDER THEM BECAUSE SUDDENLY TO
PREMIUMS SPIKE RATE AND- YOU CAN
YOU KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN
TERMS OF. PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN.
THE NEWS REPORTS RIGHT THE
COVERAGE I MEAN THE GREAT NEWS
IS WE CAN NOW TELL PEOPLE WHAT
COVERED CALIFORNIA PREMIUMS
ACTUALLY HAVE STAYED. STABLE
INTACT THAT'S BEEN UNDER 1% FOR
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS ETCETERA
THAT'S A GREAT STORY. SO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE THAT STORY IS GONNA
BE REALLY IMPORTANT AND SO THE
FEWER SWINGS WE HAVE SO WHAT IS
I GUESS WHEN THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE. YOU KNOW THE HAVE THE
ANSWER NOT FOR RECOVERY
CALIFORNIA IS THAT- YOU KNOW
WHAT THE I GUESS FOR THESE
OPTIONS AND I GUESS YOU GOT
THREE JOBS AND SO FORTH BUT- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD
BE THE THING THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
LEAD TO THE MOST STABILITY IN
THE MARKET WOULD THAT THAT WOULD
GIVE COVER CALIFORNIA MOST
ADVANTAGEOUS NEGOTIATING
POSITION LET'S SAY ASSUMING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T. PASS
BUILD BACK BETTER. I MEAN I'M
I'M CERTAINLY HOPING THEY WILL
RELEASE THIS COMPONENT OF IT YOU
KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY HOPING
PASSABLE BACK BETTER ALL
TOGETHER BUT THAT'S ANOTHER
STORY. YOU KNOW IT'S A THIS
PARTICULAR COMPONENT THIS
PREDICAMENT DOESN'T HAPPEN AND I
WOULD THINK THAT IF YOU DON'T
PASS IT BY THE TIME WE PASS OUR
BUDGET I DON'T THINK IT'S
HAPPENING IT'S ELECTION YEAR.
BUT WHAT WOULD DO WHAT WOULD
ACTUALLY POSE IN THE BEST
POSITION WHEN IT COMES TO.
NEGOTIATING WITH THE PLANS AND
KNOWING THE PLANS KNOWING THAT
OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAD WE
KNOW WHAT THE CASE MIX WILL BE
RIGHT BECAUSE OF THEIR SHIFTING
THESE DIFFERENT OPTIONS YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT CASE MIX THINGS THAT
HAPPENED AS WELL. SO IT WAS HOW
IS THAT FACTORED IN INTO THE
REPORT AND- WHAT. WOULD YOU SAY
TO THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. AT ANY
. I THINK YOU. YOU IT IN TERMS.
THE LOSS OF PREMIUM SUBSIDIES-
HOW CONSIDER INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMERS WOULD FEEL THAT WHEN
THEY- GET THOSE RENEWAL LETTERS
IN OCTOBER OBVIOUSLY LOOKING AT.
INCREASES IN OUR PLANS LOOKING
AT- ICING FOR THAT UNCERTAINTY
WILL THOSE CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN
ADDED ON TO THE A. R. P. PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES AND DROP- SO I THINK-
LOOKING AT AT STEEP PREMIUMS
SUBSIDIES. IN SOME FASHION- IS
PROBABLY THE THING THAT WOULD-
ABI FOCUSED ON MARKET STABILITY
THE MOST- ARE ENROLLEES THE BULK
OF OUR ENROLLEES ARE ON THE
LOWER END OF THE INCOME SCALE SO
WE DO THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
THAT WE PROVIDE THOSE.
INCREMENTS IN THE REPORTS THAT
YOU CAN SEE WHAT THE COST WOULD
BE TO DO THAT BACK FILLED BY
INCOME GROUPS AND THAT THE BUT
AGAIN AS THE L. A. O. MENTION.
COULD START TO THINK ABOUT
PRIORITIES BY INCOME GROUPS AND
BEEN AND WHERE THE BULK OF OUR
ENROLLEES ARE. THE SORT OF
CUSHION NINE LOS GENERAL TENT
CITIES. AND ADDRESSING THE
UNCERTAINTY THAT YOU'RE PLANNING
TO BUY OR ACTUALLY FOR EXAMPLE
THE LOSS OF THE SUBSIDIES ARE
BIGGEST IMPACT ACTION THE HIGHER
INCOME GROUP BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
ONCE YOU HAD OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SO RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE-
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. PEOPLE
BEYOND 4100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WHICH BY THE WAY
OF COURSE IS THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL SO HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
HIGHER COST OF LIVING. WE'RE NOT
TALKING TO PEOPLE MAKING NESTLE
THAT MUCH MONEY WHEN THEY'RE
4100% OF THAT DIAZ. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THIS OF THE
ALTOGETHER SO WHO KNOWS ALL THE
PEOPLE YOU PICKED UP ABOVE 4100%
PART IN FACT WHEN WE PREVIOUSLY
DID OUR STATE SUBSIDY WE DID.
RECOGNIZE THAT AND WE PROVIDE
SUBSIDIES FOR FOUR HUNDRED TO
SIX HUNDRED. BECAUSE WE KNEW
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE OUT
THERE. WHO I MEAN I GOT REALLY
EXPENSIVE THEY GOT NO SUB ZERO
YOU YOU HIS AND HE HAD A CLASS
RIGHT SO YOU KNOW YOU HAD SOME
SUBSIDY AND THEN HIT 4100% FIVE.
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL EASTENDERS
BASICALLY GOT NOTHING SO WE SAID
OKAY WE'RE GONNA PUT A STATE
SUBSIDY. I KNOWS YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE IDEA OF
SAYING WHAT WE SHOULD FOCUS THE
MONEY ON THE POOREST. BUT I
THINK THAT WAS ALSO PART OF
TRYING TO CREATE A LARGER
MARKET. PLACE AS WELL AS
AVAILABILITY THAT ABSOLUTE
DENTAL I THINK CONTRIBUTED TO
THE BILLETE PARA CALIFORNIA TO
ACTUALLY HAVE KEEP THE LOWER
PREMIUMS WHICH BY THE WAY ALSO
HELPS. OVERALL IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH WE HAVE TO PUT IN FOR
SUBSIDIES IN WE CAN KEEP THE
PREMIUM AMOUNTS- LOWER. IN YOUR
NEGOTIATION CORRECT. ABSOLUTELY
IN. MEANS IN SPEECH THERE-
DEFINITELY THOSE ARE PEOPLE.
SUBSIDIES ARE HIGH. FOR THOSE
HIGHER INCOME GROUPS. AND IT'S
ONE OF OUR LOWEST GROUPS BY
NUMBER THE NINETEEN ROWLEY'S SO.
AN BIGGER NUMBERS OF ENROLLEES
AT THE LOWER END OF THE INCOME
SCALE BUT AGAIN AND THEY WILL
SEE SMALLER LOSSES AFFAIR. WELL-
SO THAT'S PART OF THE TRADE ON
SO THE CONDENSATES AT THE
MARGINS RIGHT. WORK THINGS GET A
MOST AFFECTED SO. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHO WILL GET AFFECTED THE
MOST AT THE MARGINS WITH THE.
ELIMINATION OF THE A. R. P. AND
WHAT DO WE DO WITH STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDIES. ARE OTHER SUBSIDIES
RIGHT TO TRY TO. POLICE PROTECT.
TO MAINTAIN ENOUGH OF A MARGIN
THAT WOULD NOT. IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN OUR PREMIUM AND THAT
YOU KNOW- ADVANTAGE IN
NEGOTIATION AS WELL RIGHT SO I
THINK THAT THE DYNAMIC WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
GREAT BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE
PREMIUMS GO UP THAT DOESN'T JUST
AFFECT. YOUR AFFECTS EVERYBODY
CORRECT. BUT DOES THAT'LL TAX ON
AND THE OFF EXCHANGE MARKET AS
WELL AND WE'RE DEFINITELY
LOOKING AT THAT NOW AS WE
PREPARE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE BEING BACK
CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT ABOUT
POTENTIAL IMPACTS AS A R. P.
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES EXPIRING. SO I
SAW SO I THINK INTO IN TERMS OF
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT. YOU KNOW
WE ALSO NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT'S
WHATEVER WE PROPOSE A SUBSIDY
SPECIALLY IF. WELL TEN FORTY
RIGHT NOW IT'S WELL HOPEFULLY
STILL S. BUT- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
FOR YOU KNOW THE AARP GOES AWAY
. WHAT WE DO THAT WOULD ALSO
ENSURE THAT- WE- MAXIMIZE ACCESS
WHICH ALSO INCLUDES. BETTER
STABILIZATION THE MARKET WHICH
INCLUDES GIVING COVERED
CALIFORNIA THE BEST LEVERAGE FOR
YOUR ACTIVE NEGOTIATION WHICH
WILL TAKE PLACE IN THE SUMMER
AFTER WE PASSED THE BUDGET RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU GO TO THE HEALTH
PLANS AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SAYING OKAY HEALTH PLANS WERE
THE PREMIUM IS GOING TO BE AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE NEGOTIATING
WITH YOU ON THAT AND SO BECAUSE
THOSE PREMIUMS WILL BE WHAT'S-
YOU KNOW. CONGO CROSS THE BOARD
SO- SO ANYWAY I DO SO I HOPE
THAT WE CAN KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WELL I MEAN I SER BELIEVE ME I
WOULD LOVE TO GIVE MORE. THAN A
DEDUCTIBLES ALL THAT STUFF AND-
YOU KNOW I'M JUST I'M NOT SAYING
OPPOSED TO THAT BUT I ALSO BE
SURE WE'RE ALSO CONSIDERING.
WHAT MOVES WE MAKE THAT WOULD
ALSO ENSURE WE HAVE THE LOWEST
POSSIBLE PREMIUMS BECAUSE THAT
WAY WE'RE NOT HAVING TO
SUBSIDIZE THEIR HOMES. BECAUSE
OF LOOKING AT THE PLANS. TO KEEP
THE PREMIUMS LOWER. BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THE CASE MIX IS GOING TO
BE. BETTER THAN THAT THAN WHAT I
THINK WERE EVERYONE'S BETTER
OFF. THAN MY WRONG. BROWN OKAY
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU AND THEN I
GUESS WE DECIDE TO DO I JUST
WANT ONE OTHER REMARK- IN A AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
COVER CALIFORNIA'S DONE AND-
IT'S AN AMAZING GROUP BUT- YOU
KNOW WHEN I CHAIRED THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
ONE OF THE THINGS. BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE OVERSEE CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S A PLACE YOU
KNOW HE'S GOT REQUEST FOR WERE.
EXEMPTED POSITIONSSO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET PAID YOU KNOW HOW
THE CIVIL SERVICE PAY SCALE. THE
END OF THOSE PUSH BACK ON THAT.
YOU KNOW AFTER ALL WE HAVE TO
DEAL TALK ABOUT INCOME
INEQUALITY AND SO FORTH AND-
SOMETIMES YOU'LL TALK ABOUT HOW
MUCH CEOS MAY CONSIDER A- AND
THE HEALTH OF THAT DISPARITY.
AND SO CERTAINLY STATE SERVICE
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW IT'S NOT SO
COMPETITIVE. WITH THE PRIVATE
MARKET- BUT- YOU KNOW I THINK
ONE OF MY THINGS THAT THAT I
JUST ALSO WANTED TO TOUCH ON IS
THAT. CALIFORNIA'S NOTED THAT
THE INCOME COMES FROM TAXES ON
PREMIUMS ESSENTIALLY. AND YOU
KNOW I THINK I UNDERSTAND OR
SEVERAL EXEMPTS DITIONS. IN IN
IN IN THE ORGANIZATION. AND SO
DID I THINK THERE IS YOU KNOW-
WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT- IT'S
NOT SET BY THE LEGISLATURE BUT
WE'RE- HERE TALKING ABOUT
SUBSIDIES FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA. AND CERTAINLY WE'RE
DOING FOR THE DAY- BENEFICIARIES
BUT- BE SURE THAT PAY SCALES ARE
NOT. YOU KNOW EXCESSIVE. IN ANY
ORGANIZATION IN THE STATE. SO.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST A- NO
THINK WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE
SCHOOL OVER A- DOES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DIRTY PAN
AND- THANK YOU- THE DIRECTOR
ABOUT IN. THE L. A. O. AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ALL
THE STAFF HERE. I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES THE PRESENTATIONS FOR
TODAY AND I THINK NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- EIGHTEEN TEARY
ON THE LINE. I AM ONLINE. OKAY
IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS WE IT WOULD BE
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO GET IN THE
QUEUE. AND THEN PUBLIC COMMENTS
WILL BE ONE MINUTE EACH. TIME
YOU SO WE WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS
AND AGAIN IF YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
TO SAY EVERYTHING YOU WANT YOU
CAN ALWAYS EMAIL US. OR CALL THE
COMMITTEE LATER ON. WE ARE
INTERESTED IN YOUR INPUT HOW
MANY DO WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE
OPERATOR- WE ROUGHLY HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE IN THE QUEUE RIGHT
NOW OKAY. AND WE CAN START
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY OKAY LET'S
GET STARTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR- WE HAVE MY NUMBER FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CALLER
HELLO CARE ACT HELLO HELLO CARE
EGGMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
JENNIFER NALLEY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- QUICKLY ON AN
ISSUE FOR WITH REGARDS TO SMALL
WORLD HOSPITALS TIGHTENING
COMPLIANCE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AND HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUES TO TAKE
HOSPITAL I THINK FIFTY AND
RETROFITTING KILEY. HOSPITALS
NOT ONLY NEED TO PROTECT THE
PATIENTS WORKERS AND VISITORS
INSIDE THEY NEED THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING TREATMENT
DURING A NATURAL DISASTER AND-
WE MUST ENCOURAGE ALL HOSPITAL
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH H. HI.
TO ME BOTH TWENTY THIRTY
STANDARD. I DIDN'T THREE THAT
APART OF HEALTH AND ENTER- WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
REAPPROPRIATION OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CREATION
OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. ACCORDING TO THE
UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER MANY
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE JOB BASED
COVERAGE WILL BE MEANINGFUL
RELIEF FOR THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE. BY IMPLEMENTING A
MECHANISM THAT WOULD CURTAIL THE
RISING COST OF CARE WE BELIEVE
IT WOULD RESULT IN A SYSTEM THAT
LOWERS COSTS TO TAXPAYERS. WHEN
PLAYERS AND OUR MEMBERS WHICH
WOULD THEN LOWER PREMIUMS AND
OUT OF POCKET COSTS. LEAVING THE
STATE TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. MANY OF OUR BARGAINING
DISPUTE WHEN WE ARE MEETING WITH
EMPLOYERS DURING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING SH- THANK YOU YOUR
TIME IS DIRECTLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOUR TIME IS UP THANK YOU.
CALLER PLEASE REMEMBER TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
HAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH CONTACT THE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. BOUNCERS AT THE
PROPOSAL PROPOSALS TO FUND COST
SHARING AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE
FOR COVERED CALIFORNIA BOTH OF
THESE WILL MAKE CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR CALIFORNIANS AT A
TIME WHEN MILLIONS ARE FORCED TO
DO IT- RATION CARE DUE TO COST
AND OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY WOULD KEEP
UNDERLYING COSTS DOWN AND
PREJUDICIAL ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY WHICH
CONTINUES TO INCREASE. PRICES
BEYOND INFLATION AND WAGE GROWTH
. RESHAPING OF THE OFFICE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AN LODGED
LEGISLATORS FOLLOW THROUGH AS
WELL. MEANWHILE WE MUST MAKE
PROGRESS TO REDUCE OUT OF POCKET
COSTS COVERED CALIFORNIA
ENROLLEES WHO MAKE ONLY TWO
THOUSAND A MONTH HAVE ANNUAL
DEDUCTIBLE THAT BROACHING FOUR
THOUSAND. OR THIRTY DOLLARS FOR
REGULAR DOCTOR APPOINTMENT. HEY
THE CHAIRS COMMENTS FORWARD TO
PARTNERING TO UPGRADE COST
SHARING HERE IS MOMENT EIGHT
DEDUCTIBLES FOR SUMMER PLANS
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES ARE EXTENDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PERFECT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE AYE NUMBER
TWENTY JULY NUMBER TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SANDERLING MCCONNELL WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE WORK
FORCE PROPOSAL DISCUSSED UNDER
AGE HEIGHT ISSUE TO SEE
EVERYTHING IS ALSO PROPOSING
ALONG WITH ANY OF W. N. F. YEAH
YOU TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
BOXER MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL
WORKERS. INTO MORE BY GRANT
COUNTY AGENCIES AND NONPROFITS
THE WORK WITH COUNTIES TO
SUPPORT FIELDWORK PLACEMENTS WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE EMPHASIS ON
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY THAT
DIRECTOR RIAN BURKE MENTIONED
WILL WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO SHAPE THE
OVERALL PROPOSAL. THE W. DAY IS
ALSO PLEASED TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE HEALTH INFORMATION DATA
EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK ADVISORY
GROUP DISCUSSED UNDER THE AGENCY
ITEM OUR MEMBERS WORK WITH
HIGHLY SENSITIVE INFORMATION
COVERING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS EVERY DAY WE THINK
THE GROUP IS TAKING A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH WOULD YOU WANT TO NOTE
THAT THE TIME WAS LAID OUT IN
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THREE OF THEM
BISHOP. ON CONSIDERING ALL OF
THE NECESSARY CHANGES THAT WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO ENSURE OUR HUMAN
SERVICES CLIENTS DATA ARE
PROPERLY PROTECTED AND THAT OUR
CLIENTS ARE GIVEN CHOICE WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT INFORMATION IS
SHARED ACROSS EVEN FEET THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWO EIGHT. NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON TEARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS BUT
I SAID THAT I'M IN I WORK WITH
ANY STATE GOING TO CANNOT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT IN
THE CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL COAST.
I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT A PROPOSAL LIKE THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH NAVIGATORS WITH THESE
PROPOSALS NAVIGATORS CAN PROVIDE
TRUSTED CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
SERVICES TO ONE OF OUR
POPULATIONS INCLUDING ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS IF WE
DO NOT PASSED PROPOSAL SUCH AS
THESE WE RISK LOSING BUILDING
AND HELP THE COMMUNITY AND
ESTABLISHING GREATER LANGUAGE
JUSTICE NAVIGATOR SPEAK THE
LANGUAGES OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
UNDERSTAND OUR CULTURE
PARTICULARLY FOR INDIGENOUS
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THESE CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND
PROPOSALS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WELL I NUMBER THIRTY THREE AND
LINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ADRIAN SELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD FAMILY SERVICES REPRESENT
A NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION SERVING CHILDREN
AND YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
H. I. ITEMS OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE WE'RE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNDOCUMENTED I
WORK FOR. FIVE ONE SEVEN AS THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
AND YOUTH THE BE ABLE HEALTHCARE
IT'S GROWING WE NEED TO BE MORE
CREATIVE AND EVEN BOLDER AND ARE
BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE MAY BE
MADE. CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS I THINK YOU
KNOW WORKFORCE CRISIS THE BASIC
THE HIRE AND RETAIN QUALIFIED
STOCK. AND I'LL BE THIRTY OF OUR
MEMBERS THEY REPORTED THAT THEY
ARE STRENGTHENING PARTICULARLY
HIGH MAKING THE INTERNAL MEMORY.
WHICH RESULT IN A TRAIN
CONDUCTOR OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN WE NEED THESE
INVESTMENT THE THEFT AND MARK
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO BRINGING
FOR AN ADDITIONAL PROPOSAL
AUGMENT AND COMPLEMENT WHAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED AND WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE ARE GOING
NUMBER THIRTY SIX LINE NUMBER
TWO SIX. GOOD EVENING ACT. AND
WINDY WITH A COW SERVICIOS OF
OUR AND DRUG EXECUTIVE RECKLESS
THREE AT SOUTH USE THE TREATMENT
I UNDER I EACH TIED ISSUE CAN'T
WE ARE AND BOBBY TO AND TRY TO
COURSE AND A DEDICATION ON OUR
STATE I DO WE HAVE BLOCKED THE
TICKET AGAIN PORTION OF THE WORK
FORCE DURING THE PANDEMIC AT THE
SAME TIME MACHINE DEATH BY
OVERDOSE SKYROCKET- BUT
WORKFORCE CRISIS IS CRITICAL AND
WE'RE CURRENTLY EVALUATING
PROPOSAL AND MAY BRING
ADDITIONAL PROPOSAL BOB.
DIGITALLY WE ARE SUPPORTED BY
BOTH BACKING REQUEST UNDER
DAMAGE THE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION ABOUT B. TWO
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER FIVE LINE THIRTY. GOOD
EVENING MADAM AND DR PAN CARNEY
DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
CORN REPRESENTING THE THIRTY
THREE DISTRICT OF MINNESOTA
HOSPITALS YOUR WITH A COMMENT
ON- H. CHI. ISSUE SEVEN THE WORK
FORCE AND HEALTHY CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S.
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA AS YOU
KNOW HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN HIT
WITH- WITH THAT YOU KNOW WORK
SHORTAGES SO WE DO SUPPORT THAT
WITH RESPECT TO THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS WERE VIEWING THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS RECENTLY
PRESENTED AND- WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS THAT. THROUGH
THE PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
LINE THIRTY EIGHT. HI I WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
ONE FORTY ONE FORTY AND ALSO
FORTY ONE FIFTY FOR THE BERKELEY
THE COMMENT ABOUT HOW TO ATTRACT
AND RETAIN WORKERS IN THE HEALTH
CARE CAREERS INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS. IT IS
ASTONISHING TO ME THAT YOU
LAWMAKERS CANNOT CONNECT THE
DOTS ABOUT SHORTAGES IN THESE
PROFESSIONS WHEN YOU FIRED ALL
THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS DUE TO
PHARMA MANDATE. CALIFORNIA IS
LOSING PEOPLE FREE STATE STATES
LIKE NEBRASKA AND FLORIDA ARE
PAYING BONUSES TO HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND NOT FORCING PEOPLE
TO TAKE INJECTIONS BUT THEY DO
NOT WANT. THE AND THEY SAY THIS
IS NOT ROCKET SCIENCE. YOU
LAWMAKERS ARE CREATING THESE
PROBLEMS SO PLEASE JUST STOP
STOP THE MANDATE AND THE MADNESS
AND FOR THE LOVE OF GOD STOP
MANDATING THIS POISON FOR
CHILDREN AND LET THEM TAKE OFF
THE MASK. IF YOU DIDN'T NOTICE
THE TRUCKERS. BASICALLY HOUSE.
WHAT WHY IN YOUR TIME IS UP.
YOU'RE STANDING UP THE- CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE CALLER NUMBER
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS KALRA
HELLO. WE CAN'T THANK YOU. HELLO
YOUR TIME IS STARTED. GREAT I'M
NOT SURE EGGMAN AND MANAGER
MEMBERS APPROPRIATE I GOT NUMBER
FORTY FIVE THAT'S GREAT WELL I'M
CALLING BECAUSE- I HAVE BEEN.
EARNS ABOUT- THIS HOSPITAL I
AGREE A PLAN PROPOSAL- AND I
JUST WANNA GET THIS STRAIGHT
EACH CAR I WANT TO COLLECT MORE
TAXES FROM PERSONAGENS THE FINAL
BILL DATA THAT MIGHT VIOLATIONS
OF FEDERAL LAW FURTHERMORE A
LEARNING. RESEARCHERSCOMPANIES
TO ACCESS TO PATIENT INFORMATION
SO THEY CAN HEAR YOU IF YOU
CANNOT PAY YOUR HOSPITAL BILLS.
I WOULD URGE CAUTION PENDING A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD VIOLATE A
FEDERAL LAW PROTECTING PATIENT
INFORMATION. RICHARD LATELY AND
DOCTOR DR TAN. PLEASE STOP THESE
REGULATIONS AND THESE MANDATE
COULD YOU PLEASE AND THEM. IF
YOU KNOW WHAT. THIRTY CHILDREN.
THE MORE MENTAL ISSUES YOUR TIME
IS UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CALL. WE HAVE MY NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT BY NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT. GO AHEAD PLEASE CALLER
JERRY. ARAMBULA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA KIND I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK WE APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT TOOK PLACE ON
PROPOSAL THAT SEEKS TO CLOSE
RACIAL DISPARITIES INCREASE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND BOLSTER THE STATE OF BIRTH
THE ADDRESS OF PORTABILITY ISSUE
AS A MEMBER OF THE CMHC HEALTH
EQUITY IN QUALITY COMMISSION
WERE EAGER TO MOVE FORWARD I'M
PROGRAMS THAT REALLY HELPS US
GET CLOSER TO MEASURING OUTCOMES
FOR THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
QUALITY OF CARE. OTHER RELATED
TO THE EQUITY INITIATIVES AND
BILL KELLY TO CHANCE I TRY AND
THE SUPPORTIVE OF INCREASING
WORK BURKE THANK WORK CITY
RAMPING UP AFRICAN LANGUAGE
ACCESSIBILITY AND ADVANCING THE
OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY ALL OF WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY BRING THE STATE
CLOSER TOWARD REDUCING BARRIERS
TO ACCESS ESPECIALLY. AMONG BY
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER WE DO A THE
LIVE. TO FUNDING. I TO CONTINUE
IMPORTANT WORK OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH NAVIGATORS OF THE FOR
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR I. ASHLEY WITH
REGARDS TO MENTAL HEALTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TIME IS UP
WORK A COLDER. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS CALLER IS
NOT A LINE FORTY SIX LINE FORTY
SIX HELLO CALLER STARTED AFTER.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEN STEWART
AS CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE COALITION I WISH TO
VOICE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CREATION OF AN OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY ON BEHALF OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION LIVES
REPRESENTED BY OUR ORGANIZATION
WHO. ALONG WITH ALL CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE ACCESS TO THE MOST
AFFORDABLE AND HIGHEST QUALITY
OF HEALTH CARE POSSIBLE. GREAT
INTEREST IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. IS TO PERMIT
OVERSIGHT OF THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA AND ENSURE
THAT THE BENEFITS OF RESULTING
COST REFORMS ARE DIRECTLY SHARED
BY CONSUMERS EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
AND TAXPAYERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLEASE. YEP
LINE NUMBER FIFTY ONE LINE FIFTY
ONE. GOOD EVENING CARE EGGMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
OSAR SANDOVAL NINETY GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS SENIOR MANAGER FOR THE
WORK YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA ALSO KNOWN
AS- THE- I'M CALLING TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE OFFICE OF
DOCTOR AFFORDABILITY.
CALIFORNIANS ARE THAT HAVE BEEN
FACING A HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS LONG BEFORE
THE COOK NINETEEN KIND OF THIS
CRISIS FORCES MILLIONS TO MAKE
THE DIFFICULT DECISION OF
SKIPPING FOR RATIONING CARE DUE
TO THE COST. THIS TAGIC
CIRCUMSTANCE CANNOT CONTINUE WE
ARE ALSO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIANS WHERE THEY ARE WHEN
IT COMES TO INFORMING THEM ABOUT
THEIR HEALTHCARE OPTIONS.
NAVIGATORS ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT BALBOA INFORMATION AND HELP
BRIDGE THE GAP CAUSED BY RACIAL
DISPARITY AND THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY NUMBER
FORTY ONE WINDS. FORTY ONE. THE
HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN DURING THE LIMITED TIME FRAME
TODAY YEAH MY WHAT FILED WRITTEN
RESPONSES TO SPECIFIC BUDGET
PROPOSAL CRITICAL TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP ENSURING PULLING OUT
THE DEVELOPMENT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PRIOR TO COMMENT SHOULD
GENERALLY CMA AT THE COURT OF
THE HEALTH RELATED PROPOSALS AND
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
ARE CONCERNED WHY IN THE DETAILS
AND IMPLEMENTATION. SAM IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
QUALITY HEALTH CARE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AMENDMENTS TO
THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY PROPOSAL IN ORDER TO
BETTER FOCUS ON THE TRUE COST
DRIVERS IN THE STATE WITH HIGHLY
CONCENTRATED HEALTH INSURANCE.
THE MARKET DEMAND SUPPORTED IN
CONCEPT OF THE PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION IN EQUITY GRANTS
AND MUCH OF THE WORK FORCE
PACKAGE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE DEPARTMENT THEMSELVES TO
ENSURE THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PROPOSAL MAXIMIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE THE
MEDICAL WORKFORCE AND OUTSIDE
ACCESS TO CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEGHAN BIRDS ON THE HALF
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY CARE TO
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WE'RE EXCITED THE
COMPOSED AND MENTION DIVERSE
PROVIDE STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH WORKFORCE
SHRANK HI AS COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS CONTINUE TO SERVE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF CODE BUT NINETEEN
THEY REMAIN. COMMITTED TO
DELIVERING ON HEALTHCARE IN THE
CASE OF NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
INCLUDING BURN OUT RETIRING
PROVIDERS AND THE NATIONAL
LIGHTNING LIGHTNING PROVIDER
SHORTAGE HEARING HEALTH CENTERS
TRAIN RECRUIT AND EMPLOY
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND OFTEN CIRCULATIONS IN AREAS
OF HIGH UNMET MEDICAL NEED. AND
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS INVESTING FOR LONGER
PAYMENT SCHOLARSHIP TYPE IN THE
TRAINING PROGRAM STRATEGICALLY
REMOVE BARRIERS FOR STUDENTS TO
ENTER THE PIPELINE AND GROW MORE
CULTURALLY DIVERSE AND THEN WITH
THE GLEE COMPETENT WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CENTER SO
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE THESE
INVESTMENTS. ARE PARTICULARLY IN
THE AREA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THESE PROPOSALS AND
STRENGTHENS THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
LEVINE FORTY FOUR LINES FOUR.
GOOD EVENING LINDA WAY WOULD
WESTERN ON LAW POP WE ARE THE
AGENCIES WORK IN DEVELOPING THE
LANGUAGE JACKSON'S TRADEMARK AND
GET CALLED ENGAGEMENT AND
REQUEST STAKEHOLDERS BE INVOLVED
THROUGHOUT NOT JUST FINAL
ROUTINE WE SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AS
REIGNING IN THE COST OF CARE
CENTRAL TO GETTING TO UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE WE APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT IN WRKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT UNDER EACH SIDE.
INCLUDING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
NURSING AND NURSE MIDWIVES AND
WOULD YOU CRISIS INCLUDE
LICENSED MIDWIVES FONG AB TEN
TWENTY WE SUPPORT THE B. C. P.
AS WELL AS THE NEW CHIEF HELP
DESK WORKLOAD REQUEST WITH THE
COURT THE RESERVE FUND TO BE
USED FOR FUTURE COVER CALIFORNIA
PORTABILITY PROGRAMS WELL WE
HOPE FEDERAL PREMIUM ASSISTANCE
WILL CONTINUE IF IT DOES NOT
STATE AFFORDABILITY. WILL BE
MORE IMPORTANT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE.
BUT MY NUMBERHERE SIX LINES
SIX. GO AHEAD PLEASE. FOR THE
NEXT LINE. WE HAS LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE LINE NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING COLORED EVENING JOSH
DUGGAR ONLY GOOD EVENING JOSH
DUGGAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEM
FIRST ON WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS ARE
FACING EXTREME WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES. WHICH HAVE ONLY
EXACERBATED AND COMPOUNDED BY
THE PANDEMIC SYSTEMS ARE
STRUGGLING RETAIN WORKERS AND
FILL POSITIONS ACROSS THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORTING AND REBUILDING
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE WITH A FOCUS ON EQUITY
THROUGH THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS. AND MAJOR PROVIDERS
OF TRAINING TO THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AN ESSENTIAL THINKING
AT THIS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THESE
PROPOSALS AND HOW WE CAN PARTNER
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO BEST SUPPORT THE
WORK FORCE NEEDS OF HE HEALTH
CARE SAFETY NET. AND ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTY CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT IN ARE PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHILD WELFARE ADULT PROTECTION
AND PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
FINALLY ON THE GOLDEN BUT-
NINETEEN FUNDING WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
PER SURGE STAFFING IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET YEAR AND
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN TESTING
AND TAXING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER A- LINE A. THE
OVERSIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY BY MICHAEL REPLIED TO
THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY COVER CALIFORNIA.
IN TO THE NEXT DOOR NEARLY
EXPENSIVE TO DISEASE AND COST
THE SITE IS ONE OF THE KEY
REASONS PEOPLE LIVING WITH THE
DISEASE STOP HER ALTER THE
DECLINE OF PAYING FARE THE- OUR
THIRTY SHOW THAT IT COSTS.
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE
YEAR. AND DIRECTLY DIRECT COST
FOR SOMEBODY WITH MS- THE TOPIC
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO. UPGRADE IN
COSTS WHICH OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE
OF GREAT BENEFIT TO PEOPLE WITH.
AN ASKED. YEAH ONE PARTICULAR
ITEM WHICH IS COVERED BY THE
PUBLIC CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. WOULD
BE TO- PROVIDE. FOR WHY SHARING
INCREASING AMOUNTS OF PEOPLE IN
THE US. AND OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THEIR MEDICATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION ON US THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE AYE
NUMBER FIFTY. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LARA KNOWLEDGE AGENT ON BEHALF
OF BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA WE
WANTED TO CALL AND IN FACT
THEY'RE APPRECIATION FOR THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDING THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY AND
HIS BUDGET WHICH IS NINE UNDER
AGE HI- WE ARE STILL ARE BEING
IT WILL BE DOING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS POLICY
CENTER WAS INTRODUCED IN TWENTY
TWENTY- WE BELIEVE THE OFFICE
WOULD PUT CALIFORNIA AT THE
FOREFRONT OF TACKLING THE HIGH
COST OF HEALTHCARE. AND MAKE
GREAT STRIDES IN MAKING
HEALTHCARE MORE SUSTAINABLY
AFFORDABLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH TRANSPARENCY HOLDING
ENTIRE DELIVERY SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR CROP GROWTH AND
ENSURING QUALITY OF CARE AND
PATIENT OUTCOMES WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION AS THE
PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS CALLER
LINE TWENTY THREE LINE TWENTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS RACHEL
WATSON I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND I NEARLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND AT RISK THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ON THE PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN
CALIFORNIA WE AGREE WITH DR PEN
THAT WE NEED TO ELEVATE PRIMARY
CARE AND ONE WAY TO DO THIS IS
TO CHANGE THE WAY YOU PAY FOR
PRIMARY CARE IN THE AMOUNT OF
MEDICAL AND THAT ALLOCATED
TOWARDS IT. IN ADDITION WE ASK
THAT YOU PRIORITIZE INCREASING
INVESTMENT IN THE FONG BOB
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN TRAINING
PROGRAM WHICH WILL EXPAND THE
PRIMARY CARE AND HEALTH
WORKFORCE AS MANY FAMILY
PHYSICIANS RECEIVED TO UNDERGO
HOURS OF TRAINING WILL BE A GOOD
HEALTH IN ADDITION REQUEST THAT
YOU MAKE A TECHNICAL FIX THE
THIRTY MILLION ALLOCATION AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUDGET A NEW PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAM. THROUGH
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY SHOULD FOREVER
REASON A PORTION OF THE FIFTY
MILLION NOT BE FULLY ALLOCATED
TO NEW PROGRAM THAT THE FUNDS BE
ALLOCATED TO EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND EXPANSION BOB THAT EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHERING DISCUSSIONS ON BUILT
ON THE PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
WORKFORCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FORTY LINE
NUMBER FORTY. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR LOOK REELING FROM KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF CAL
PACE THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP I'LL BE HAPPY CAL
PACE THE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
OF PROGRAMS OF ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
VISION. HEALTH WORKFORCE
EXPANSION. YOU'RE WATCHING THESE
PROPOSALS AND WE'VE BEEN PLEASED
WITH OUR INITIAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH H. HIGH COUNTRY THAT PIECE
OF THE WORK FORCE NEEDS ARE
INCLUDED. CALLS ON BEHALF OF
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BOLSTER THE
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING
WORKFORCE. ASIAN CODE NINETEEN
RESPONSE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
HAVE CONTINUED TO SERVE AN
EPIPEN FAMILIES OR AT RISK
PREGNANT AND POSTPARTUM
POPULATION AND THEIR INPUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. IT
WOULD HAVE LINE NUMBER. FIFTY
FOUR NINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HEALTH
PUBLIC AFFAIR CALLING ON BEHALF
AND THAT CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO UNDER- THE DEPARTMENT
OF. HELLO ACCESS AND INFORMATION
EACH GUY AND WOULD SUPPORT AN
INCREASE FUNDING TO WORKFORCE
ARGUMENTATION- SPECIFICALLY IN
THE SONG BROWN ACT BUT WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT- CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT FUNDING. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH- HHS AND
EACH HIGHER ON CORRECTING THAT
AND THEY ARE PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS SIMILAR TO- NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANT AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR PROVIDER
COLLEAGUES IN THAT SPACE. WE
ALSO ALSO LIKE- SUPPORT ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE FINDING-
AS WELL AS ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
THE COMPREHENSIVE NURSING
INITIATIVE. AS NURSE MIDWIVES
PROVIDE- MATERNAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND ATTEND OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND BIRDS IN CALIFORNIA
EVERY YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE A NUMBER FIFTH
NINE LINES YOU NINE. YES GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MINING
HISTORY ALONG FROM ASIAN
RESEARCH WHICH INCLUDES HAS
OFFICES IN SACRAMENTO ON LA FOR
OVER FORTY YEARS IT PROVIDED BY
DAHLE DIRECTION EVERYTHING FROM
PUBLIC BENEFITS LIKE MEDICARE
COULD HAVE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS TO THE ASIAN AMERICAN
NATIVE LINE IF YOU THINK I'M IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES IMMIGRANTS.
LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKERS I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT A
PROPOSAL BY THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM IN THE OFFICE
OF HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY THAT
SHE H. W. WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO CRUNCH A BO SUCH AS THEY ARE
I. TO PROVIDE VITAL CULTURAL AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
NAVIGATION SERVICES A MEDIC. CAL
TRUSTED MESSENGERS. FOR THE
UPCOMING. OF POLITICAL MATTER
THE OLDER ADULTS FIFTY. KERN
ROLE HARD TO REACH YOU WHO. FIVE
INTERNET. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY FOR THE REASONS
NOTIFIED TO RECOMMEND FOR TO
TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
SESSION LOW INCOME POPULATION.
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
QUALITY HEALTHCARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. REPLY NUMBER. SIXTY ONE.
GOOD EVENING CARE EGGMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
KRISTOFF MEYER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES. ALL EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STATE HOSPITAL MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE STANDARD. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ITEM
FORTY ONE FORTY ISSUE SEVEN
JOINING TO RECRUIT AND TRAIN
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ADDRESS
TEACHER SHORTAGES SHORTAGES HAVE
LONG PLAGUED THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS WHERE. THEY CAN
SEE RATES TOP 50% FOR THE COMING
MAKE IT CAN BE RATE ALSO LOOKS
LIKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS WE NEED TO DO MORE
TO RETAIN THE EXPERIENCE THAT WE
HAVE AND BOLSTER THE WORK FORCE.
WE HAVE COMMON AND OTHER ITEMS
BUT WILL FOLLOW UP WITH THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE SECOND TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. I HAVE MY
NUMBER THREE TWO. SIXTY TWO.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN AND SCOPE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY AND FOR FUNDING
ADDITIONAL COST SHARING
ASSISTANCE ARE COVERED
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
PROVIDE NUMBER FIFTY THREE LINE
FIFTY THREE. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF AN OFFENSE
MARIO WITH SECTION POLICY OF
COLIN OKAY THE TWO ITEMS THE
FIRST BEING THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY- THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR- AND
DOCTOR PAN AND TERMS OF-
HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
AFFORDABILITY AND WITHOUT
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY-
THE HEALTH. INDUSTRY WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE THEIR
PRICES BE ON INFLATION WAGE WAGE
GROWTH- AND OFFICE OF HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY WOULD TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE WHOLE
SYSTEM I WOULD HAVE THE BEST
POTENTIAL TO ENSURE THE BENEFITS
OF COST REFORMS CAN REACH
CONSUMERS. IN ADDITION WE LIKE
TO- VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
COVERED CALIFORNIA COST SHARING
ASSISTANCE FOLLOWING WHAT WAS
OUTLINED IN THE RECENT COVERED
CALIFORNIA REPORT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD FIND ADDITIONAL COST
SHARING HELP FOR THE RECORD OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE RELYING ON
THE STATE HEALTH CARE MARKET
PLACE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME HAVE A GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHERE MY NUMBER FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT OFFERING
COMMON ITEMS UNDER THE APARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE ACT WITHIN
INFORMATION CULTURE DISTRICT
COURT ISSUED Q. AND SEVEN THE
MAKE VITAL INVESTMENT TO EXPAND
ACT WITH THE CHARACTER WORK FOR
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT AND IN
SEVEN TO PROVIDE NECESSARY
RESOURCES FOR THE SMALL AND
RURAL HOSPITAL RELIEF PROGRAM.
LASTLY WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ON
ISSUE I AM NINE REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OFFICE
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
PARTICULARLY THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH THAT MAY ADVERSELY
IMPACT HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
pCOMMUNITY THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TAX COLOR PLEASE. WE
ARE GOING. SIXTY ONE NUMBERS. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD EVENING ONLY
SAY MANUAL WITH THE NATIONAL
HEALTH LAW PROGRAM WE SUPPORT
THE OPPOSITE HEALTHCARE
AFFORDABILITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
HEALTH INDUSTRY HAS ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
BECAUSE KEEPING COSTS DOWN IS
ESSENTIAL TO ACHIEVING UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ALSO DRUNK
BEFORE AND REDUCING COST SHARING
FOR COVER CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS BACKING IN THE
BALANCE BETWEEN MEDIC CAL AND
COVER CALIFORNIA EITHER
INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE IN JUST OVER
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH
BUT HAVE DEDUCTIBLES APPROACHING. FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
. SURELY IF THAT AND HE THAT
FUNDING NOT CAN. THAT FUNDING
WILL BE CRITICAL TO ENSURE LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME CALIFORNIANS
CAN ACCESS THE CARE THEY NEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE. OKAY
CALIFORNIANS AFFORDABLE BECAUSE
THE INTERNET SB SIX FIFTY FOR
EACH KIND OF WILL BE IN
FINANCING FINANCIAL RECORDS
WHICH WITHIN TRANSPARENT BETWEEN
INDUSTRY THAT ALLOWED TRAVEL ON
TAXPAYER PROBLEMS CHICAGO BRIDGE
A COMPARABLE DR GRANT. NOT ONLY
ANALYZE AND COLLECT THE LOCAL
DATA RETENTION DATA APPRECIATE
LL THE COMPETITION. TONIGHT A
LITTLE. THANK YOU CAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEXICO PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBERS SEVEN SIX SEVEN.
IT'S INTERESTING HOW CAN CALLERS
GET CUT OFF AND OTHERS GET
LONGER AND WE CAN GO SHOULD HE
STAY TO HEAR THE COMMENTS WE
KNOW HE RUNS HIS FORCING POISON
INTO CHILDREN SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
STAY AND LISTEN TO WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE MINDS OF THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE WE'RE SICK OF IT I
BELIEVE. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I DON'T FOR THIS CALLER SOLICIT
GOOD NIGHT FOR NOW THEY GO
ALREADY HAD YOUR ONE MINUTE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YEAH LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN.
GOOD EVENING TO OPT OUT CALVARY
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION TO BE BRIEF
I'LL DIRECT YOU TO THE LETTERS
HE SENT TO THE COMMITTEE AND
MEMBERS REGARDING ON THE ISSUES
UNDER H. CHI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE- BUT JUST
TO CLARIFY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CARE ECONOMY WORK FOR
SUPPORT. PROVIDED ENOUGH BUDGET
ITEM- WE HAVE HAD TO HAVE THE
HASN'T BEEN NOTED OUR HOSPITALS
ARE FACING MORE SCHOOL FORCE
CRISIS IS NOT SEEN IN PREVIOUS
YEARS AS  RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND OTHER ISSUES. AND
THE WORK FORCE. WORKS WILL ALLOW
US TO. EXPAND RETAIN AND RECRUIT
NEW WORK FORCES. THAT
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT FOCUS ON
DIVERSE CANDIDATES ACROSS THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD. IN ADDITION WE
ARE MOVING ON TO THE WHOLE CARE
PORTABILITY WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE CHAIR
THE WHOLE AND THE CHURCH OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE- TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS WE'VE-
TAKEN A QUICK LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE I APPRECIATE THAT
REFLECT SOME OF THE WORK WE HAVE
BEEN DOING. OVER THE LAST YEAR
TO ADDRESS OUR CHIEF CONCERN
OUTLINED IN THE LETTER PROVIDED.
VERY MUCH INCLUDE WORKING FOR
THE WORK. YEAH PROBLEM SHARE
THANK YOU CALLER PLEASE. YOU
HAVE MY NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN LINE
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN. THREE
BILLION SEVEN THEY'LL BE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA COUNSELOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH AGENCIES ARE PRETENDING
THEY KNOW HEALTH. DISORDER
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY AGENCY TO
PROVIDE. HEALTH AND NEARLY EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA WE
ARE THANKFUL FOR THE ABOUT. HOW
ONE EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL AT THE DOLLAR WILL
PROVE CRITICAL IN THE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES INCLUDING.
HOW INTERVENTIONS I NEED FLOOR
WORKFORCE NOW MORE THAN THE
RECORD SHE WORKING WITH
MINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL AND
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
WILL BE AND HOW PROVIDERS. EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
MEXICO PLEASE. HEY WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. THAT WOULD BE LIKE
SIX NINE PLEASE CALL. GOOD
EVENING. THANK GOOD EVENING-
RECOMMEND A FELIX- WITH MATHIS
EIGHT NOW HEALTH WITH EXCHANGE
I'M CALLING ABOUT THE ISSUE ONE-
OVER THE ACCOUNT HHS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHIEF DATA OFFICER
DONALD MONEY AND BOARDED A
REVIEW OF THE IMPORTANT WORK TO
DATE- WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AFFLICTION YOUR ONE ON THE-
STATE DATA EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK-
DIRECTOR HUNTING MENTIONED- THE
STAKEHOLDERS IDENTIFIED THE NEED
FOR STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING TO
BUILD I KEEP YAKKING PROVIDERS
EXACTLY DATA SHARING NETWORKS.
BOTH YOU MENTIONED DR PAN
RAISING QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO BE PART
OF A COALITION THAT WORKS WITH
YOU THE STAFF AND THE AGENCY ON
A REQUIRED IN THE COMING WEEKS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR IS OUR THERE ANY OTHER
CALLS IN THE QUEUE THAT IT THE
NIGHT. THERE ARE NO OTHER IN THE
MAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MONTEREY WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TONIGHT. AND WITH THAT- I WILL
THEN. CONCLUDE THIS SUB THREE
MEETING OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE.